ओके
आई थिंक आई एम लाइव नाउ आई एम लाइव लेट्स
मी चेक ओके आई थिंक आई एम लाइव गाइज़ ओके
सो प्लीज कंफर्म अ हेलो गुड इवनिंग गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ़ यू प्लीज कंफर्म इफ आई एम
अह ऑडिबल एंड विज़िबल
क्लियर आवाज़ क्लियर वीडियो आप सभी को मिल
रही है प्लीज कंफर्म कर दीजिए फटाफट
कंफर्म कर दीजिए। गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते
हे हे गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते
नमस्ते टू एवरीबॉडी
एकदम क्लियर बहुत बढ़िया। चलिए मैं भी एक
बार टेस्ट कर लेता हूं। देख लेता हूं मेरे
साइड से।
आई थिंक आई एम लाइव एंड एवरीथिंग इज गुड
आई थिंक आई एम लाइव
एवरीथिंग इज गुड
गुड गुड चलिए सो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके सो सबसे पहले तो गुड इवनिंग अंड
नमस्ते टू एवरीबॉडी एंड वेलकम टू द क्लास
20 ऑफ आवर एसओसी एल वन फ्री जॉब रेडी लाइव
ट्रेनिंग ओनली ऑन डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी
YouTube चैनल फॉर यू ऑल एंड इस ट्रेनिंग
के थ्रू हम एसओसी एल वन जॉब रेडी बनेंगे
एंड उसके अह लिए प्रिपेयर करेंगे एंड अपने
आप को उस लेवल पे लेकर जाएंगे कि इस
ट्रेनिंग को करने के जस्ट इस ट्रेनिंग को
करने के बाद आप एल1 के इंटरव्यूज एंड एल1
के जितने भी स्किल्स है वह गेन कर सकते
हैं। एंड उसके लिए जो इंटरव्यूज हैं उनमें
आप जाके एंड इंटरव्यूज क्रैक करने की एक
एबिलिटी अपने में रख सकते हैं। सो वो
एबिलिटी आपके अंदर आ जाएगी इस ट्रेनिंग के
बाद क्योंकि इस ट्रेनिंग की क्वालिटी उस
लेवल की रखी गई है कि आपको जरा सा भी कहीं
और जाने की जरूरत ना पड़े। एंड सब कुछ
आपको एक जगह पे इसी जगह पे मिल जाए। एंड
यू गेट टू नो अबाउट एवरीथिंग दैट इज़
रिक्वायर्ड फॉर द एसओसी एल1 जॉब
इंटरव्यूज़। सो जो भी लोग सिंसियर हैं, जो
भी लोग काफी टाइम से हमारे साथ अभी तक
कंटिन्यू कर रहे हैं, शुरू से कर रहे हैं
एंड लाइव में मोस्टली सबसे ज्यादा अ उनके
लिए ये मैं बोलना चाहूंगा जो लाइव में
कंटिन्यू रहते हैं उनके लिए ज्यादा ये चीज़
बेनिफिट देने वाली है, वैलुएबल होने वाली
है आने वाले टाइम में। एंड हम लोग भी उनके
लिए ज्यादा अवेलेबल रहेंगे। क्योंकि मुझे
अब तो लाइव सेक्शन में जितने लोग भी
ज्यादातर लाइव आते हैं रेगुलर उनके नाम भी
ऑलमोस्ट बहुत सारे लोगों का नाम कंटिन्यू
याद हो चुका है मुझे कि कौन-कौन लाइव में
आता है और वो जो टॉप फाइनलिस्ट लिस्ट
देखता हूं तो उसमें भी थोड़ा आईडिया लग
जाता है तो वैसे पता चल जाता है राइट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके नाउ अ यस प्लीज डोंट स्पैम इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट टू एवरीबॉडी एंड आई होप कि आप
सभी लोग ठीक हैं एंड हम स्टार्ट करते हैं
बट उसके पहले मैं आपको एक इंपॉर्टेंट चीज
बता देता हूं डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] का YouTube
YouTube चैनल जो है वो आप सभी लोगों को
ओपन कर लेना होता है। सबसे पहला जो काम है
वो क्या करना होता है लाइव सेक्शन में
जाके एंड कोई सा भी हमारे प्रीवियस एसओसी
की क्लास की वीडियो को ओपन कर लीजिएगा।
इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में चले जाइएगा। यहां
दो लिंक आपको मिलेंगे। एक WhatsApp ग्रुप
का और एक WhatsApp चैनल का। दोनों ग्रुप
को ओपन कर लीजिएगा। एक WhatsApp ग्रुप
आपको मिल जाएगा। दैट इज़ एसओसी ट्रेनिंग की
स्पेशल आपकी ग्रुप है जिसमें कि एसओसी के
इस पूरी ट्रेनिंग की जितनी भी रिसोर्सेज
हैं, नोट्स हैं, पीडीएफ हैं या जो भी
अपकमिंग अपडेट्स हैं या आने वाले आपके
एग्जाम्स या सर्टिफिकेशन या इंटरव्यू से
रिलेटेड जो भी अपडेट्स होंगी सब इसी ग्रुप
में एक्सक्लूसिवली आया करेंगी। एंड एक
हमारा WhatsApp चैनल डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी
जहां लगभग 12,000 डिफ्रॉनिस्टर्स हमारे
साथ जुड़े हुए हैं। इसको फॉलो कर लीजिएगा
क्योंकि हमारी कंपनी से रिलेटेड जितनी
बाकी अपडेट्स हैं चाहे इस ट्रेनिंग की भी
हो या बाकी किसी भी ट्रेनिंग अपडेट्स या
व्हाटएवर आपको यहां मिलने वाला है। तो
इसको फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। ये दोनों चीजें
आपको कर लेनी है सबसे पहले। एंड उसके बाद
आपको आ जाना है Instagram Lindin पे।
Lindin पे आके आप यहां पे मुझसे कनेक्ट कर
सकते हैं। यह मेरी प्रोफाइल है। मुझसे
जुड़ सकते हैं। मुझे फॉलो कर सकते हैं।
एंड यहां पे हमारी डिफ़्रॉनिक्स की भी पेज
है जिसको आप डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च करेंगे तो
आपको डिफ़्रोनिक्स हमारी कंपनी का Lindin
पेज मिल जाएगा। उस पे हमारी कंपनी से
रिलेटेड अपडेट्स एंड जो भी आपको लाइक
व्हाटएवर प्रोग्रेस वी आर डू डूइंग एज़ अ
कंपनी एंड व्हाटएवर अपडेट्स आर देयर। यू
विल बी गेटिंग ऑल दोज़ अपडेट्स ऑन हियर।
जैसे कि अभी रिसेंटली हमने एक रिमोट जॉब
पोस्ट किया फुल टाइम के लिए एंड जो कि आप
यहां पे देख सकते हैं एंड ऐसी चीजों में
पार्टिसिपेट कर सकते हैं। एंड अदर और भी
बहुत सारे अपडेट्स वगैरह आपको मिलते
जाएंगे इस पेज के थ्रू। एंड यह है
Instagram पेज जो कि मेरी खुद की पर्सनल
प्रोफाइल है Instagram की। आप यहां पे आके
मुझे फॉलो कर सकते हैं। मुझसे जुड़ सकते
हैं मेरी डेली लाइफ अपडेट्स के लिए। वैसे
मैं इतना फ्रीक्वेंट नहीं रहता हूं। डेली
अपडेट नहीं करता हूं। बट स्टिल यू कैन गेट
टू नो मी। एंड ये डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी हमारा
Instagram पेज हमारे कंपनी का पेज है जहां
पे लगभग 500 लोग हमसे जुड़े हुए हैं। यहां
पे इंफॉर्मेशनेशन रील कंटेंट्स वगैरह ये
सब आपको मिल जाते हैं। ये हमारा एक्स का
पेज है डिफरेंस एकडमी हैंडल के साथ। आप इस
पे हमें आके फॉलो अप कर लीजिएगा। ये हमारी
वेबसाइट है जिस पे आपको सारी अपडेट्स
वगैरह मिलती रहेंगी। यह नंबर है जिस पे आप
हमसे कोई भी क्वेरीज, कोई भी क्वेश्चन हो
WhatsApp के ऊपर पूछ सकते हैं। एकडमी पे
जाके आप हमारे जो कोर्सर्सेस हैं उनको
एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं जो हमारी तरफ से
आपको ऑफर किए जाते हैं। एंड दैट्स इट फॉर
दिस
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सोशल हैंडल्स। सो ओके अब हम आज की जो सेशन
स्टार्ट करेंगे वो सेशन आज का जो है थोड़ा
सा थोड़ा सा साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन
की ट्रेनिंग बहुत जल्दी आएगी। एंड
अनाउंसमेंट आपकी आने वाली है। मई में ही
आएगी। आपके इसी मंथ में आपकी साइबर क्राइम
इन्वेस्टिगेशन की आपकी जो ट्रेनिंग है
लाइव ट्रेनिंग नेक्स्ट बैच की अनाउंसमेंट
आने वाली है। तो उसके लिए वेट कीजिए। बहुत
जल्द आने वाली है। ठीक है? ओके नमस्ते।
गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग।
ओके गुड इवनिंग। चलिए तो लेट्स स्टार्ट।
अभी इंटरव्यू क्वेश्चंस की रिक्वायरमेंट
नहीं है। जब होगी तो मैं आपके लिए ला
दूंगा। आज की जो गाइस टॉपिक है देखो आज के
टॉपिक्स में आप ये स्लाइड्स देखोगे ना
लगभग 31 स्लाइड्स हैं। 30 स्लाइड्स हैं
लगभग आज के आज के सेशन के लिए। एंड ये
स्लाइड्स इसलिए हैं इसको इससे ज्यादा डरना
नहीं है क्योंकि आज की टॉपिक बहुत ही
ज्यादा बहुत बहुत बहुत बहुत बहुत बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। एंड बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक है जिसमें आपको मजा भी
आएगा। खैर पढ़ने में। हालांकि हर सेशन को
मैं इंटरेस्टिंग बनाने की कोशिश करता हूं।
आज का वैसा ही बहुत ही खास बहुत ही
इंटरेस्टिंग है। तो आज हम बेसिकली अ
Windows के इवेंट लॉक्स के बारे में पढ़ने
वाले हैं। Windows के प्रोसेससेस के बारे
में पढ़ने वाले हैं। एंड Windows के
सर्विसेस के बारे में पढ़ने वाले हैं। सो
देयर आर थ्री थिंग्स दैट वी आर गोइंग टू
कवर इन टुडे सेशन एंड हम काफी इन डेप्थ
एंड एसओसी लेवल की जो हमें इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
चाहिए, एसओसी लेवल की जो नॉलेज चाहिए, उस
तरीके से हम आज की क्लास को खत्म करेंगे।
ठीक है? तो आपको मजा आएगा
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आज की क्लास में
क्योंकि इवेंट लॉग्स को पढ़ना या लॉगिंग
को समझना एसओसी
जो एनालिस्ट होते हैं उनके लिए यह वही बात
हो गई कि नदी को पार करना है तो नाव या
बोट या आपके पास कोई ऐसी चीज होनी चाहिए
जिस पे कि आप बैठ के या लेट के या चढ़ के
या खड़े होके नदी को पार कर जाओ। अब नदी
पार करने चले गए तो स्विमिंग भी आनी
चाहिए। या तो अगर बोट नहीं है तो स्विमिंग
आती हो। अगर नदी बहुत बड़ी हो तो स्विमिंग
से भी काम नहीं चलने वाला है। राइट? तो
कुछ ना कुछ चाहिए। तो उसी तरीके से ये
टॉपिक्स एसओसी के अ अगर आपको एसओसी
काइंड ऑफ़ थिंक कि इसमें अच्छा करना है,
एक्सेल करना है। सो यू नीड टू कवर दीज़
पर्टिकुलर टॉपिक्स। राइट? चलिए, अब हम
इसको आगे की तरफ ले चलते हैं। जस्ट अ
सेकंड।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओके।
ओके। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सो सबसे
पहले हम स्टार्ट करते हैं बिफोर दैट लेट
मी डू वन थिंग।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके
चलिए
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सबसे पहले द फर्स्ट थिंग कि हम Windows
इवेंट लॉग्स के बारे में तो पढ़ेंगे अभी
बहुत कुछ है हमारे अभी इस पर्टिकुलर सेशन
के लिए बट समझना ये है कि एक्चुअली इवेंट
लॉग्स Windows का जो इवेंट लॉग होता है वो
होता क्या है? व्हाट आर इवेंट लॉ्स? व्हाट
आर इवेंट लॉग्स? देखो इसके नाम में ही
इसकी पूरी डेफिनेशन है। आपको ज्यादा दिमाग
लगाने की जरूरत नहीं है। एव्री डेफिनेशन
मतलब एव्री अ थिंग इज इट्स नेम। इवेंट को
जो लॉग करता है या किसी भी तरह के इवेंट
को लॉग करने वाला किसी भी तरह का इवेंट या
कोई भी इंसिडेंस हो रहा है उसको लॉग जो कर
देता है वही इवेंट लॉगर कहलाता है या
इवेंट लॉग्स होता है। ठीक है?
इग्नोर मत करो सर। ट्रेनिंग जब मैं
क्लासेस दे रहा हूं तो आपको इग्नोर ही
करूंगा। क्लासेस के टाइम में सिर्फ
क्लासेस आपके क्वेश्चंस नहीं ले सकता। सो
आपने जो क्वेश्चन पूछा है जॉब इंटरव्यू
कॉल नहीं आ रहा है सर प्लीज हेल्प। तो
इसमें मैं आपकी कोई हेल्प नहीं कर सकता
हूं क्योंकि अभी ट्रेनिंग चल रही है। आप
ट्रेनिंग के बाद जब चैट वाली चीजें देखता
हूं तो उस टाइम में पूछा करो। बीच में
आपको मैं इग्नोर ही करूंगा। ठीक है? कोई
भी चैट होगी वो मैं इग्नोर कर दूंगा। मैं
बस देखता हूं कि आप लोग एक्चुअली रिप्लाई
कर रहे हैं कि नहीं, प्रेजेंट हैं कि
नहीं, इंटरेक्ट कर रहे हैं कि नहीं। उसके
अलावा मैं आपके आंसर नहीं कर सकता। अगर
हां कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट कुछ होगी इस ट्रेनिंग
के रिगार्डिंग तो जरूर आपको आंसर करूंगा।
ठीक है? उसके लिए बेफिक्र रहिए। चलिए तो
प्लीज आस्क एनी डाउट आफ्टर द सेशन क्योंकि
उसमें सेशन के बीच में डिस्टरबेंस पैदा
होती है। ठीक है? दैट्स व्हाई। सो अगर
आपको पूछना है तो सेशन के बाद में आप पूछ
सकते हैं। या तो फिर आप सेशन को देखिए
पहले। ठीक है?
ओके। सो
Windows [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इवेंट
लॉन्ग लॉग्स आर जस्ट नॉट जस्ट लॉग्स।
इवेंट लॉक्स आर नॉट जस्ट लॉग्स। दे आर द
फॉरेंसिक टाइमलाइन ऑफ एवरीथिंग हैपनिंग
इनसाइड Windows। Windows के अंदर जितनी भी
चीजें जितनी भी चीजें हो रही हैं, जितनी
भी चीजें अकर कर रही हैं, उन सबका एक
फॉरेंसिक टाइमलाइन है आपका Windows इवेंट
लॉक। बस सिंपल सा फंडा है। फॉरेंसिक्स
टाइमलाइन का मतलब होता है कि एक तरह से आप
ऐसे बोल सकते हो काइंड ऑफ कि
जैसे डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक्स या फॉरेंसिक्स में
आप
एक-एक चीज की गहराई तक जाके उसकी
इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल के उसके रूट कॉज को पता
लगाते हो ना वही सेम चीज वही सिमिलर
टाइमलाइन जो है आपका एक तरह का आप मान
सकते हो जो भी आप सिस्टम पे करते हो वो
पूरी की पूरी एक टाइमलाइन एव्री टाइमलाइन
ऑफ व्हाटएवर यू इज़ हैपनिंग व्हाटएवर इज़
अकरिंग ऑन योर सिस्टम आपके Windows पे कुछ
भी हो रहा है ना इवन आप लॉग्स को क्लियर
कर रहे हैं लॉग्स को रिमूव कर रहे हैं वो
भी इसी का पार्ट है वो भी इस टाइमलाइन का
पार्ट है। एंड इवेंट लॉग्स लॉग्स
एवरीथिंग। तो अगर किसी को इवेंट लॉ्स
अच्छे से चेक करने आती है, किसी को इवेंट
लॉ्स अच्छे से समझ में आती है तो वो बहुत
कुछ कर सकता है। गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते। बहुत
कुछ कर सकता है। चलिए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब आज के सेशन को एकदम ध्यान से देना है।
ध्यान से देखना है। दिमाग खोल के देखना
है। बिल्कुल भी
डिस्ट्रैक्ट नहीं होनी है। ठीक है? एव्री
एक्शन जनरेट्स टेलीमेट्री। ठीक है? हर
एक्शन जो है ना एक जो भी आप एक्शन लेते हो
उसमें एक इवेंट जनरेट होता है। बस इसका
मतलब अभी यह समझो जितने भी आप जो भी आप
एक्शन लेते हो उसमें एक इवेंट जनरेट होता
है। ठीक है? जैसे कि आप यूजर लॉगिन अगर
कोई कर रहा है तो इवेंट जनरेट हुआ।
प्रोसेस कोई स्टार्ट हुआ इवेंट जनरेट हुआ।
सर्विज स्टार्ट हुई इवेंट जनरेट हुई।
पॉलिसी चेंज हुआ तब भी इवेंट जनरेट हुई।
इन एव्री काइंड ऑफ़ एक्शन देयर इज़ एन इवेंट
दैट इज़ बीइंग जनरेटेड। दैट्स इट। ओके
गौरव। वेयर लॉग्स आर स्टर्ड। ये लॉग्स
स्टोर कहां होते हैं? तो इसका एक पाथ होता
है Windows के सिस्टम 32 में विन ईवीटी
एंड लॉग्स। इसमें ये जो है स्टोर होते
हैं। लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज़ द पाथ
सीई में चलेंगे। Windows चलेंगे। सिस्टम
32 में चलेंगे। एंड यहां पे वी विल सर्च
फॉर विन ईवीटी। यह वाली यह वाली
डायरेक्टरी होती है। ठीक है? विन ईवीटी।
अब इस डायरेक्टरी को ओपन करेंगे तो यहां
पे आपको दो
डायरेक्टरीज अदर सब डायरेक्टरीज मिलेंगे
लॉग्स एंड ट्रेस फॉर्मेट। तो लॉग्स के
अंदर जब जाएंगे तो यहां पे हमारे जितने भी
लॉग्स हैं वो सारे जो भी जनरेट हो रहे हैं
वो सारे आपको दिखेंगे। अब ये लॉग जो है आप
डेट वाइज देख सकते हैं। द करंट लॉग सबसे
लेटेस्ट लॉग जो है वो 55
55 2026 मतलब आज का है एंड टाइमिंग 76
मतलब अभी थोड़ी देर पहले का है। एंड ये
साइज जो है 18500 KB के आसपास का ये अह
जनरेट हुई है। ये जनरेट क्या हुई है?
एप्लीकेशनx
18 MB की है ये कोई एप्लीकेशन मतलब अभी जो
अभी एप्लीकेशन से रिलेटेड कोई इवेंट जनरेट
हुई है उसका ये पूरा लॉग है। ठीक है? उसी
तरीके से यहां पे कुछ ट्रेस फॉर्मेट
डायरेक्टरीज होती हैं जिसमें कुछ अलग
तरीके की चीजें स्टोर होती है। बट फिलहाल
हम लॉग्स के ऊपर यहां पे बात कर रहे हैं।
तो Windows के अंदर में ये एक लोकेशन होती
है जहां पे सारे लॉग्स जो हैं आपके वो
स्टोर्ड होते हैं जो भी जनरेट होते हैं।
ठीक है? इनका फाइल फॉर्मेट जो होता है
ईवीtx होता है जो कि लाइक एक एक जेरिक
एक्सटेंशन है जो कि इवेंट्स को डिनोट करता
है। अब ये क्यों क्रिटिकल है आपके बीइंग
एन एसओसी व्हाई इवेंट लॉक्स आर क्रिटिकल
सिंपल व्हाई व्हाई इट्स क्रिटिकल क्रिटिकल
क्योंकि लॉग्स जो है वो आंसर करते हैं किस
चीज का? हु डिड व्हाट व्हेन फ्रॉम वेयर
एंड हाउ ये आंसर्स मिलते हैं आपको लॉक्स
के थ्रू। ये आंसर्स बहुत ही ज्यादाेंट
होते हैं फॉर एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट। स्पेशली
एल1 जो पोजीशन है आपका या होने वाला है
उसके लिए ये क्या होते हैं? आंसर्स आपके
लिए बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। बीइंग एन एसोसिए
एनालिस्ट जब भी आप कोई लॉग्स पे काम कर
रहे हैं तो आपको यह आंसर्स खोजने हैं। हु
डिड व्हाट? किसने क्या करा? कब करा?
फ्रॉम वेयर कहां से करा एंड हाउ कैसे करा?
इनके आंसर्स आपको खोजने हैं। जब इनके
आंसर्स आपको मिल जाएंगे तो समझो कि आपने
सारी फाइंडिंग्स एंड इन्वेस्टिगेशन
प्रॉपर्ली कर ली है। एंड व्हाटएवर यू हैव
टू अ गेट यू हैव ऑलरेडी गॉट दैट। मतलब
आपको वो चीजें मिल चुकी हैं जो चीजें आपको
चाहिए थी। एज सिंपल एज दैट। अब Windows
लॉगिंग आर्किटेक्चर को थोड़ा समझते हैं।
Windows लॉगिंग आर्किटेक्चर एग्जैक्टली
किस तरीके से होता है? अब यहां पे जो ये
आपको दिख रहा है
इमेज दिख रहा है। हो सकता है आपको ये इमेज
उतनी क्लेरिटी के साथ ना मिले। तो मैं एक
काम कर देता हूं। मैं इसको कॉपी करके
एंड वर्ड में पेस्ट पेस्ट करते हैं। इसको
थोड़ा सा ज़ूम इन अ
कर लेंगे। आई थिंक ज़ूम इन तो हो ही जाएगा
यह वर्ड में पहले से ही।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] ओके।
या इट्स ज़ूम्ड इन आई थिंक।
ठीक है। बढ़िया। तो ये जो है ये सोर्स हैक
द बॉक्स सोर्स है इसका। यहां पे मैं आपको
द एनाटॉमी ऑफ़ Windows इवेंट ऑफ़ अ Windows
इवेंट लॉग। एक इवेंट लॉग है। उसका मैं
आपको पूरा यहां पे ब्रेकडाउन दिखा रहा हूं
इसके थ्रू इस इमेज के थ्रू। ठीक है? ठीक
है? किस तरीके से ये चीजें काम करती हैं।
कोई इवेंट लॉ कैसे काम करता है उसको आप
देखिएगा। ठीक है? तो सबसे पहले जो है कुछ
इस तरीके से यहां से स्टार्ट होती है।
देखो यहां पे यूजर है आपका। यहां जो यूजर
कोई बैठा हुआ है। ठीक है? द यूजर अकाउंट
दैट वाज़ लॉक्ड ऑन दैट वाज़ लॉक्ड ऑन व्हेन
द इवेंट अकर्ड। तो ये एक शुरुआत यहां लॉग
नेम से यूजर तक की पूरी एक जर्नी की आपको
मैं पूरा जर्नी जो है वो आपको बता रहा हूं
यहां पे। ठीक है? एक इवेंट लॉग का। तो
सबसे पहले यहां पे लॉग नेम की हम बात करते
हैं। लॉग नेम से लेके एंड यूजर तक की हम
पूरी बात करेंगे। लॉग नेम द नेम ऑफ द
इवेंट लॉग। उसके बाद सोर्स होता है द
सॉफ्टवेयर दैट लॉग्ड द इवेंट। यानी जो
सॉफ्टवेयर ने इस पर्टिकुलर उस इवेंट को
लॉग किया है इसके बारे में बात होती है।
देन होती है हमारी XML डाटा या करेक्ट
करेक्ट। इट देन होती है ये हमारा इसी को
बोलते हैं एनाटॉमी। मतलब एनाटॉमी ऑफ़
Windows इवेंट लॉग का मतलब हो गया कि एक
कोई लॉग है। ठीक है? एक कोई लॉग जनरेट
मतलब सेव हुई है या आपकी कलेक्ट हुई है।
ठीक है? तो ये पूरी लॉगिंग किस तरीके से
हो रही है? किस तरीके से एक-एक स्टेप पे
वो लॉगिंग हो रही है। उसी के बारे में हम
यहां पे जान रहे हैं। ठीक है? तो सबसे
पहले लॉग नेम आपकी हो गई। इस तरीके आपके
इन्वेस्टिगेशन में काफी हेल्प करेगी।
बीइंग एन एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट बीइंग एन एल1
आपके या इंसिडेंट रेस्पोंडर भी हैं आप तो
आपके साथ ये बहुत ज्यादा ये हेल्प करने
वाली है। तो लॉक नेम इवेंट लॉ सोर्स द
सॉफ्टवेयर दैट लॉक द इवेंट जो सॉफ्टवेयर
है जिसने लॉक किया इवेंट को XML डेटा ऑल द
इनेशन अबव इनेशन इज़ आल्सो इंक्लूडेड इन एन
XML फॉर्मेट। तो एक्सml फॉर्मेट में डेटा
आपकी प्रेजेंट रहती है सारे। इवेंट आईडी अ
यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर फॉर द इवेंट। अब देखो
इसमें एक इवेंट आईडी भी होता है। जब भी
आपका कोई इवेंट होता है जनरेट तो उसकी एक
इवेंट आईडी जनरेट होती है जो कि यूनिक
होता है। ठीक है? दैट्स यूनिक। ठीक है
सर सॉरी बीच में मेरा एग्जाम था तो मैं
थोड़ा स्लो हो गया था। अभी मैं थोड़ा
क्लास पीछे हूं। मुझे इस पूछना था कि
मैंने वो क्लासेस खत्म करूं या फिर अभी
अभी कंटिन्यू करो और वो क्लासेस जल्दी
खत्म करो। अभी कंटिन्यू कर लो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है। बट वो क्लासेस भी जल्दी खत्म
करो। ठीक है? XML डेटा के बाद इवेंट आईडी
जब भी कोई इवेंट जनरेट होती है तो उसकी एक
आईडी भी जनरेट होती है जिसको हम इवेंट
आईडी जो कि एक यूनिक नंबर होता है। यूनिक
आइडेंटिफायर होता है। फिर टास्क कैटेगरी अ
वैल्यू और नेम दैट एक्सप्लेंस द पर्पस और
यूज़ ऑफ़ द इवेंट। मतलब उस इवेंट का एक
पर्पस। ठीक है? एक पर्पस या
उसका मान लो कि यूज़ पर्पस हो गया या यूज़
केस हो गया। उसको जो एक्सप्लेन कर देता है
उसको हम टास्क कैटेगरी बोलते हैं। वो
टास्क कैटेगरी होता है। टास्क कैटेगरी का
मतलब है एक ऐसी कैटेग एक ऐसी जगह जहां पे
उस इवेंट का पर्पस या फिर एक यूज़ जो है वो
पता चल रहा हो। फिर कंप्यूटर द नेम ऑफ़ द
कंप्यूटर वेयर द इवेंट अकर कंप्यूटर नेम
जो होता है आपका होस्ट नेम वगैरह जैसे आप
सीएमडी वगैरह टाइप करके होस्ट नेम होस्ट
नेम लिखते हो ना होस्ट नेम क्या आपके
कंप्यूटर का नाम क्या है? डिन जैसे यहां
पे ये डिफरॉन स्पीशी है तो ये उसी की बात
हो रही है यहां पे कंप्यूटर का नाम लेवल द
सीवियरिटी ऑफ़ द इवेंट इवेंट की सीिवियरिटी
क्या है ये सब हम अभी जानेंगे भी आगे हम
आगे अभी इवेंट आईडीज के बारे में की
इंपॉर्टेंट इवेंट आईडीज क्या होती है उसके
बाद इसके अलग-अलग टाइप्स कौन-कौन से चीजें
होती है वो सब जानेंगे तो अभी बस ये
ओवरव्यू मैं आपको दे रहा हूं। ठीक है
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] अभी
ओवरव्यू के लिए दे रहा हूं। हां हां
बिल्कुल भाई
सॉरी फॉर द इंटरप्शन व्हाट्स योर ओपिनियन
ऑन क्ल क्लाउड का माइथ माइथोस का ओपिनियन
कुछ भी नहीं है मतलब ओपिनियन मैं क्या
बताऊं वैसे तो बहुत लोगों ने इंटरव्यू
इंटरनेट पे इसके बारे में ऑलरेडी बहुत कुछ
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको दे ही दिया होगा आपको मिल
भी गया होगा लेकिन मुझे एक गिमिक टाइप लग
रही है थोड़ी सी अभी मे बी क्योंकि अभी
इनका बहुत कुछ बिनेस एक्सपेंशन और बहुत
कुछ होने वाला है आने वाले टाइम में तो
शायद यह उस पर्पस से कर रहे हैं। लेकिन
ऐसा नहीं है कि ऐसी चीजें नहीं बन सकती
हैं। ऐसा नहीं है कि ऐसी चीजें नहीं
आएंगी। इन फ्यूचर आराम से आ सकता है। अगर
यह ऑलरेडी आ चुका है तो इट्स डेंजरस। इट्स
अ मैटर ऑफ़
लाइक से मैटर ऑफ़ थोड़ा सा
थॉट। मैटर ऑफ थॉट मैटर ऑफ इसको आपको थोड़ा
सा समझना पड़ेगा कि एग्जैक्टली
एग्जैक्टली
अगर ऐसी चीज एक्सिस्ट कर रही है या उसको
रोकी गई है या करेगी भी आगे चलके तो इट
विल बी अ लिटिल बिट ऑफ डेंजर इट विल बी
लिटिल बिट इट विल बी डेंजरस फॉर एव्री
टाइप ऑफ
टूल्स एंड टेक्निक्स एंड कंपनीज़ एंड
प्रोग्राम्स एंड एवरीथिंग एवरीथिंग हर चीज
को इंपैक्ट करेगी बहुत ज्यादा इंपैक्ट
करेगी एंड इट विल बी नॉट गुड इट विल नॉट
बी एब्सोलुटली गुड ये चीजें अच्छी नहीं है
ये चीजें खराब हो रही
ठीक है? एंड मैं सीधा-सीधा इतना बता सकता
हूं आप लोगों को कि क्लाउड माइथोस जैसी
चीज अगर रियल में आ चुकी है। अभी एग्जैक्ट
किसी को भी नहीं पता। सच बता रहा हूं मैं।
यह बोला जा रहा है उनके तरफ से
स्टेटमेंट्स एंड न्यूज़ के थ्रू आ रही है।
फैलाया गया है इसको जो भी है। बट अगर
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अभी ऐसा है
भी या अगर आने वाले टाइम में ऐसा निकल के
आ रहा है तो इट विल बी डेंजरस।
ठीक है? यह काफी डेंजरस हो सकता है। एंड
क्लॉड माइथोस ही नहीं और बहुत सारे मॉडल्स
आएंगे आने वाले टाइम में जो डेंजरस होगा।
तो वी शुड स्टॉप एआई एट दिस पॉइंट। एआई को
बहुत ज्यादा इससे ज्यादा एक स्ट्रेच मत
करो। आर्टिफिशियल जनरल इंटेलिजेंस की तरफ
ज्यादा मत बढ़ो। जनरेटिव एआई पे ज्यादा वो
मत करो। क्योंकि वो कहीं ना कहीं इफ़ेक्ट
करेगी। अब ह्यूमन ह्यूमंस को शांति पसंद
नहीं होता है। पता है ना? जब शांति होती
है जिंदगी में तो हमें हमें दिक्कतें होनी
शुरू हो जाती है। अरे कुछ तो किक नहीं मिल
रहा। कुछ तो तूफानी करना है। तो यह ऐसे
तूफानी काम कर रहे हैं ह्यूमंस कि उसी
तूफान में उड़ जाएंगे एक दिन और पता भी
नहीं चलेगा। ह्यूमंस आर क्रिएटिंग देयर ओन
डिस्ट्रयर्स। सिंपल सा फंडा है। उस
डिस्ट्रयर पर पूरी काम कर रहे हैं, मेहनत
कर रहे हैं, टाइम दे रहे हैं, पैसा लगा
रहे हैं। पूरी पूरी कंट्री उस पर पैसा लगा
रही है। सब कुछ कर रही है। और एक दिन पता
नहीं शायद वही ह्यूमंस को डिस्ट्रॉय कर
देंगे। सो दीज़ आर वेरी डेंजरस थिंग्स। आई
आई आई मैं एक्चुअली सपोर्ट नहीं करता कि
एआई को हम एक नेक्स्ट लेवल पे एक्सटेंड
करें। एक पर्टिकुलर लेवल तक जाके और
सैचुरेशन आना चाहिए उसमें और उसको रोकना
चाहिए। फिर उसको यूज़ करो अपने काम के अपने
यूज़ केसेस के लिए, अपने काम को आसान बनाने
के लिए। ऐसा मत उसको डेवलप ऐसा लेवल पे
लेकर मत जाओ कि जहां पे तुम्हें किसी की
जरूरत ही ना पड़े। बैठा एक सिस्टम पे एक
बंदा बैठ के पूरे सिक्योरिटी हैंडल कर ले
कंपनी की। क्या होगा बाकी लोगों के क्या
होगा जॉब्स की? और क्या होगा अगर वो एआई
फ्यूरियस हो गया। वो एआई को अच्छा नहीं
लगने लगा। फिर सो इट्स इट्स नॉट गुड।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़][गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
मैनुअल क्या हुआ? एi एi माइथ से मैनुअल
छोड़ो। ऑटोमेटिक छोड़ो। हर तरह के पेन
टेस्टिंग पे इंपैक्ट पड़ सकता है। पड़
सकता है। बट अभी तक कुछ क्लेरिटी नहीं है।
तो अभी अभी क्लेरिटी के अलावा मैं ज्यादा
कुछ नहीं बोलूंगा इस पे। आई एम आल्सो
रिसर्चिंग ऑन दैट पर्टिकुलर थिंग्स एंड
रीडिंग एंड ऑल। तो कभी कुछ क्लेरिटी के
साथ अगर कुछ मैं समझ पाया अच्छे से तो
आपको मैं वीडियो के थ्रू जरूर समझाऊंगा।
बहुत ही डिटेल वे में समझाऊंगा। थोड़ा
मतलब थोड़ा अच्छे इफेक्टिव वे में ताकि
आपको एक्चुअली समझ में आए कि एक्सैक्टली
है क्या ये। ठीक है?
चलिए तो यहां पर अभी बैक टू द बैक टू
पवेलियन यहां पर आ जाते हैं। ज्यादा
इधर-उधर की बातें नहीं करते। इधर-उधर की
बातें मुझे पता है आपको बहुत मजा आता है।
बट अभी आ जाते हैं एसओसी पे। तो यहां पे
टास्क कैटेगरी का मैंने बता दिया कंप्यूटर
नेम होता है। देन लेवल ऑफ़ सीवियरिटी होती
है। लॉक्ड द डेटा एंड डेट एंड टाइम व्हेन
द इवेंट वाज़ लॉक्ड। मतलब एग्जैक्ट डेट एंड
टाइम जहां पे इवेंट को लॉक जिस डेट और
टाइम में इवेंट को लॉक किया गया था।
कीवर्ड्स होते हैं मोर डिटेल क्लासिफिकेशन
ऑफ़ इवेंट्स। कुछ कीवर्ड्स अटैच्ड होते हैं
जिसमें कि और भी डिटेल पता चलती है। उन
कीवर्ड्स के थ्रू जो है और भी डिटेल्स
टाइड अप होते हैं और उससे हमें और डिटेल
पता चलती है। ऑप कोड ऑपरेशन कोड
आइडेंटिफाई द स्पेसिफिक ऑपरेशन दैट द
इवेंट रिपोर्ट्स। ऑफ कोड जो होती है वो
स्पेसिफिक ऑपरेशन कोड बोलते हैं।
स्पेसिफिक ऑपरेशन यानी स्पेसिफिक एक कोई
जो चीज हो रही है अ इवेंट के अंदर में
उसको वो डिनोट करता है। एंड देन लास्ट द
यूजर द यूजर अकाउंट दैट वाज़ लॉक्ड ऑन
व्हेन द इवेंट ओकर जो यूजर अकाउंट लॉक्ड
इन था हमारा जब ये इवेंट ऑकर हुआ उसके
बारे में डिटेल। तो ये पूरा का पूरा एक
Windows इवेंट लॉग फुटप्रिंट्स था आपका
एंड ये पूरी की पूरी इस तरीके से काम करती
है। कोई भी इवेंट की बात करें किसी भी तरह
का इवेंट की बात करें उसमें ये सारी चीजें
लॉग नेम सोर्स एक्सML डेटा इवेंट आईडी
टास्क कैटेगरी कंप्यूटर नेम लेवल ऑफ
सीवियरिटी लॉग्ड जो बेसिकली डेट एंड टाइम
जो होते हैं कीवर्ड्स होते हैं ऑपरेशन कोड
होते हैं यूज़र्स होते हैं जो भी यूजर वहां
पे लॉक्ड ये सारी चीजें आपकी होती है। तो
आई होप कि आपको यह चीज तो समझ में अभी आ
गई होगी। चलिए
Windows का लॉगिन आर्किटेक्चर। लेकिन अभी
इसमें और भी चीजें हैं। मैं आपको वो भी
समझाऊंगा। अब आते हैं Windows इवेंट्स लॉग
के टाइप्स एंड सोर्सेस कहां से कैसे काम
करते हैं? ये सोर्सेस किस तरीके के होते
हैं? वो सारे हम चीजें समझते हैं। ठीक है?
यहां तक सबको क्लियर था यहां तक? लाइक अभी
जो हमने करा यहां पे Windows इवेंट लॉ्स
क्या होते हैं? क्या क्रिट क्यों क्रिटिकल
एंड Windows लॉगिंग आर्किटेक्चर का हमने
यहां पे एक Windows इवेंट लॉक फुटप्रिंट्स
को समझा। तो आई थिंक यहां तक सबके क्लियर
होगा। इट्स नॉट दैट टफ टू अंडरस्टैंड।
राइट?
सच बोल रहा हूं सर। आपका वीडियो देखने के
बाद किसी और चैनल में जाना नहीं पड़ा। यू
आर अ परफेक्ट टीचर। थैंक यू ब्रदर फॉर
दैट। मजा आ गया। हां। चलिए अभी और मजा
आएगा। लेट्स सी। ओके। Windows लॉगिंग
आर्किटेचर अब Windows इवेंट लॉक्स के कुछ
टाइप्स को देख लेते हैं। अगर हम टाइप्स की
बातें करें तो एरर इवेंट लॉक्स होते हैं।
वार्निंग इवेंट लॉक्स होते हैं। इनेशन
इनेशनल इवेंट लॉक्स होते हैं। सक्सेस ऑडिट
होते हैं। फेलियर ऑडिट होते हैं। ये सब जो
होते हैं टाइप्स में आते हैं आपके।
सोर्सेस की हम बात करें तो सिस्टम इवेंट
लॉक्स होते हैं। मतलब ये टाइप्स के बेसिस
पे है। ये जो है ना टाइप्स तो एरर वाले
होते हैं, वार्निंग वाले होते हैं,
इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल इनेशनल इवेंट लॉक्स होते
हैं, सक्सेस ऑडिट होते हैं एंड फेलियर
ऑडिट होते हैं। ये तो दीज़ आर बेस्ड ऑन द
टाइप्स। दीज़ आर बेस्ड ऑन द सोर्स। यह
Windows इवेंट लॉक्स जो सोर्स पर बेस्ड
हैं। तो सिस्टम इवेंट लॉक्स होते हैं,
एप्लीकेशन इवेंट लॉक्स होते हैं,
सिक्योरिटी इवेंट लॉक्स होते हैं, सेटअप
इवेंट लॉक्स होते हैं, फॉरवर्डेड इवेंट
लॉक्स होते हैं। ये सब चीज़ होती हैं। और
एक क्लियर्ड सेक्शन होता है यानी कि
इवेंट्स को क्लियर कर दिया गया हो। ऐसे
इवेंट्स जिनको क्लियर कर दिया गया हो। तो
इवेंट V, जीयूआई, कमांड, प्र्प्ट, पावर
शेल जहां-जहां से इवेंट्स को क्लियर कर
दिया गया हो। तो इवेंट अगर क्लियर भी हो
रहे हैं, क्लियर कोई अगर जैसे कोई अटैकर
है जब वो अटैक करता है तो अगर साइबर जैसे
साइबर किल चेन या आपने हैकिंग के स्टेप्स
पढ़े होंगे। तो उसमें एक आता है ना लास्ट
में क्लियरिंग स्टेप्स। जो भी स्टेप्स
आपने किए हैं जो भी आपने अटैक वाला
स्टेप्स हैं उनको क्लियर करना। अपने लॉग्स
को क्लियर करना। तो लॉग्स क्लियर करने के
भी चीज को यहां पे लॉग किया जाता है। तो
ये इसलिए बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट होता है। तो दिस
इज़ द इवेंट लॉग्स। अ बेसिकली एक चार्ट के
थ्रू आपको बताया टाइप्स एंड क्लियर्ड एंड
सोर्स के थ्रू। ठीक है? आई होप आपको
क्लियर होगा। अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यहां पे स्टेप बाय स्टेप फ्लो देखते हैं।
इसमें एग्जैक्टली क्या काम कर क्या कैसे
होता है ये? फ्लो स्टेप वाइज़ हम देखते हैं
इसको। स्टेप वाइज़ फ्लो की जब हम बात करते
हैं गाइस तो सबसे पहला जो स्टेप होता है द
फर्स्ट स्टेप जो हम यहां पे लेते हैं वो
है एक्शन हैपेंस। अगर हम एक स्टेप बाय
स्टेप फ्लो को देखते हैं तो सबसे पहले एक
एक्शन हैपन होता है। व्हाट हैपेंड? एक्शन
हैपन। ठीक है?
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
एक्शन [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हैपेंड
जैसे कि लॉग इन हो गया, प्रोसेससेस हो गए
एक्सट्रा एक्सट्रा। तो ये ये एक्शन हो
गया। उसके बाद इवेंट प्रोवाइडर जनरेट्स
इवेंट। तो जो भी इवेंट प्रोवाइडर्स होते
हैं वो इवेंट को जनरेट करते हैं। दूसरा
स्टेप हो गया। तीसरा स्टेप हो गया। तीसरा
स्टेप क्या हो जाता है? Windows इवेंट लॉक
सर्विसेस कलेक्ट्स इट। Windows का जो
इवेंट लॉक सर्विस होता है वो इसको कलेक्ट
करता है। जो भी इवेंट जनरेट होते हैं
कलेक्ट होता है वो। इवेंट रिटेन टू ईवीटीx
फाइल। इन इवेंट्स को ईवीटीx फाइल जो कि
मैंने आपको लोकेशन दिखाया था Windows के
अंदर सिस्टम 32 के अंदर में आपका विन
ईवीटी वाली जो फोल्डर थी उसमें ये फाइल्स
को ईवीटीx एक्सटेंशन के साथ क्रिएट किया
जाता है। व्यूड इन इवेंट व्यूअर और इन्हीं
यही जो फाइल्स आप वहां पे क्रिएट हुए रहते
हैं उनको इवेंट व्यूअर में आप देख सकते
हैं। या एसओसी अगर केस एसओसी वगैरह की बात
करें हम एसओसी के केस में तो एसआईएम जैसी
टूल्स टेक्नोलॉजी का यूज़ एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड
के अंदर आप ये देख सकते हैं। तो आपने जब
देखा था आपने जो बेसिकली यहां पे मैं आपको
एक बार फिर से वो कर देता हूं। आपने जैसे
सी ड्राइव में Windows में गए थे आप
सिस्टम 32 में गए थे
एंड यहां पे अ विन ईवीटी डायरेक्टरी में
लॉग्स के अंदर ये जो लॉग्स क्रिएट हुए हैं
ना लॉग्स इन सबको देखने के लिए इन लॉग्स
को प्रॉपर फॉर्मेट में देखने के लिए ही
Windows के अंदर में इवेंट व्यूअर करके एक
यूटिलिटी होती है। इवेंट व्यूअर। इवेंट
व्यूअर को जब आप ओपन करेंगे तो यह जो
इवेंट व्यूअर्स में आप जैसे Windows लॉ्स
में अलग-अलग एप्लीकेशन के अलग लॉक्स हैं।
ठीक है? सिक्योरिटी के अलग लॉक्स हैं। तो
ये जो लॉक्स देख रहे हैं ये वही लॉ्स हैं
जो वहां पे लॉक्ड हो रहे हैं। उस
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर में वो यहां पे दिखा
रहे हैं। जैसे कि एक लेवल आपका लेवल हो
गया। इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल जैसे हमने देखा था ना
लेवल एक लेवल थी जो हम पिछले वाले उसमें
देखा था हमने। यहां पे कुछ और भी तरह के
लेवल हो सकते हैं। फिलहाल इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल
है वो नहीं। कोई सिक्योरिटी अलर्ट या कोई
थ्रेट ऐसा कुछ नहीं है। तो लेवल आपका
इनेशनल है। डेट एंड टाइम हो गया। सोर्स हो
गया एंड इवेंट आईडी जैसा मैंने बोला था।
टास्क का कैटेगरी जैसे मैंने बोला हुआ था
जो कि कैटेगरी आपके बताता है वो सारी चीज़
यहां पे जो जो मैंने आपको बताई है वो सारी
चीजें आपको यहां पे मिलेंगी। जैसे आप इसके
डिटेल्स में देखेंगे तो लॉग नेम यहां पे
एप्लीकेशन जैसे मैंने बताया था सोर्स
विंडोज़ एरर रिपोर्टिंग आपका इवेंट आईडी जो
होता है लेवल इनेशन हो गया। यूजर सिस्टम
हो गया आपका ऑप कोड इनेशनल इनफो हो गया।
लॉग्ड एग्जैक्ट डेट एंड टाइम टास्क
कैटेगरी नन हो गया। कीवर्ड्स अगर कोई
कीवर्ड्स वगैरह यहां पे होता है तो मिल
जाएगा। या तो एंड कंप्यूटर आपका कंप्यूटर
जो नेम हो गया वो हो गया। तो आपको ये जो
यहां पे एग्जैक्ट चीजें दिखाता है वही
एग्जैक्ट चीजें मैं आपको सिखा भी रहा हूं।
तो आपको ऐसा नहीं समझना है कि ये सिर्फ
थ्योरिटिकल नॉलेज है। आपको ऐसा
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] नहीं समझना
है कि अरे यार
ये क्या लॉग्स हैं? क्या है? ये जो मैं जो
भी स्लाइड मैं आपको बताता हूं तो स्लाइड
में जो चीजें बताता हूं वो रियल में आप
रिलेट कर सकते हैं एक्चुअल चीजों से। तो
जब आप इसका बेनिफिट क्या होगा? मैं आपको
बताता हूं। इनका बेनिफिट ये होगा कि अभी
आप थ्योरी टाइप में पढ़ रहे हैं चीजों को।
हम जब प्रैक्टिकल करेंगे तो आपको ये चीजें
दिमाग में आप कहेंगी कि अच्छा हमने पढ़ा
था इसके बारे में। तो आप रिलेट कर पाएंगे
एंड इन चीजों को समझ पाएंगे एग्जैक्टली।
क्योंकि आपने ऑलरेडी यह टर्म्स एंड
कीवर्ड्स एंड जो भी चीजें हैं यह ऑलरेडी
आपने पढ़ा हुआ है। इसीलिए बोलता हूं कि आप
जब एकदम से घुस के पढ़ोगे ना पूरी अपनी
जान जोर जान लगा के तो आपको मजा आएगा। आगे
चल के आपको सब चीजें समझ में आ जाएगा। ठीक
है?
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? आई होप कि आपको ये चीजें क्लियर
हो रही होंगी। चलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब स्टेप बाय
स्टेप फ्लो में यहां मैंने आपको बताया कि
पांच स्टेप्स हैं। एक्शन पहले होता है।
इवेंट प्रोवाइडर जो होता है वो जनरेट जैसे
इवेंट एरर रिपोर्टिंग है प्रोवाइडर अगर तो
वो जनरेट करता है इवेंट को। Windows इवेंट
लॉक सर्विस उसको कलेक्ट करता है। उसको
ईवीटीx फाइल में राइट करता है। और Windows
का इवेंट व्यूअर जो है या एसओसी के केस
में एसआईएम टूल्स का यूज़ करके इवेंट्स को
या लॉग्स को हम देखते हैं। ठीक है? अब
यहां पे कुछ की कंपोनेंट्स की बात करें तो
यहां पे एक इवेंट प्रोवाइडर होता है। एक
इवेंट चैनल होता है। इवेंट लॉग सर्विज
होती हैं। ठीक है? ये कुछ की कंपोनेंट्स
होते हैं। अब इवेंट प्रोवाइडर में जैसे
जनरली जो कि जनरेट करता है लॉग्स को जैसे
सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइडर हो गया, पावर शेल हो
गया जो बेसिकली उस इवेंट को जनरेट कर रहा
है। तो कोई भी लाइक पावर शेल आपकी हो गई
या किसी भी तरह का कोई सिक्योरिटी
सॉफ्टवेयर आप यूज़ कर रहे हैं। जो इवेंट्स
को जनरेट करने के लिए यूज़ में लिया जा रहा
है या इवेंट्स को जनरेट कर रहे हैं वो सब
इसमें आ जाएंगे। इवेंट चैनल होते हैं लॉक
के टाइप। अब लॉक के टाइप्स जो हैं वो
सिक्योरिटी लॉक्स, सिस्टम लॉग्स,
एप्लीकेशन लॉग्स इस तरह के टाइप्स होते
हैं। सिक्योरिटी, सिस्टम एप्लीकेशन। इन
तीनों के बारे में हम डिटेल में भी पढ़ने
वाले हैं। याद रखिएगा। सिक्योरिटी लॉग्स,
सिस्टम लॉग्स एंड एप्लीकेशन लॉग्स। यह तीन
तरह के मेन आपके इवेंट देखो लॉग्स और भी
कुछ-कुछ होते हैं। बट यह मेन आपके तीन तरह
के लॉग्स इवेंट चैनल लॉग टाइप्स होते हैं।
एंड उसके बाद इवेंट लॉग सर्विस होता है जो
कि लॉग्स को स्टोर करता है। जो भी लॉ्स
हैं उसको स्टोर करता है। एज सिंपल एज ये
तीनों याद रखिएगा सिस्टम सिक्योरिटी एंड
एप्लीकेशन।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
अब इन तीनों में सबसे पहले हम सिक्योरिटी
लॉग्स को देखेंगे। फिर सिस्टम फिर
एप्लीकेशन को। तो सिक्योरिटी लॉग्स की हम
बात करते हैं। सिक्योरिटी लॉ्स में
सिक्योरिटी लॉग्स का काम क्या होता है?
ठीक है?
सिक्योरिटी लॉग्स का क्या काम होता है?
सिक्योरिटी लॉग्स ट्रैक ऑथेंटिकेशन,
सिक्योरिटी लॉग ट्रैक ऑथराइजेशन, ट्रैक
प्रिविलेजेस एंड ट्रैक अकाउंट चेंजेस। ये
सिक्योरिटी लॉक्स का काम है। ये बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट होता है। सबसे ज्यादाेंट एसओसी
के लिए सिक्योरिटी लॉक्स ही होता है।
हालांकि और भी जो सिस्टम लॉक्स हैं वो भी
देखो वो भी इंपॉर्टेंट है। एप्लीकेशन
लॉक्स भी इंपॉर्टेंट है। बट सिक्योरिटी
लॉक्स क्योंकि सिक्योरिटी से कनेक्टेड
चीजें हैं जुड़ी चीज़ है। तो ये ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट आपके लिए है। तो ये ट्रैक करने
कौन-कौन सी चीज़ ट्रैक करता है? तो
ऑथेंटिकेशन को, ऑथोराइज़ेशन को, प्रिविलजेस
को, अकाउंट चेंजेस को ट्रैक करता है। दीज़
आर योर प्राइमरी इन्वेस्टिगेशन लॉग्स। ये
आपका प्राइमरी इन्वेस्टिगेशन लॉ होना
चाहिए। अब देखो
अब यहां पे कुछ लॉगन टाइप्स होते हैं।
जब भी आप ठीक है सिस्टम लॉगिन वगैरह करते
हो तो उसमें कुछ लॉग ऑन टाइप्स होते हैं।
उन टाइप्स को भी देखना जरूरी है। उन
टाइप्स को समझना जरूरी है क्योंकि ये लॉग
ऑन टाइप्स आपको कहीं-कहीं सिक्योरिटी
लॉग्स के अंदर में देखने को मिल सकते हैं।
तो जैसे एक लॉग ऑन टाइप होता है टाइप टू।
टाइप टू का मतलब होता है इंटरेक्टिव। यह
एक लोकल लॉगिन के लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता
है। जैसे लोकली आपने कोई अकाउंट लॉग इन
किया है सिस्टम पे तो टाइप टू का वो लॉग
ऑन टाइप होता है। टाइप थ्री नेटवर्क
एसएमबी है। नेटवर्क लॉग इन अगर आप कर रहे
हैं किसी तरह का या सर्वर मैसेज ब्लॉक
एक्सेस कर रहे हैं एसएमबी एक्सेस कर रहे
हैं उस टाइप का जो लॉग इन वगैरह होता है
वो टाइप थ्री में आता है। एक टाइप 10 होता
है रिमोट लॉगिन के लिए। जैसे कोई भी रिमोट
सर्विस आप यूज कर रहे हैं या आरडीपी जैसे
या रिमोट डेस्कटॉप प्रोटोकॉल जो होता है
उसको यूज़ वगैरह कर रहे हैं किसी भी तरह का
रिमोट तो वो लॉग इन 10 में टाइप में आता
है। एक होता है सेवन जो कि अनलॉक होता है।
जैसे कि अनलॉक करने के लिए कोई भी सेशन को
वापस से रीयूज़ करना है या वापस से स्टार्ट
करना है। ये सब के लिए जो लॉग इन टाइप
होता है सेवन होता है। अब ये लॉग इन
टाइप्स एसओसी के लिए काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है।
क्योंकि जब आप एसओसी के जब आप लॉग्स को
देख रहे होते हैं तो वहां पे ये लॉग इन
टाइप्स आपको देखने को मिलता है। उससे हमें
इनिशियल जानकारी मिल जाती है कि
एग्जैक्टली जो ये अटैक हमारे पास हो रहा
है अटैक या जो भी पॉसिबल अटैक है उसमें
किस तरह की चीजें हो रही है। अगर 10 है तो
रिमोट लॉग इन होने की कोशिश हो रही है।
अगर टू है तो इंटरेक्टिव लोकल लॉग इन करने
की कोशिश कोई कर रहा है। थ्री है तो
नेटवर्क लॉग इन करने की कोशिश कर रहा है।
इस तरीके से या सेशन यूज़ कर रहा है सेवन
है तो इस तरह की इनफेशन हमें मिलती है।
सिंपल सिंपल सिंपल सा फंडा है।
सर फिर से एक बार बताना ऑथेंटिकेट और
ऑथोराइजेशन। अरे ऑथेंटिकेट और ऑथराइज़ेशन
नॉर्मल सी चीज़ है। ऑथेंटिकेशन का देखो
ऑथेंटिकेशन का मतलब होता है किसी भी चीज़
को ऑथेंटिकेट कर देना कि हां भैया ये इस
चीज़ को ऑथेंटिकेट हम करते हैं। अब आप
इसमें आगे लॉग इन वगैरह जो भी चीज़ आपको
करनी है। यू आर ऑथेंटिकेटेड फॉर दैट
पर्टिकुलर। ऑथोराइजेशन का मतलब है किसी
पर्टिकुलर सर्विस के किसी पर्टिकुलर
सर्विस के लिए ऑथोराइज़ करना। इस पर्टिकुलर
चीज़ के लिए ऑथराइज़ करना। ऑथेंटिकेशन में
सिर्फ लॉगिन से रिलेटेड हम किसी चीज में
लॉगिन कर रहे हैं या कुछ एक्सेस ले रहे
हैं उसके लिए होता ऑथराइजेशन मतलब हम किसी
सर्विस को एक्सेस करने की कोशिश कर रहे
हैं। हम किसी एक पर्टिकुलर एरिया को
एक्सेस करने की कोशिश कर रहे हैं। हम किसी
एसएमबी शेयर नेटवर्क शेयर को एक्सेस करना
चाहते हैं। उसकी ऑथराइजेशन की बात हो रही
है। आई होप आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। ठीक
है? चलिए [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब यहां पे एसओ
एसओसी मस्ट मैप एसओसी मस्ट मैप में क्या
होना चाहिए कि लॉगन टाइप मतलब एज अ एसओसी
आपको इस तरह की मैपिंग करनी चाहिए एज अ
लॉगन मतलब मैपिंग में क्या होता है कि
लॉगन टाइप को मैप करो देखो IP को मैप करो
यूजर को मैप करो और देन आपको अटैक का
पैटर्न पता चल जाएगा IP आपके पास होगी लॉग
इन टाइप कैसा है वो रहेगा और यूजर का
डिटेल रहेगा तो आपको अटैक का पैटर्न पता
पता चल जाता है बीइंग एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट
एल1
अब यहां आते हैं सिक्योरिटी इवेंट लॉग्स
इसको समझते हैं। ठीक है? सिक्योरिटी इवेंट
लॉग्स
जो होते हैं जो जो इवेंट लॉक्स हैं उन
सबको यहां पे मैंने लिस्ट डाउन किया हुआ
है। अब यहां पे हो सकता है आपको उतना
क्लियर ना दिखे। तो इसको भी मैं यहां से
कॉपी कर लेता हूं।
लेट्स सी इफ वी कैन पेस्ट इट इन MS PT
मुश्किल है।
हां यहां पे तो नहीं होगी।
चलो वर्ड में ही करते हैं इसको।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] स्केरी है ना
स्केरी।
चलो यहां पे मैंने पेंट यहां पे मैंने
पेस्ट किया। इसमें ज्यादा अच्छे से
विजिबिलिटी भी आएगी आपको।
हम अच्छा वर्ड में मार्कर नहीं होता है
क्या? वर्ड में किसी को पता है क्या?
मार्कर वर्ड तो मैं यूज़ ही नहीं करता। तो
आई डोंट हैव एनी आईडिया। या हाईलाइटर होता
है क्या? वर्ड में
लेट मी सी
हाउ टू यूज़ हाईलाइटर
और मार्कर
इन MS Word बताओ क्या-क्या सर्च करना पड़
रहा है? सेलेक्ट द टेक्स्ट
ऑन एन इमेज।
यह तो लिखना ही भूल गया। क्या है भाई? टू
हाईलाइट और मार्क एन इमेज। द बेस्ट मेथड
इज़ टू इंसर्ट अ ट्रांसपेरेंट शेप ओवर द
रेक्टेंग ओवर द टारगेट ओके
ओके ड्रॉ टैब ड्रॉ टैब कहां है भाई ओके
ड्रॉ टैब अच्छा ये है ना यार गुड गुड गुड
गुड गुड गुड मिल गया चलो खोजने से हर चीज
मिलती है अपने को मिल गया है यहां पे रेड
वाली ले लेते हैं इसमें कुछ है क्या इसको
मोटा करने हां ये रहा
क्या बात है भाई अरे यार यार अब क्या
चाहिए लाइफ में? यही तो चाहिए था लाइफ
में।
लाइफ इससे ज्यादा अच्छी क्या हो सकती है
कि मार्कर मिल गया।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] चलो
ठीक है। सो यहां पे हम सिक्योरिटी इवेंट
लॉक्स की बात कर रहे हैं। सिक्योरिटी
इवेंट लॉक्स में हम जितने भी की इवेंट
आईडीज हैं, जो इंपॉर्टेंट इवेंट आईडीज
हैं, हमने यहां पे उनको यहां पे लाया है
एंड हम उसको देखने वाले हैं। ठीक है?
देखो, अब वैसे सिक्योरिटी इवेंट लॉ्स में
बहुत सारे इवेंट आईडीज होते हैं। इवेंट
आईडीज़। ठीक है? इवेंट लॉक्स में बहुत सारे
इवेंट आईडीज़ होते हैं। अगर आपको मैं इवेंट
व्यूअर दिखाया था आपको मैंने अभी थोड़ी
देर पहले तो आपने देखा होगा इवेंट व्यूअर
में। ठीक है? कि Windows logs में अगर मैं
एप्लीकेशन लॉग्स की बात करता हूं तो यहां
पे आपको दिखेगा अभी जस्ट वेट।
यहां देख रहे हो यहां पे इसको मैं थोड़ा
सा नीचे की तरफ। हां। यहां पे देख रहे हो
इवेंट आईडीज।
इवेंट आईडीज। कितने सारे इवेंट्स आईडीज़
हैं। यह देखो ना देयर आर लॉट ऑफ़ लॉट ऑफ़
लॉट ऑफ़ इवेंट आईडीज़। देयर आर बहुत सारे
इवेंट आईडीज़। बट यहां पे हमने कुछ
कैटेगराइज़ किया कुछ इवेंट्स आईडीज़ को। कुछ
इंपॉर्टेंट इवेंट आईडीज़ को जो कि स्पेशली
बिलोंग करते हैं सिक्योरिटी इवेंट लॉ्स के
अ सेक्शन से। ठीक है? इसके बाद जब हम इसके
बाद हम उन आईडीज़ को भी देखेंगे जो सिस्टम
इवेंट सिस्टम इवेंट लॉ्स के हैं।
एप्लीकेशन इवेंट लॉक्स के हैं। तो फिलहाल
हम सिक्योरिटी इवेंट लॉक्स की बात करते
हैं यहां पे। इंपॉर्टेंट सिक्योरिटी इवेंट
आईडीज इन विंडोज सिक्योरिटी लॉग्स। तो
सबसे पहला जो कैटेगरी है वो है लॉग इन एंड
ऑथेंटिकेशन इवेंट्स। तो लॉग इन एंड
ऑथेंटिकेशन इवेंट्स का क्या काम है? ट्रैक
यूजर लॉग इन एक्टिविटीज़ एंड डिटेक्ट अन
ऑथराइज़्ड एक्सेस। बस इसका यही काम है
ऑथराइज़्ड एक्सेस को डिटेक्ट करना एंड यूजर
के लॉग ऑन एक्टिविटी को ट्रैक करना। तो
जैसे कि 4624 है। तो इसका मतलब होता है
सक्सेसफुल लॉगन। क्या है? मॉनिटर लॉगन। 2
= इंटरेक्टिव, 10 = आरडीपी, 3 = नेटवर्क।
तो मतलब ये जो वही लॉग इन टाइप्स है वो
यहां पे दिखाया हुआ और कुछ भी नहीं है। तो
ये लॉगन को मॉनिटर करता है। जो भी लॉगिन्स
वगैरह लॉगिस वगैरह होते हैं उनको मॉनिटर
करता है। 4624 का मतलब सक्सेसफुल लॉग इन
होता है। 4625 का मतलब होता है फेल्ड लॉग
ऑन। 4634 का मतलब होता है लॉग ऑफ। लॉग ऑफ
किया गया है। किसी अकाउंट को लॉग ऑफ कर
दिया गया है। 46 47 का मतलब है इन यूजर
इनिशिएटेड लॉग ऑफ। यूजर ने लॉग ऑफ को
इनिशिएट किया है। 4648 लॉग ऑन यूजिंग
एक्सप्लसिट क्रेडेंशियल्स। लाइक मतलब कि
क्रेडेंशियल अब्यूज टाइप या कोई तरह का
कोई अटैक आई थिंक हो रहा है उसका यूज़ किया
जा रहा है यहां पे 4648 जब भी ऐसा लॉ आपको
मिलता है तो वहां पे थोड़ी चिंता वाली बात
है 4672 स्पेशल प्रिविलेज असाइन मतलब कि अ
कोई स्पेशल प्रिविलेज असाइन हुआ है। हो
सकता है ये प्रिविलेज एस्क्लेशन के केस
में भी आ सकता है यहां पे एंड ये एक
मलेशियस केस भी हो सकता है। तो ये बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज होती है। उसके बाद अकाउंट
मैनेजमेंट इवेंट्स में आते हैं। ठीक है?
अब यहां पे जितने भी नहीं नहीं ना देखो अ
आई डोंट थिंक किसी को भी यहां पे जितने
इवेंट आईडीज आपके प्रेजेंट होते हैं किसी
को भी सारे इवेंट आईडीज याद नहीं हो सकते
हैं। इट्स नॉट पॉसिबल टू रिमेंबर ईच एंड
एव्री इवेंट आईडीज। ये तो पॉसिबल ही नहीं
है। बट होता क्या है? है व्हाट हैपेंस
एक्सैक्टली कि जब आप कॉर्पोरेट में काम
करते हो जॉब कर रहे हो सिस्टम पे जब आप
इसी इसी डोमेन में ही दिन रात अपना काम कर
रहे हो तो कुछ-कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट इनमें से जो
इवेंट आईडीज हैं जिस पे तुम रेगुलर डेली
बेसिस पे काम करोगे जो रेगुलर तुम्हें
देखने को मिलेंगे वो तुम्हें याद हो
जाएंगे ऑटोमेटिकली अब जैसे 4624 है
सक्सेसफुल लॉग इन ये तुम्हें जब बार-बार
तुम इनेशन में देखोगे कि हां सक्सेसफुल
लॉग इन हुआ है अच्छा ठीक है किसी अटैक में
भी देख लिया कि हां भाई तो ये तुम्हें याद
याद हो जाएगा। अब कोई ऐसी चीज़ है कि यूजर
इनिशिएटेड लॉग ऑफ़ थोड़ा कम देखने को मिलेगा
तो शायद उतना तुम्हें याद ना हो। स्पेशल
प्रिविलेज असाइन थोड़ा कम दे तो शायद उतना।
बट ये सारी जो मेमोराइजेशन है वो
प्रैक्टिस पे डिपेंड करती है। बट सारे
कोड्स आपको याद नहीं हो सकते हैं। यू शुड
बी हैविंग द चीट लिस्ट या आपके पास कोड्स
होने चाहिए सारे। एक इंटरनेट से डाउनलोड
कर लो। इंटरनेट पे सारे कोड्स अवेलेबल है।
इवेंट आईडीज़ और क्या करती है वो सब
अवेलेबल है। डाउनलोड कर लो। देखते रहो।
उनसे मैच कर लो। धीरे-धीरे आपको जितनी भी
चीजें जो रेगुलर सर्विज हैं जो आप रेगुलर
यूज़ करो वो ऑटोमेटिकली याद हो जाएगी ओवर द
टाइम विद द एक्सपीरियंस। दैट्स इट। ठीक
है? अब अकाउंट मैनेजमेंट इवेंट्स की बात
करें तो उसी तरीके से 4720
यूजर अकाउंट क्रिएट होने का ये इवेंट आईडी
है। अगर यूजर अकाउंट इनेबल हुआ है तो ये
4722 होता है। पासवर्ड चेंज अटेम्प्ट किया
गया है तो 4723 हो गया। और पासवर्ड रिसेट
किया गया है एडमिंस के द्वारा। 4724 हो
गया। तो ये मतलब अलग-अलग चीजों के लिए
इवेंट आईडीज है। अब मैं सारे इवेंट आईडीज
पे एक-एक करके इतना टाइम तो नहीं दूंगा
क्योंकि वो वेस्ट ऑफ टाइम है क्योंकि ये
इवेंट आईडीज की लिस्ट है। आपको जब इस
पर्टिकुलर सेशन की पीडीएफ मिलेगी तो आपको
उसमें ऑलरेडी ये जो आपकी इमेज है वो आपको
मिल जाएगी। तो आप वहां से अपना देख के
उसको स्टडी फॉरवर्ड कर सकते हैं। या उसी
तरीके से ग्रुप एंड प्रिविलेज मैनेजमेंट
की बात करें तो इसमें भी बहुत सारी इवेंट
आईडीज़ हैं। जैसे 4728 मेंबर ऐड हुआ है
ग्लोबल ग्रुप में। 29 मेंबर रिमूव हुआ है।
32 मेंबर ऐड हुआ है लोकल ग्रुप में। ऐसे
कर करके। एंड यहां पे इसकी डिस्क्रिप्शन
सारी दी गई है। प्रोसेस क्रिएशन एंड
एग्जीक्यूशन की बात करें तो प्रोसेस
क्रिएट होने का एक इवेंट आईडी 4688 बहुत
जरूरी ये इवेंट आईडी होता है। प्रोसेस
क्रिएशन वाली जो इवेंट आईडी है वो बहुतेंट
होती है क्योंकि उसी से सारे प्रोसेससेस
क्रिएट आपके होते हैं 4688 4689 टर्मिनेट
करने के लिए। ठीक है? ये सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट
है। मोस्टेंट इवेंट। ट्रैक न्यू
प्रोसेससेस, पैरेंट प्रोसेससेस, कमांड
लाइन यूज़र्स, एवरीथिंग सिंपल।
ये सारी चीजें होती हैं। अब यहां पे देखो
प्रिविलेज यूज़ अ प्रिविलेज जो है इवेंट्स
क्या होते हैं यहां पे? मॉनिटर यूज़ ऑफ़
सेंसिटिव प्रिविलेज एंड ऑपरेशंस। तो जैसे
4673 तो सेंसिटिव प्रिविलेज यूज़्ड 4674
ऑपरेशन ऑन प्रिविलेज ऑब्जेक्ट। ठीक है ना?
यानी यूजर एक्सरसाइज अ सेंसिटिव प्रिविलेज
एंड एन ऑपरेशन वाज़ परफॉर्म्ड ऑन अ
प्रिविलज्ड ऑब्जेक्ट। तो ये सब अगर इवेंट
आईडीज अगर इवेंट्स आपको मिल रहे हैं देखने
को तो इसका मतलब है कुछ प्रिविलेज्ड थिंग
चीजें हो रही हैं। एंड इट कैन बी सस्िशियस
कौन मतलब यू शुड बी लुक यू शुड बी लुकिंग
आउट फॉर दैट कि एक्चुअली ये प्रिविलेज्ड
वाली चीज़ आखिर कौन कर रहा है? क्या हमारा
ही नॉर्मल कोई यूजर ही कर रहा है या फिर
कोई और ट्राई कर रहा है इनको एक्सेस लेने
के लिए। तो ये बहुतेंट हो जाते हैं। ठीक
है? उसी तरीके से यहां पे ऑथेंटिकेशन
जिसको बेसिकली नेटवर्क में बात करें या
एनtएलएम लोकल कंप्यूटर की बात करें तो
उसमें भी कुछ इवेंट आईडीज होते हैं जो करब
के टीजीटी रिक्वेस्ट जो टिकटिंग वगैरह का
होता है वो सब देखते हैं उसके बारे में
बताते हैं। सर्विस टिकट के बारे में बताते
हैं। ये सब चीजें बताते हैं। एनटीएलएम
ऑथेंटिकेशन के बारे में बताते हैं। उसी
तरह ऑब्जेक्ट एक्सेस इवेंट्स भी है जो कि
हैंडल रिक्वेस्टेड यहां पे ऑब्जेक्ट
एक्सेस अटेम्प्ट या हैंडल क्लोज्ड या किस
तरह से मतलब ऑब्जेक्ट को एक्सेस किया जा
रहा है। लाइक आप कोई भी जब अह फाइल या कोई
रजिस्ट्री या किसी भी तरह का कोई ऑब्जेक्ट
को एक्सेस करते हैं तो उससे रिलेटेड जितने
भी इवेंट्स होते हैं उनको हम ऑब्जेक्ट
एक्सेस इवेंट्स बोलते हैं। और उन इवेंट्स
की आईडीज़ यहां पे आपको दी हुई है जो यहां
पे कुछ की आईडीज़ हैं यहां पे। इन सारे
देखो। अब ये सारी आईडीज़ को आपको याद करने
की जरूरत नहीं है। बिल्कुल भी जरूरत नहीं
है। सच बता रहा हूं मैं। ये आपको याद होगा
भी नहीं। कभी नहीं होगा। बट जो इंपॉर्टेंट
आईडीज़ हैं आपको बस पता होना चाहिए कि हां
एक्साक्ट्ली। जब आप लाइक यू विल बी इन द
प्रैक्टिस रेगुलर आप डेली बेसिस पे करेंगे
तो आपका दिमाग काम करना शुरू हो जाएगा।
राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। पॉलिसी एंड ऑडिट चेंज के भी यहां पे
कुछ-कुछ आईडीज होते हैं। यहां पे इवेंट
आईडीज होते हैं जिनमें अलग-अलग काम होते
हैं। इवेंट आईडीज का मतलब है कुछ एक
पर्टिकुलर इवेंट हो रही है। पर्टिकुलर कोई
एक ऑपरेशन हो रहा है। कोई एक इंसिडेंट है
एंड उसकी एक आईडी जनरेट हो रही है। बस और
कुछ भी नहीं है। मतलब ये आईडी के अगेंस्ट
ये इवेंट का नाम दिया हुआ है। ये आईडी है।
ये कोई इवेंट हो रहा है। कोई काम जैसे
मैंने कोई फाइल एक्सेस करने की कोशिश करी
तो वो एक इवेंट है। तो उसकी एक आईडी जनरेट
होती है। वही आईडी के बारे में मैं यहां
पे बता रहा हूं। तो कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] बेसिक्स आईडीज
के बारे में आपको बता रहा हूं। जैसे अगर
यूजर को आपने कोई यूजर अकाउंट क्रिएट किया
उस समय एक इवेंट जनरेट हुआ। वो इवेंट आईडी
क्या हुआ? 4720
बस आपने बीइंग एन एडमिन पासवर्ड रिसेट
किया। उस पे एक इवेंट जनरेट हुआ। इवेंट
आईडी वो इवेंट आईडी क्या हुआ? 4724। तो ये
यूनिक नंबर्स होते हैं। दैट्स इट। आई थिंक
आपको अब समझ में आ गया होगा। चलिए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे
लॉग टपरिंग का भी एक इवेंट होता है भैया।
जी हां लॉग टपरिंग का भी एक इवेंट होता
है। क्या होता है भैया? क्रिटिकल अलर्ट
में आता है। डिटेक्ट अटेमप्ट्स टू क्लियर
और टपर विथ लॉग्स। मतलब कि अ अगर कोई लॉग
को टपर करने की कोशिश कर रहा है, लॉग को
क्लियर करने की कोशिश कर रहा है। कोई हैकर
भैया हैं हमारे। बोल रहे हैं कि ना लॉक को
तो क्लियर करना है। तो उस केस में 1102
इवेंट आईडी है। यहां पे ये बताती है कि
सिक्योरिटी लॉक को क्लियर किया गया है। तो
ये भी एक दिक्कत वाली बात है। ठीक है ना?
अगर ऐसा कुछ होता है तो आपको इमीडिएंट
इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस यहां पे रिक्वायर्ड
होती है कि भैया कुछ लॉक क्लियर हुआ है।
गड़बड़ वाली बात है। कुछ देखो जल्दी। उसके
बाद सिस्टम एंड सिक्योरिटी स्टेट इवेंट्स
हैं। ट्रैक सिस्टम लेवल सिक्योरिटी
इवेंट्स। जैसे 4608 है तो Windows स्टार्ट
हुआ है। 4609 ये कौन सी इवेंट होती है?
Windows शटडाउन की। 4616 ये क्या होते
हैं? Windows का सिस्टम जो है मतलब सिस्टम
का जो टाइम है उसको चेंज किया गया है। ये
सब चीजें टाइम चेंज कैन इंडिकेट लॉग
मैनपुलेशन। अगर कोई टाइम चेंज का कोई
इंडिकेशन आता है तो मतलब लॉग मैनपुलेशन
कुछ करने की कोशिश की जा रही है। ऐसा भी
होता है। तो ये सारे इवेंट आईडीज होते
हैं। अब यहां पे देखो क्या होता है। यहां
पे मैं आपको एक चीज़ बताता हूं। यहां पे
अटैक डिटेक्शन शीटशीट है ये। ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
अटैक मल्टीपल मल्टी यहां पे ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
अटैक मल्टीपल 4625 ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक के
केस में यहां पे मल्टीपल 4625 नाम की
इवेंट है। अब ये 4625 कौन सी इवेंट है?
ऊपर चलते हैं। 4625 फेल्ड लॉग इन यानी कि
फेल्ड लॉग इन वाली इवेंट आईडी यहां पर
इवेंट जो है वह जनरेट हो रही है। यानी कि
जब भी लॉग इन फेल्ड वाली बहुत सारे बहुत
सारे फेल्ड लॉगिनस जनरेट हो रहे हैं तो
ब्लूटूथ अटैक का वहां पे चांसेस बढ़ जाता
है या चांसेस रह रहे हैं। या क्या होता
है? फेल्ड लॉग ऑन इवेंट्स फ्रॉम सेम आईपी
या ब्राउज़र। ऐसा कुछ आ रहा है। मतलब समझिए
ब्रूटस अटैक टाइप जैसी चीज होने की कोशिश
हो रही है। सक्सेसफुल अटैक 4625 फॉललोड
बाय 4624 यानी 4625 यानी फेल्ड लॉग इन तो
अटेम्प्ट हुआ है बट 4624 भी फिर आया इवेंट
लॉग में। तो इसका मतलब है कि सक्सेसफुल
लॉग इन भी हो गई है। क्योंकि 4624 इज़ ऑफ़
सक्सेसफुल लॉग इन। पहले फ़ेल हुआ है,
फ़ेलियर हुआ है, ब्रूटफ़ोर्स हो रहा है।
फ़ेलियर करते-करते ब्रूटफ़ोर्स सक्सेसफुल हो
गया है। एंड देन अब सक्सेसफुल हो गई। तो
4624 यहां पे आपका इवेंट आईडी आ चुका है।
उसी तरीके से प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन की जब
बात करें तो 4672 प्लस ग्रुप मेंबरशिप
चेंज इवेंट्स यानी 4672 किस चीज का था?
4672 देखो ऊपर ये रहा 4672 स्पेशल
प्रिविलेज असाइन। मतलब किसी को स्पेशल
प्रिविलेज दी गई है तो प्रिविल एस्केलेशन
का केस हो जाता है। मैलवेयर एग्जीक्यूशन
468 विद सस्िशियस प्रोसेस और कमांड लाइन।
तो 468 किसका था भाई? देखते हैं।
प्रोसेससेस क्रिएट 468 से यानी कि कोई
प्रोसेस क्रिएट हुई है। यानी कि कोई
मैलवेयर जो है अपना काम करना शुरू कर चुका
है। दैट्स द थिंग। उसी तरीके से
पर्सिस्टेंस का भी है। लॉक टपरिंग का भी
ये सारी चीजें होती हैं। ठीक है? अब एज एन
एसोसिए एनालिस्ट आपके लिए कुछ टिप्स क्या
हैं कि अगर आप एक एसोसिए एनालिस्ट हैं एल1
है तो टिप क्या है कि ऑलवेज चेक लॉग इन
टाइप्स इन 4624 इवेंट्स। जब भी 4624
इवेंट्स हैं यानी 4624 इवेंट किस लिए होता
है? आपका सक्सेसफुल लॉग इन का होता है। तो
उसमें आप लॉग इन का टाइप चेक करो कि किस
टाइप का लॉग इन टाइप हो रहा है। कोरिलेट
मल्टीपल इवेंट्स फॉर एक्यूरेट डिटेक्शन।
मल्टीपल इवेंट्स को एक दूसरे के साथ रिलेट
करो। एक दूसरे के साथ कनेक्ट करने की
कोशिश करो और देखो कि भैया कि एग्जैक्टली
क्या आ रहा है, क्या निकल के आ रहा है,
क्या आपको डिटेक्ट हो रहा है?
इन्वेस्टिगेट अनयूज़ुअल लॉग इन टाइम्स
लोकेशनेशंस एंड प्रिविलजेस। अगर कोई
अनयूज़ुअल लॉग इन टाइम आपको हो रहा है। अब
जैसे रात को 12 1:00 के पास लॉग इन नहीं
होना चाहिए जनरली या नहीं हो रहा है। होता
है आपका जनरली बट आपको देखने को मिल रहा
है। अनयूज़ुअल लॉग इन टाइम है। या ऐसी
लोकेशन मान लो आप यूके से कोई लोकेशन लॉग
इन या कुछ ऐसा एक्सेस या कोई भी किसी तरह
का इवेंट हो रहा है तो वो अनयूजुअल लोकेशन
है। एंड अनयूजुअल प्रिविलजेस आप देख रहे
हैं कि भैया इस पर्टिकुलर ऑब्जेक्ट को इस
लेवल ऑफ प्रिविलज से एक्सेस करने की जरूरत
ही नहीं है। या होना ही नहीं चाहिए। फिर
भी आपको दिखा रहा है तो वो अनयूजुअल
प्रिविलजेस होता है। आपको समझ में आ रहा
है इतना इनेबल एडवांस्ड ऑडिट पॉलिसी फॉर
कंप्रहेंसिव लॉगिंग कुछ एडवांस ऑडिट
पॉलिसीज को इनेबल कर देना चाहिए। यानी कि
जिसके थ्रू ऑडिट होते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
लाइक लॉगिन जो भी लॉ्स हो रहे हैं, जो भी
लॉगिन हो रहे हैं, उस पे ऑडिट करना कि
भैया कौन सा लॉ किस तरीके से जनरेट हुआ
है, क्या हो रहा है एक्सैक्टली सारी डिटेल
उससे मिलेंगी। उसको इनेबल करना एंड
रेगुलरली रिव्यू एंड मॉनिटर क्रिटिकल
इवेंट आईडी। जो जितने भी क्रिटिकल इवेंट
आईडीज़ हैं उनको रेगुलरली जो है आप देखते
रहिए और उसको मैनेज करते रहिए। उसको आप जो
है मॉनिटर करते रहिए। यह बहुत ज़्यादा
ज़रूरी होता है बिंग एन एसओसी L1। तो, यह
पूरी की पूरी कहानी थी आपकी हमारी
सिक्योरिटी इवेंट लॉक्स की। आई होप कि
आपको यह चीज़ समझ में आई होगी। तो, जल्दी
से एक बार बता दीजिए सभी लोगों को। सभी
लोग समझ में आ रहा है आपको?
प्लीज रिस्पॉन्ड एवरीबडी। फास्ट। आई एम
वेटिंग फॉर ऑल ऑफ योर रिस्पांस। सो प्लीज
रिसोंड एंड आई एम वेटिंग फॉर द
रिस्पों्ससेस। एवरीवन
आर यू गेटिंग गाइस? मजा आ रहा है। ठीक है।
चलिए ये तो क्लियर हो गया। सिक्योरिटी
सिस्टम इवेंट लॉक्स।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
व्हिच लैपटॉप इज बेस्ट फॉर साइबर
सिक्योरिटी इन हाई लेवल। ये तो अभी मैं
बात नहीं कर सकता क्योंकि अभी क्लासेस करा
रहा हूं। ये सब जो क्वेश्चंस होते हैं आप
जब मैं लाइव इंटैक्ट करता हूं तब आप क्यों
नहीं पूछने आते हैं? आपको आना चाहिए ना उस
टाइम पे। मैं उसी तो आता हूं। लाइव
इंटैक्ट करता हूं आपसे या आप लाइक ग्रुप्स
वगैरह में भी होते हैं। बहुत सारी चीजें
होती हैं। आप पूछ सकते हैं। राइट? चलिए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
पर्सिस्टेंस [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] का
मतलब होता है कि आपने किसी सिस्टम का एक
बार एक्सेस ले लिया है। अब जब यूजर या जो
भी विक्टिम है वह जब भी सिस्टम को रिबूूट
करेगा या जब भी सिस्टम को वापस से स्टार्ट
करेगा तो वापस से आपको एक्सेस उस सिस्टम
को मिल जाएगा। यानी कि पर्सिस्टेंटली यानी
लॉन्ग टर्म के लिए आप सिस्टम के साथ जुड़
के रह रहे हैं। आप सिस्टम के अंदर में
घुसा के अपने आपको रख रहे हैं। एंड सिस्टम
को कॉम्प्रोमाइज करके लॉन्ग टर्म तक के
लिए आपने रखा हुआ है अपने।
अब आते [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हैं
सिस्टम लॉक्स के ऊपर में। सिक्योरिटी लॉ्स
हो गए। अब आते हैं सिस्टम लॉक्स। सिस्टम
लॉक्स क्या होते हैं? व्हाट आर सिस्टम
लॉक्स? सिस्टम लॉग्स जो होते हैं, वह किस
तरह की ट्रैकिंग करते हैं? ओएस के
बिहेवियर को ट्रैक करते हैं। ड्राइवर्स को
ट्रैक करते हैं, हार्डवेयर्स को ट्रैक
करते हैं। बूट के इवेंट्स को ट्रैक करते
हैं। यानी जब सिस्टम आपका बूट होता है, जब
सिस्टम आपका स्टार्ट होता है, उसको ये
ट्रैक करते हैं। दीज़ आर कॉल्ड सिस्टम
लॉक्स। सिंपल सा फंडा है। सिस्टम लॉग्स इन
सब चीजों को ट्रैक करते हैं। अब सिस्टम
लॉग्स में भी बहुत सारे सिस्टम लॉग्स होते
हैं। देखो मैं हर एक लॉग को यहां पे बहुत
ज्यादा डिटेल में नहीं जाऊंगा लेके
क्योंकि इससे कोई फायदा नहीं होने वाला
है। ये आपको कभी याद भी नहीं होने वाले
हैं। कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट लॉ्स को आपके दिमाग
में आपके मेमोराइज हो जाएगा। ओवर द टाइम
जब आप एसोस एल वन के जॉब के लिए जाएंगे।
जब आप डेली आपका वही काम रहेगा। डेली उन
लॉग्स को देखेंगे। उनके नंबर्स इवेंट
आईडीज़ को देखेंगे तो आपको याद हो जाएगा।
बट अभी बस मैं आपको एक ओवरव्यू दे रहा
हूं। तो इंपॉर्टेंट इवेंट्स अगर हम सिस्टम
लॉक्स की बात करें तो 6568
7045 जैसे 6O5 का मतलब है सिस्टम स्टार्ट
हुआ है। 6O6 का मतलब सिस्टम शट डाउन हुआ।
6O8 का मतलब है अनएक्सेक्टेड शट डाउन हुआ
है। 745 का मतलब हुआ है सर्विस को इंस्टॉल
की गई है। सर्विसेस हैज़ बीन इंस्टॉल्ड। तो
ये कुछ सिस्टम लॉक्स होते हैं। अगर हम
सिस्टम लॉक्स की भी मैं यहां पे बात करूं
तो यहां पे भी हमारे पास सिस्टम लॉक्स
हैं। मैं इसको भी कॉपी कर लेता हूं। एंड
वर्ड में इसको भी हम पेस्ट करके इसको भी
देखते हैं एक बार।
यह रहा।
तो सिस्टम लॉक्स की हम बात करें जो जनरली
यूज़ किस लिए किया जाता है? अगर मैं हां
सिस्टम लॉक्स की बात करूं तो ये जनरली यूज़
किए जाते हैं फॉर ट्रबल शूटिंग एंड सिस्टम
हेल्थ मॉनिटरिंग। सिस्टम की ट्रबल शूटिंग
के लिए और सिस्टम के हेल्थ मॉनिटरिंग के
लिए जनरली ये यूज़ में लिए जाते हैं। पहले
में सिस्टम स्टार्टअप एंड शटडाउन इवेंट्स
हैं। पावर एंड रिबूट इवेंट्स हैं। ड्राइवर
एंड हार्डवेयर इवेंट्स हैं। डिस्क एंड
स्टोरेज इवेंट्स हैं। सर्विस कंट्रोल
मैनेजर इवेंट्स हैं। नेटवर्क एंड
कनेक्टिविटी इवेंट्स हैं। टाइम एंड सिस्टम
इंटीग्रिटी इवेंट्स हैं। क्रैश एंड एरर
रिपोर्टिंग इवेंट्स हैं। क्रिटिकल सिस्टम
हेल्थ इंडिकेटर इवेंट्स हैं। यह सारे आपके
नौ तरह के यहां पे विंडो सिस्टम लॉग्स के
इवेंट्स यहां पे हैं। अब इनमें अलग-अलग
इवेंट आईडीज़ हैं। जैसे सिक्स वाली सीरीज़
में इवेंट लॉग सर्विस 6005 है। तो इवेंट
का लॉक सर्विस स्टार्ट हुआ है। इवेंट का
लॉक सर्विस स्टॉप हुआ है। अनएक्सेक्टेड शट
डाउन हुई है। सिस्टम अप टाइम यहां पे इसको
डिनोट करता है। उसी तरीके से अगर 41 है तो
कर्नल पावर की वहां पे कर्नल पावर का इशूज़
है। यहां पे कुछ इशू आ रहा है। कर्नल
कर्नल के पावर से रिलेटेड 1074 है तो
प्लांट शटडाउन या रिस्टार्ट ठीक है ना
मतलब कि सिस्टम यहां पे इसका कर्नल पावर
का मतलब यहां पे देख लो सिस्टम रिबूूटेड
विदाउट क्लीन शटडाउन ठीक है पावर फेलियर
क्रैश या बीएसओडी कर्नल पावर से रिलेटेड
इशू है मतलब कि
पावर को अचानक से बंद कर दिया गया अचानक
से पावर इंटरप्ट हो गई है यानी कभी ऐसा
क्रैश हो गया कुछ भी हो गया उससे रिलेटेड
चीजें हैं तो इसका डिस्क्रिप्शन भी आपको
यहां पे दिया हुआ है 1074 प्लांट शटडाउन
मतलब सिस्टम शटडाउन जो है वो इनिशिएट किया
गया यूजर से। कर्नल पावर क्रिटिकल मतलब
क्रिटिकल पावर रिलेटेड कुछ इशू इशू जो है
वो आई है। उसी तरीके से ड्राइवर हार्डवेयर
रिलेटेड कुछ इवेंट आईडीज हैं। इनकी इनका
यहां पे इसका मतलब क्या होता है? और एक
डिस्क्रिप्शन यहां पे दिया हुआ है। उसी
तरीके से डिस्क स्टोरेज से रिलेटेड है।
डिस्क्रिप्शन दिया हुआ है आपका। फिर यहां
पे सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर एंड
डिस्क्रिप्शन दिया हुआ है। नेटवर्क के ये
सारे डिस्क्रिप्शंस आपको यहां पे किसके
लिए मिल जाएंगे? Windows के सिस्टम इवेंट
लॉक्स के बारे में आपको मिल जाएंगे। तो जब
भी आपको ये पीडीएफ मिलेगी जब भी आपको आज
के सेशन की ये नोट्स मिलेंगे तो आई वुड
रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबॉडी टू प्लीज गो विद द
रिकॉर्डिंग। इसके इस सेशन की तो
रिकॉर्डिंग को वापस देखना ही और इन पीडीएफ
इन नोट्स को इन इमेज को पढ़ के समझने की
भी कोशिश करना इवेंट लॉक्स। को हालांकि
याद करने की जरूरत नहीं है। टाइम के साथ
एंड एक्सपीरियंस के साथ आपको जो कॉमन एंड
बेसिक इवेंट आईडीज है वो याद हो जाएंगी।
सिस्टम लॉक चीटशीट की बात करें, सिस्टम
क्रैश या रिबूूट की बात करें तो 41 + 6008
+ 10001 ये तीन सिस्टम लॉक्स यहां पे काम
कर रहे हैं। डिस्क फेलर में ये चारों
सिस्टम लॉक्स आपके काम कर रहे हैं। सर्विस
फेलर में ये दोनों सिस्टम लॉक्स काम कर
रहे हैं। उसी तरीके ड्राइवर इशू है तो दो
सिस्टम लॉक्स आपके काम कर रही है। नेटवर्क
इशू है तो 10014 आपका सिस्टम लॉक जो है
डीएनएस क्लाइंट इवेंट्स वाली काम कर रही
है। एक प्रोट टिप है आपके लिए। प्रोट टिप
क्या है? यूज़ सिस्टम लॉग्स विद सिक्योरिटी
लॉग्स टुगेदर फॉर कंप्लीट विजिबिलिटी ऑफ़
इशूज़ एंड अटैक्स। तो मतलब आप एक एसओसी एल
वन है इफ यू आर एन एसओसी एल वन तो आप
सिस्टम लॉग्स को सिक्योरिटी लॉग्स के साथ
अगर आप कंबाइन कर देते हैं और उसको यूज़
करते हैं तो इस तरह से आपको इशूज़ ज्यादा
विज़िबल होंगे और अटैक्स को आप ज्यादा
अच्छे से मैप कर पाएंगे। ज्यादा अच्छे से
आपको अटैक्स के बारे में समझ आएगा। ठीक
है? तो यहां पे सिंपल से एक लाइन है सिंपल
सा कलेक्ट कोरिलेट इन्वेस्टिगेट एंड
रिजॉल्व ये आपको चार अ जो है स्टेप्स फॉलो
करने हैं टू सीज़ आई एंड आर टू सीज़ आई आर
इसको फॉलो कीजिएगा कलेक्ट कलेक्ट करिए
इवेंट को लॉग्स कोरिलेट कोरिलेट कीजिए उन
लॉग्स को बाकी लॉग्स के साथ इन्वेस्टिगेट
कीजिए एंड देन उसको रिॉल्व कीजिए दैट्स इट
व्हाट इज़ दैट द प्रोसेस दैट यू हैव फॉलो
बीइंग एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट एल वन आई आई थिंक
ये भी आपका क्लियर हो गया होगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है?
तो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ये था हमारा
Windows का
सिस्टम लॉ। एसओसी यूज़ केस की बात करें तो
डिटेक्ट सिस्टम क्राइसिस डिटेक्ट मलिसेस
सर्विस इंस्टॉलेशन। ये मैंने वैसे ही बता
दिया है। ये सब चीजें इसमें आती हैं।
लॉग्स को ऐसा कह सकते हैं कि लाइक वो ही
सोर्स ऑफ ट्रुथ है फॉर सिस्टम एंड।
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल लॉग्स आर एवरीथिंग।
एवरीथिंग। अब आते हैं एप्लीकेशन लॉक्स पे।
एप्लीकेशन लॉक्स की बात करते हैं यहां पे।
तो व्हाट दे ट्रैक? तो एप्लीकेशन लॉग्स
ट्रैक करते हैं ऐप के क्राइसिस को, एरर्स
को, सॉफ्टवेयर एक्टिविटीज को। एसओसी के
लिए रिलेवेंट क्यों होते हैं? ये डिटेक्ट
एक्सप्लइट अटेम्प्ट्स। अगर कोई एक्सप्लइट
अटेम्प्ट हो रही है उसको डिटेक्ट करते
हैं। आइडेंटिफाई मलिशियस ऐप बिहेवियर। अगर
कोई ऐप है जो मलशियसली बिहेव कर रही है
उसको भी ये आइडेंटिफाई करती है। तो
बेसिकली एप्लीकेशन लॉक्स का काम होता है
ऐप के क्रसेस को लॉक करना, एरर्स को लॉक
करना, सॉफ्टवेयर एक्टिविटीज़ को लॉक करना।
तो जैसे एग्जांपल के तौर पे देखें तो अगर
कोई एप्ली एप्लीकेशन है जैसे वर्ड क्रैश
वर्ड जो है वो क्रैश हो गई है। तो ये
एक्सप्लइट हो सकता है। हो सकता है कोई
एक्सप्लइट हो। कोई ट्राई कर रहा है इसको
क्रैश करने की। तो उसी तरीके से जैसे कि
बाकी हमने लॉक्स देखे। एप्लीकेशन लॉक्स भी
होते हैं। बहुत सारे होते हैं। अ
मैं ओपन [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कर लेता
हूं वर्ड। अगेन मैं इस पे बहुत ज्यादा
टाइम नहीं यहां पर हम वेस्ट करेंगे
क्योंकि यह बहुत सारे लॉग्स आईडीज होते
हैं। सारे इंपॉर्टेंट नहीं है। बट हां फिर
भी मैंने आपके लिए कुछ-कुछ यहां पे ला दिए
हैं जो आपको रेगुलर प्रैक्टिस के बेसिस पे
जब आप जॉब करेंगे जब आप इन चीजों को
रेगुलर डेली बेसिस पे देखेंगे तो आपको
बहुत सारी इंपॉर्टेंट चीजें जो है याद हो
जाएंगी। तो एप्लीकेशन में यहां पे क्या
होता है?
इंपॉर्टेंट एप्लीकेशन लॉग्स फॉर मॉनिटरिंग
एंड टबल शूटिंग। मॉनिटरिंग डबल शूटिंग के
लिए हमारे तो एप्लीकेशन यहां पे एक है
एप्लीकेशन स्टार्ट एंड जनरल इवेंट्स
एप्लीकेशन क्रैश एंड फ़ेलियर इवेंट्स
एप्लीकेशन इंस्टॉल एंड अपडेट इवेंट्स
सिक्योरिटी एंड परमिशन इवेंट्स परफॉर्मेंस
एंड रिसोर्स इवेंट्स देन एप्लीकेशन एंड
सिस्टम इंटीग्रेशन इवेंट्स ये सारे
इवेंट्स भी होते हैं। देन आपका ऑडिट एंड
लॉगिंग इवेंट्स होता है। एंड ये सारी
चीजें आपकी होती है। तो अब देखो अब इन
सारे इवेंट्स में बहुत सारे इवेंट्स हैं।
इवेंट आईडीज है जैसे 1000 है। तो
एप्लीकेशन में कोई एरर है क्या? एन
एप्लीकेशन क्रैश और स्टॉप्ड वर्किंग
अनएक्सेक्टेडली। कोई एप्लीकेशन क्रैश या
अनएक्सेक्टेडली वह वर्क करना अह बंद कर
देता है तो एप्लीकेशन एरर होगी वो और वहां
पे इवेंट आईडी जनरेट होगी 1000 की। अगर
कोई इवेंट आईडी जनरेट हुई है 1001 की तो
एप्लीकेशन हैंग कर रहा है टू की तो
एप्लीकेशन अनरिस्पांसिव है। थ्री की
एप्लीकेशन रीस्टार्ट हो रही है। फोर की
एप्लीकेशन स्टार्ट हुई है। फाइव की
एप्लीकेशन स्टॉप हो गई है। ये सारे इस तरह
के इवेंट आईडीज़ होते हैं। अब इन एप्लीकेशन
इवेंट आईडीज़ में कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट इवेंट
आईडीज़ जो है वो हैं 1000 जो कि एप्लीकेशन
एरर को बताते हैं। 1001 एप्लीकेशन के हैंग
का बताते हैं। 1006 एप्लीकेशन क्रैश को
बताते हैं।
26 नेट रन टाइम एरर नेट फ्रेमवर्क का रन
टाइम एरर कोई इशू आ रहा है डॉट नेट
फ्रेमवर्क का उसको बताते हैं। 1030
एप्लीकेशन इंस्टॉल का इशू कोई है मतलब
उसका बताते हैं। 1031 एप्लीकेशन अनइंस्टॉल
के बारे में बताते हैं। 1032 एप्लीकेशन
अपडेट के बारे में बताते हैं। 1033
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन चेंजेस के बारे में बताते
हैं। भाई किसी भी तरह का कॉन्फ़िगरेशन चेंज
हुआ है। 104 एक्सेस डिनाइड का के बारे में
बताते हैं। 1051 परफॉर्मेंस एरर के बारे
में बताते हैं। 2016 जो है सर्विस कॉमन
कम्युनिकेशन फेलियर के बारे में बताते
हैं। 173 लॉग राइट फेलियर के बारे में लॉग
रिटन फेलियर हुआ है कुछ ऐसा बताते हैं। ये
सारी चीजें होती हैं आपकी एप्लीकेशन लॉग्स
के अंदर। प्रोटेप की बात करें तो मॉनिटर
एप्लीकेशन लॉग्स रेगुलरली टू डिटेक्ट
क्रशेस, परफॉर्मेंस इशूज़, सिक्योरिटी
प्रॉब्लम्स एंड इंटीग्रेशन फेलियर्स
अर्ली। मतलब आपको रेगुलर मॉनिटर करना
चाहिए ताकि आप जो है क्रैशेस को जल्दी
डिटेक्ट कर पाएं। कोई परफॉर्मेंस इशू ना
हो एप्लीकेशनेशंस के वो सब डिटेक्ट कर
पाए। दैट्स इट।
मॉनिटर कलेक्ट इवेंट्स कंटीन्यूअसली।
कंटीन्यूअसली इवेंट्स को कलेक्ट करना है।
यही आपका काम होना चाहिए। कोरिलेट कोरिलेट
विद अदर लॉग्स। अदर लॉग्स के साथ कोरिलेट
कीजिए। अलर्ट सेट अलर्ट्स फॉर क्रिटिकल
इवेंट्स। जितने भी इवेंट्स क्रिटिकल
इवेंट्स हैं उनके लिए अलर्ट सेट कर दो।
उनके लिए अलर्ट का वो रियल रूल बना दो कि
भैया इन इवेंट्स पे अलर्ट आ जाए और फिर
इन्वेस्टिगेट करके रॉल्व कर दो। एज सिंपल
एस दैट। यह हमारी क्या थी?
Windows एप्लीकेशन लॉक्स। आई होप कि आपको
यह भी समझ में आ गया होगा। तो इवेंट लॉक्स
के बारे में मुझे सभी लोग जितने भी लोग
यहां पे देख रहे हैं, एक तो पहला काम
कीजिएगा कि लाइक ठोक दीजिएगा क्योंकि जस्ट
70 लाइक्स आर देयर वेरी वेरी लेस लाइक्स।
एंड दूसरी चीज बता दीजिए कि इवेंट लॉग्स
के बारे में आपको सब समझ में आ गया। इवन
अगर आप में से कुछ लोग ऐसे हैं जिनको
एक्चुअली में थोड़ी बहुत नहीं समझ में आ
रही है अगर आई होगी तो आई वुड रिक्वेस्ट
देम टू प्लीज रीवाच दिस वीडियो।
रिकॉर्डिंग इसको देखिएगा। नोट्स बनाइएगा।
जैसा कि मैं पहले भी आपको बोलता आ रहा हूं
कि नोट्स आपको खुद के भी बनाने हैं। सिर्फ
मेरे दिए हुए नोट्स पे डिपेंड नहीं रहना
है। वो नोट्स देने हैं। मैं कभी भी बंद कर
सकता हूं। मैंने कभी प्रॉमिस आपको नहीं
किया कि आपको नोट्स मैं सारे दूंगा। आई
हैव नेवर प्रॉमिस्ड बट स्टिल आई एम गिविंग
यू द नोट्स। तो कभी भी जब बंद हो जाएगी तो
आपके अपने नोट्स होने चाहिए जो आपको उस
समय जो है ऐसा ना लगे कि आप बिल्कुल लाचार
हो गए हैं। आपके पास कुछ भी नहीं है। तो
आपके अपने नोट्स होंगे तो उस समय आपके वो
जनक साबित होंगे एंड आपके लिए हेल्पफुल
रहेंगे। तो प्लीज नोट्स बनाइएगा। की
पॉइंट्स लिख के Lindin पे डालिए, टैग
कीजिए। Lindin वाली काम बहुत लोग कर रहे
हैं अभी भी। दैट्स गुड। प्लीज आप भी
कीजिए।
तो एवरीबडी प्लीज लेट मी नो। एवरीबडी
प्लीज लेट मी नो। सभी लोग जितने यहां पे
40 प्लस पीपल आर हियर। प्लीज लेट मी नो कि
आपको Windows इवेंट लॉक्स के बारे में सब
समझ में आ चुका है।
मैं तभी आगे बढूंगा जब मुझे रिस्पांस
आएगा। रिस्पांस तो देना पड़ेगा भाई।
यू हैव टू गिव द रिस्पों्ससेस गाइस। नहीं
तो काम कैसे चलेगा यह बताओ। लाइक नहीं
ठोका सबने यार। सही बात है।
जल्दी बता दीजिए। जल्दी बता दीजिए।
नहीं अभी भी सबके मैसेज सबके नहीं आया कि
समझ में आया कि नहीं? अभी भी सबके चैट
नहीं आया।
ऑल क्लियर
सर डिफरेंस बिटवीन बग बंटी सीरीज डीसी
एपीटी डीए यह लास्ट में मैं आपको बता
दूंगा। एक बार लास्ट में पूछ लीजिएगा जब
सेशन खत्म होगा तो ऑल क्लियर
बहुत बढ़िया। चलो अच्छी बात है। ऑल
क्लियर। ठीक है। चलिए लेट्स मूव टू द
नेक्स्ट टॉपिक। Windows प्रोसेससेस।
अभी तक हमने Windows इवेंट लॉक्स की बात
करी जिसको हम इवेंट व्यूअर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] में यहां पे
देखने वाले हैं। मतलब इवेंट व्यूअर में
आपको सब मिलेगा। अब हम Windows प्रोसेससेस
की बात कर रहे हैं। जब हम टास्क मैनेजर
ओपन करते हैं [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
कुछ इस तरीके से तो आपको यहां पे
प्रोसेससेस दिखते हैं। देखो यहां पे यहां
पे ये प्रोसेससेस का टैब है। इसमें आपको
सारे प्रोसेससेस जो ऐप एप्लीकेशन के
प्रोसेससेस हैं जो भी आप एप्लीकेशन यूज़ कर
रहे हैं वो सबसे टॉप पे दिखेगी। और साथ
में आपको बैकग्राउंड जितने भी प्रोसेससेस
हैं, जो बैकग्राउंड में काम कर रहे हैं,
वो आपको बैकग्राउंड प्रोसेससेस भी आपको
यहां पे दिखेंगे। ये सारे बैकग्राउंड
प्रोसेससेस दिखेंगे। राइट? तो सारी चीजें
आपको यहां पे प्रोसेससेस यहीं पे दिखेंगे।
इसके अलावा और भी चीजें हैं जो हम बाद में
डिस्कस करेंगे। सर्विज वगैरह जैसे इस पे
आएंगे हम यहां पे तो सर्विज हैं। बट
फिलहाल हम प्रोसेससेस पे फोकस करेंगे।
ओके?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अच्छा एक चीज
बताओ आप लोग जैसे आज मैंने कुछ ज्यादा
टॉपिक्स यहां पे इंक्लूड कर दिए हैं।
क्योंकि आप लोगों का ही कहना है कि सर
थोड़ी जल्दी ट्रेनिंग खत्म करो। तो मैं
ट्रेनिंग खत्म करने के चक्कर में क्वालिटी
में कॉम्प्रोमाइज तो नहीं कर सकता लेकिन
हां टॉपिक्स को बढ़ा-बढ़ा के आपको थोड़ी
वो जो ड्यूरेशन है थोड़ा जल्दी मैं आपको
करा सकता हूं तो टॉपिक्स बढ़ाने पड़ेंगे।
क्वालिटी कॉम्प्रोमाइज तो कभी भी नहीं
होगी। चाहे ट्रेनिंग में 100 साल लग जाए
ट्रेनिंग देते देते मुझे। नहीं 100 साल
ज्यादा बोल दिया है। चाहे 100 जन्म भी मैं
ट्रेनिंग दूं तो क्वालिटी में
कॉम्प्रोमाइज नहीं हो सकती है। लेकिन हां
कंटेंट मैं ज्यादा आपको एक बार में ला के
दे सकता हूं। अगर आप भी कैपेबल हैं उतनी
देर तक यहां पे रहने के लिए। तो आप में से
किसी को कोई इशू है क्या? अगर मैं ये
ज्यादा थोड़े कंटेंट ला जैसे आज की कंटेंट
थोड़ी ज्यादा है। आपको लग भी रहा होगा
शायद। तो आर यू हैविंग एनी इशू गाइस?
कोई प्रॉब्लम है आप में से किसी को या
मतलब ऐसा तो नहीं कि मेजरिटी लोगों को
प्रॉब्लम है। एक दो लोगों को प्रॉब्लम
होगी तो चलेगा उतना टेंशन नहीं लेना है।
लेकिन ऐसा नहीं होना चाहिए कि अब सबको
मेजरिटी को प्रॉब्लम ही हो रहा है। ऐसा तो
नहीं है मुझे वो बता दीजिए। नो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
50% समझ में आ रहा है। अगर आपको 50% आ रहा
है किड कार्टून करके तो आप प्लीज
रिकॉर्डिंग देख के वापस से देखिए। आपको
100% समझ में आ जाएगा।
नो प्रॉब्लम।
भूत बैंक एक ₹1 का है यहां पर ₹1 का
इन्होंने सुपर चैट किया है। धन्यवाद।
लेकिन ये ये कौन सा स्कीम है भाई? यह ₹19
का सुपर चैट कौन करता है? मतलब 19 क्यों
किया?
19 नंबर या तो 20 होता है, 15 होता है, 10
होता है, पांच होता है। यह 19 क्या होता
है यार? लकी नंबर लगता है इस बंदे का।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मजा आ रहा है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बढ़िया है
और 19 ये सुपर चैट तुम लोग करते हो तो
थोड़ा ध्यान से देना ध्यान देना जब भी सुपर
चैट करते हो थोड़ी ध्यान से सुपर चैट करना
कभी-कभी 19 जो आपने 19 लिखा है
उसकी जगह [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] पे
1900 ना हो जाए 19 हजार ना हो जाए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
तो ऐसा भी ध्यान रखना फिर वो बड़ी गड़बड़ हो
जाएगी
ठीक है। चलिए
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके।
ओके। सो ओके ग्रेट तो यहां पे पीतांबर
पीतांबर ने किया है 100 का सुपर चैट अ मैं
सुपर चैट के लिए नहीं बोल रहा मतलब मैं
नहीं चाहता कि कोई सुपर चैट करे कोई मतलब
नहीं बनता है सो प्लीज आप लोग सुपर चैट
नहीं भी करेंगे तो चलेगा कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है लेकिन थैंक यू वेरी मच पीतांबर फॉर दिस
सुपर चैट एंड [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इसकी जरूरत वैसे नहीं है मुझे मेरी जो
सुपर चैट होगी वो वैसे होगी कि आप में से
जितने लोग यहां देख रहे हैं एसओसी की ये
ट्रेनिंग एंड अगर आप में से किसी की जॉब
लग जाती है आने वाले टाइम में आपकी जॉब्स
लगती हैं एसओसी के अंदर में एल1 के एल1 के
उस पे तो दैट इज माय सुपर चैट बस इनफॉर्म
कर दीजिएगा मुझे बता जरूर दीजिएगा कि आपकी
जॉब लगी है एंड अगर हो सके पॉसिबल हो तो
लोगों को भी बताइएगा कि आपने एसओसी की ये
ट्रेनिंग देखी है यहां पे कंटेंट आपने
देखा है इसने कुछ ना कुछ आपकी हेल्प करी
है या कुछ ना कुछ एक रोल प्ले किया आपके
जॉब के लिए तो आप यह अगर बताते हैं तो
लोगों को एग्जैक्टली हमारे बारे में पता
चलेगा कि हम जैसे लोग किस तरीके की कंटेंट
प्रोवाइड करते हैं और हमारा एक
एडवर्टाइजमेंट होगा। मैं क्लियर कट खुल के
बात करता हूं। मैं कंपनी चला रहा हूं एंड
मैं कंपनी के एडवर्टाइजमेंट करना कभी भी
पीछे नहीं हटूंगा उसमें एंड ऑलवेज करता
रहूंगा। और उसमें भी जब हम जेनुइनली कोई
काम कर रहे हो कंपनी में हम जेनुइनली
चीजों को प्रोवाइड कर रहे हैं। किसी को
स्कैम ना कर रहे हो। किसी के पैसों को
बर्बाद ना कर रहे हो। किसी की क्वालिटी
सारी चीजें दे रहे हैं। फ्री में भी
क्वालिटी दे रहे हैं। तो एडवर्टाइजमेंट इज
मैंडेटरी एंड हम वो चीज चाहेंगे कि हम हर
जगह हर लोगों तक पहुंचे। जो भी साइबर
सिक्योरिटी या इससे रिलेटेड जितने भी
डोमेनस हैं उसमें अगर कोई एंथूजियास्टिक
है पढ़ना चाहता है तो वहां तक हमारी
वीडियोस, हमारी कोर्सेज, हमारी क्लासेस,
हमारी फ्री क्लासेस, पेड क्लासेस हर चीज
पहुंचे। इसमें आप ही हेल्प कर सकते हैं और
कोई नहीं कर सकता है। सो इट्स टोटली अप टू
यू। यही हमारी सुपर चैट है। बस दैट्स इट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
या हां, यही आपकी फी है। अगर आपको जॉब लग
गई, तो यही मेरी फी होगी इसके लिए। थैंक
यू वेरी मच। एंड स्टिल थैंक यू पीतांबर
फॉर द सुपर चैट। ₹100 का किया इन्होंने
सुपर चैट।
पीतांबर ओके ऑलरेडी गॉट रोल इन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी बिकॉज़ डिफ्रॉनिस ओनली। थैंक यू
सो मच पीतांबर। आई एम ग्लैड दैट यू आर
एडमिटिंग दिस एंड अ लॉट ऑफ़ पीपल एंड लॉट
ऑफ़ लर्नर्स एडमिट इट एक्चुअली। सो आई एम
रियली ग्लैड कि ऐसे भी लोग हैं जो जॉब
लगने के बाद भी डेफ्रोनिक्स को याद रखते
हैं क्योंकि मैं ऐसे भी लोग होते हैं जो
जो सब कुछ जिन्होंने करा है एंड वी
एक्चुअली सपोर्टेड देम सब कुछ बट दे नेवर
से कि डिफ्रॉनिक्स प्लेड एनेंट रोल। ऐसे
भी कई लोग हैं। लेकिन ऐसे लोग ज्यादा हैं
जो डिफ्रॉनिक्स को नोटिफाई करते हैं, जो
डिफ्रॉनिक्स को कोट करते हैं, डिफ्रॉनिक्स
के बारे में बोलते हैं। एंड आई एम रियली
ग्लैड कि ऐसे लोग प्रेजेंट हैं। सो थैंक
यू वेरी मच। आप लोगों के कारण ही
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स आज डिफ्रॉनिक्स है एंड इतनी
चीजें हम लेकर आ पा रहे हैं या हमारी
बिज़नेस अच्छी चल पा रही है। यह सब आपकी
वजह से है। सिंपल सा फंडा है। बिज़नेस में
पैसा कमाना होता है। पैसा लोग अर्न करते
हैं। पैसे रेवेन्यू जनरेट करते हैं। लेकिन
अगर कोई रेवेन्यू जनरेट करने के साथ-साथ
एक यूनिक ऑथेंटिक चीज़ आपको प्रोवाइड कर
रहा है। तो दैट इज़ दैट शुड बी कंसीडरेबल।
सिंपल सा फंडा है। जैसे कि अगर हम कंट्री
की बात करें, पॉलिटिक्स की बात करें तो
भाई पॉलिटिकल पार्टीज आती जाती रहती हैं।
कभी वो आएगा, कभी लेफ्ट, कभी राइट, कभी
कोई मिडिल वाला आएगा, कभी कोई भी आएगा।
लेकिन और सब खाएंगे। सब बैठ के सब खाएंगे।
कोई भी ऐसा पॉलिटिकल पार्टी नहीं है जो
खाता नहीं है। जो करप्ट नहीं है। हर
पॉलिटिकल पार्टी, हर पॉलिटिशियन कुछ एकाध
को छोड़ दो। एक दो को छोड़ दो। एक दो छोड़
दो। क्यों बोल रहा हूं? क्योंकि
एक्सेप्शनंस लाइ एवरीवेयर सब करप्ट है। बट
उसी में कोई करप्शन करते हुए भी अगर आपके
लिए कुछ अच्छा कर रहा है। आपके लिए कुछ
अच्छी पॉलिसीज ला रहा है। कुछ अच्छे लॉज़
बना रहा है। कुछ आपके लिए बेनिफिट की बात
कर रहा है और एक्चुअली उसको डिलीवर कर रहा
है। तो वही अच्छा पॉलिटिशियन या अच्छा
पार्टी है। एज सिंपल एस दैट सिंपल है ना?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] भूत बांग ने फिर
से ₹19 किया। अरे यार तुम 19 वाला काम है
ये।
धन्यवाद भूत बांग।
चलिए
अच्छा इन्होंने
YouTube वालों ने एक बढ़िया सिस्टम स्कीम
निकाल दिया है। पता है ना लोगों के लिए
मतलब जो सुपर चैट वाले लोग हैं उनके लिए
स्कीम निकाला है। ये गोल वाला। ये YouTube
ने क्रिएटर को अर्न करने का एक अच्छा
तरीका निकाल दिया। जैसे बहुत लोग होते हैं
कि गोल कि सुपर चैट बोलते नहीं है और गोल
सेट कर देते हैं। जैसे गोल में किया देखो
10 सुपर चैट्स जितने सुपर चैट्स आपको
कितने चाहिए तो 10 सुपर चैट्स तो मतलब कर
दिया और टिल एंड हायर मतलब कितना वो चाहिए
लाइक ₹100 के आसपास का 200 का तो मैंने
अगर 100 कर दिया टाइमर कितना कि 30 मिनट
में मुझे 10 सुपर चैट मिल जाए ₹100 का
यानी ₹1000 का टोटल हो गया शेयर हाउ यू
विल सेलिब्रेट तो यहां पे कर दूंगा आई विल
ब्रिंग नेक्स्ट
देखो यह मैं ऐसे ही लिख रहा हूं नेक्स्ट
एसओसी क्लास सूर यह कर दिया मैंने एंड
स्टार्ट गोल। तो यह YouTube ने स्टार्ट ये
YouTube ने करा हुआ है। यह मैंने पहले भी
शायद एक बार करा हुआ था। तो यह गोल
स्टार्ट हो गई। इसका मतलब हुआ कि अगर कोई
चाहे तो ऐसा काम ये कर सकता है। यह मैंने
ऐसे ही जनरेट किया है। आई थिंक जनरेट हुआ
है क्या? पता नहीं मुझे नहीं पता है जनरेट
हुआ है कि नहीं हुआ है। यहां तो 0 / 10
दिखा रहा है। हां शायद हो गया है। हां ये
देखो देखो हो गया। है जनरेट हो गई है। तो
यह एक अच्छा तरीका YouTube ने तो निकाल
दिया है। लेकिन हमारे हमारे केस में या
मेरे केस में इस केस इस चीज़ की ज्यादा वो
नहीं है। इस चीज़ में आप जॉब ले लीजिए। एक
एसओसी एनालिस्ट बन जाइए। एक एक सक्सेसफुल
एनालिस्ट बनिए। साइबर सिक्योरिटी में
डोमेन में अच्छा कीजिए। दैट्स द सुपर चैट
दैट आई एम एक्सपेक्टिंग फ्रॉम एवरीबॉडी
फ्रॉम एवरीवन। राइट?
चलिए [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब यहां पे Windows प्रोसेससेस के बारे
में हम बात करते हैं। लेट्स टॉक अबाउट द
Windows प्रोसेस। डेफिनेशन की बात करें। अ
प्रोसेस इज़ रनिंग इंस्टेंस ऑफ अ प्रोग्राम
विथ इट्स ओन। क्या-क्या चीजें इसकी अपनी
होती है? एक कोई रनिंग इंस्टेंस है किसी
प्रोग्राम का। प्रोसेस क्या होता है? किसी
भी प्रोग्राम का एक रनिंग इंस्टेंस होता
है। मतलब एक रनिंग इंस्टेंस जो हो रही है
जो चल रही है किसी भी प्रोग्राम सॉफ्टवेयर
का वो प्रोसेस होता है। एंड इस प्रोसेस का
अपना मेमोरी स्पेस होता है। मैंने पहले भी
बोला हुआ है। थ्रेड्स होते हैं, रिसोर्सेज
होती हैं। सिक्योरिटी कॉन्टेक्स्ट होता
है। यानी हर प्रोसेस जो है अपने आप में एक
मस्त चीज है। जिसका अपना खुद का एक मेमोरी
होता है। खुद के थ्रेट्स होते हैं। खुद के
रिसोर्सेज होते हैं। खुद के सिक्योरिटी
कॉन्टेक्स्ट मतलब सिक्योरिटी के
कॉन्टेक्स्ट में भी खुद का ही होता है।
ठीक है? दैट्स इट। अब
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सिंपल व्यू की बात करें
तो एक प्रोग्राम होता है जो कि आपके मान
लो हार्ड डिस्क पे या कहीं पे भी होता है।
तो उसको आप एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं। ये
बिकम्स अ प्रोसेस इन मेमोरी। जैसे आप
एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं इसका एक प्रोसेस जो
है मेमोरी में बन जाता है। एग्जांपल
Chrome.exee एक फाइल है। Chrome सॉफ्टवेयर
है। प्रोग्राम है। जैसे आप इसको रन करते
हैं एक Chrome.exe या Chrome की प्रोसेस
बन जाती है विथ पीआईडी। प्रोसेस आईडी विथ
क्या? एक प्रोसेस आईडी। प्रोसेस आईडी के
साथ Chrome की बन जाती है पीआईडी। सिंपल
एक प्रोसेस आईडी बन जाती है। Chrome का
प्रोसेस चलने लगता है। सिमिलर ये किस तरह
का है? जैसे मैंने यहां पे टास्क मैनेजर
ओपन किया।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तो अभी Chrome ऑलरेडी चल रहा है हमारा।
देखो यहां पर Chrome.exe यह एप्लीकेशन चल
रहा है ऐप और इसी के एक प्रोसेस भी आपको
दिखेगी। Chrome.ex देखो ये बैकग्राउंड
प्रोसेससेस है। जब हम नीचे की तरफ आते
हैं। बैकग्राउंड प्रोसेस भी मैं बता रहा
हूं और प्रोसेस भी बता रहा हूं। तो
प्रोसेस भी आपने देख लिया। अब यहां पे
देखो Chrome.exc ऐसे कुछ हो सकता है कि
Chrome.exec है ही नहीं। अरे अरे अरे यहीं
पे है ना? ये रहा एप्स के अंदर। हां
प्रोसेस यहीं पे बन रहा है ना? इसको
एक्सपेंड इसको एक्सपेंड करते हैं। ये
देखो। ये सारे इसके जो प्रोसेससेस हैं वो
चल रहे हैं। ये देख रहे हो आप सारे
प्रोसेससेस जो भी है वो चल रहे हैं। कितना
CPU ये प्रोसेस ले रहा है। कितनी मेमोरी
ये प्रोसेस ले रहा है। कित डिस्क की साइज
कितनी ये ले रहा है? नेटवर्क की क्या
स्पीड फच मतलब यूज़ की जा रही है इस
प्रोसेस के द्वारा। क्योंकि ये नेटवर्क से
रिलेटेड कुछ खास अभी यहां पे नहीं है। हां
जब हम वो कर रहे हैं तब है। लेकिन वैसे ये
सारी इनेशन यहां पे आपको प्रोवाइड करता
है। यहां पे आपको मिलता है। ठीक है? तो
दिस इज कॉल्ड
दिस इज कॉल्ड प्रोसेस। अब आते हैं की
कॉम्पोनेंट्स क्या होते हैं प्रोसेससेस
के? प्रोसेससेस जो भी होते हैं उनके की
कंपोनेंट्स क्या है? सबसे पहला की
कॉम्पोनेंट है पीआईडी। प्रोसेस आईडी मैं
यहां पे सॉरी
इसमें मैंने आपको दिखाया प्रोसेस में।
यहां पे जब भी पूरी ये प्रोसेससेस होती
हैं। लिस्ट मैं दिखा देता हूं। यहां पे
जैसे ये Chrome का यह प्रोसेस चल रहा है।
राइट क्लिक करते हैं। प्रॉपर्टीज पे चलते
हैं। यहां पे यह प्रोसेस चल रहा है।
Chrome.ex इसकी सारी डिटेल्स वगैरह आएंगी।
यहां पे यहां डिटेल्स से जाओगे तो यहां पे
सारी डिटेल्स इसका Chrome से रिलेटेड सारा
चीज आ जाएगा। अब इसी को मैं यहां पे
सॉरी यहां पे मैं दिखाता हूं तुम्हें।
हम यूज़र्स की लिस्ट में प्रोसेस
कहां गई यार?
हां ये रहा। डिटेल्स में आते हैं। इसकी
डिटेल्स में जो जो प्रोसेससेस चल रहे हैं
उनकी डिटेल्स में आते हैं। ये डिटेल्स
वाला टैब जो है इस पे आ जाइएगा। इसको मैं
थोड़ा इस पे क्लिक कर लेना। ये दिख आपको
दिख जाएगी। बेसिकली ये इसको करने पे दिखता
नहीं है सही से। इसको क्लिक कर लेना। दिख
जाएगी आपको। डिटेल्स वाले में आना है।
प्रोसेस है तो यहां पे ये डिटेल्स वाले
में आना। यहां पे देखो Chrome. चल रही है।
तो इसकी एक पीआईडी बनी हुई है। प्रोसेस
आईडी जनरेट हुई है। सो ये प्रोसेस आईडी जो
है वो क्या है? यूनिक है। राइट? ये
प्रोसेस आईडी क्या है? यूनिक है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके? दीज़ आर द यूनिक प्रोसेस आईडीज़। अरे
10 10 सुपर चैट कंप्लीट नहीं करने हैं। वो
मैंने ऐसे ही डाला हुआ था यार। उसको मैं
एंड कर देता हूं। रुको। उसको मैं एंड कर
देता हूं। वो मैंने ऐसे क्रिएट करके आपको
बताया था। कोई सुपर चैट की जरूरत नहीं है।
मैंने पहले ही बोला हुआ है। मैं यहां पर
एंड गोल कहां है? इसको एंड कैसे करेंगे?
रिमूव गोल
रिमूव गोल रिमूव्ड ऑल इन वन ने 20 का सुपर
चैट किया। थैंक यू वेरी मच ऑल इन वन। अरे
वो मैंने एंड मैंने वो सुपर चैट करने के
लिए नहीं वो स्टार्ट किया था कि आप लोग
सुपर चैट करो। वो मैंने करने के लिए किया
था। वो जनरेट हो गई। स्टार्ट हो गई थी।
उसको मैंने एंड कर दिया। ठीक है? अब मजे
अब मजे लो।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? डन। चलो अब टेंशन नहीं लेना
तुम्हें। अब यहां पर प्रोसेस चल रही है।
उसकी एक प्रोसेस आईडी है। वहीं यहां पर
प्रोसेस आईडी सेम प्रोसेस आईडी की यहां पे
बात हो रही है। ठीक है? तो चलिए
लेट्स गो प्रोसेस आईडी जो कि एक यूनिक
आइडेंटिफायर होता है। अब यहां पे जैसे कि
पीआईडी जो भी अब एक होती है यहां पे
कॉम्पोनेंट वर्चुअल मेमोरी। ईच प्रोसेस
गेट्स आइसोलेटेड मेमोरी। हर प्रोसेस को एक
मेमोरी मिलता है। उसको हम वर्चुअल मेमोरी,
आइसोलेटेड मेमोरी, वर्चुअल मेमोरी आप बोल
सकते हैं। यूज्ड इन प्रोसेस इंजेक्शन मतलब
प्रोसेस इंजेक्शन टाइप की एक अटैक होती
है। उसमें इन्हीं वर्चुअल मेमोरी को यूज़
में लेके एंड उसमें इंजेक्शन किया जाता है
एंड प्रोसेससेस कॉम्प्रोमाइज किए जाते
हैं। तो, यह एक तरह का अटैक है। हम आगे
उसके बारे में देखने वाले हैं। एक होता है
थ्रेड। यूनिट्स ऑफ एग्जीक्यूशन इनसाइड
प्रोसेस। मतलब वन प्रोसेस इक्वल टू
मल्टीपल थ्रेट्स। मतलब एग्जीक्यूशन के
टोटल नंबर ऑफ यूनिट्स। उस प्रोसेस को
कितने यूनिट्स में एग्जीक्यूट किया जा रहा
है? तो एक प्रोसेस को मल्टीपल यूनिट्स में
एग्जीक्यूट किया जा सकता है। एक प्रोसेस
को मल्टीपल थ्रेड्स के अंदर में
एग्जीक्यूट किया जा सकता है। वही हम
थ्रेट्स बोलते हैं। उसके बाद हैंडल्स होते
हैं। रेफरेंसेस टू सिस्टम रिसोर्सेज,
फाइल्स, रजिस्ट्री एंड नेटवर्क। हैंडल्स
का मतलब है उस प्रोसेस को जो हैंडल कर रही
है उसको रेफरेंस देना। रेफरेंसेस टू
सिस्टम रिसोर्सेज। जो भी सिस्टम रिसोर्सेज
हैं जो उसको हैंडल कर रही है उस प्रोसेस
को उसको रेफर करना उसको उसका रेफरेंस उससे
मिलता है आपको जैसे कोई फाइल हो गई या कोई
रजिस्ट्री हो गया या कोई नेटवर्क हो गया
वो सारी चीजें सिक्योरिटी कॉन्टेक्स्ट रंस
एज अ यूजर मतलब कि वो प्रोसेस किस तरह से
रन हो रहा है किस प्रिविलेज से रन हो रहा
है नॉर्मल यूजर के प्रिविलेज से या कोई
एडमिन या सिस्टम प्रिविलेज से या किस
तरीके के प्रिविलेज से रन हो रहा है तो वो
आपको बता देता तो ये कुछ की कंपोनेंट्स
हैं आपके प्रोसेससेस के। ठीक है? तो आई
होप कि आपको ये समझ में आ गया होगा।
प्रोसेस आईडी, वर्चुअल मेमोरी, थ्रेड्स,
हैंडल्स एंड सिक्योरिटी कॉन्टेक्स्ट। अब
यहां पे नेक्स्ट में मैं प्रोसेस
आर्किटेक्चर आपको यहां पे बताऊंगा थोड़ा सा
कि किस तरीके से प्रोसेस आर्किटेक्चर आपके
Windows में काम करता है। अब ये जो चीज़
आपके शायद माइंड से ऊपर कभी-कभी चली
जाएगी। लेकिन दीज़ आर वेरीेंट थिंग्स। एंड
जब आप इन चीजों को बार-बार प्रैक्टिस
करेंगे, वापस रिपीट करेंगे तो यू विल
अंडरस्टैंड एवरीथिंग। ये जो चीजें मैं
आपको बता रहा हूं यू विल अंडरस्टैंड इट।
आपको कोई बड़ी टेंशन वाली बात नहीं। थोड़ी
सी एक्सप्लोर करनी होगी। थोड़ी सी आपको
दिमाग अपना खुद का भी लगाना होगा। थोड़ा
प्रैक्टिस प्रैक्टिस करनी होगी। यू विल बी
अंडरस्टैंड। सबसे पहले यहां पे सिस्टम
आपका होता है। उसमें एक होती है sms.exee
sms.exec
अब ये क्या है? मैं आपको आगे यहां पे
बताऊंगा। अ बेसिकली
वेयर इज द
मैं आपको बताता हूं। हां ये sms.exee
जो है इसके बारे में मैं आपको बताऊंगा आगे
चलके। यहां पे आई थिंक
मैं आपको बताता हूं क्या एक्सैक्टली
एग्जैक्टली क्या होता है वो अभी हम उसको
देखेंगे sms sms exc देखो
हां देखो sms exc जो है ये एक प्रोसेस है
प्रोसेस फाइल इसका sms exex है पीआईडी की
इसकी एक रेंज होती है 500 से लेके 600 के
रेंज में जो जो भी पीआईडीस हैं वो sms exc
वाले प्रोसेस के होते हैं। इसका काम क्या
है? सेशन मैनेजर सब सिस्टम स्टार्ट्स यूजर
सेशंस एंड क्रिटिकल सिस्टम प्रोसेससेस। तो
जितने भी यूज़र्स के सेशंस हैं। ठीक है?
जितने भी यूजर्स के सेशंस हैं एंड सब
सिस्टम सेशंस हैं या आपके क्रिटिकल सिस्टम
प्रोसेससेस सबको स्टार्ट एंड मैनेज करने
का काम आपका sms.exe का होता है। वही चीज़
हम यहां पे कर रहे हैं कि जब हमारा सबसे
पहले सिस्टम आता है Windows प्रोसेस
आर्किटेक्चर। जैसे Windows का आर्किटेक्चर
था ना वैसे ही Windows के प्रोसेस का
आर्किटेक्चर हम यहां पे देख रहे हैं। तो
सिस्टम होता है। उसके बाद सबसे इनिशियल जो
हमारी अ प्रोसेस होती है वो sms.xe होती
है जो मास्टर प्रोसेस जिसको कहते हैं।
बाकी प्रोसेससेस को ये मैनेज करती है।
इसमें दो तरह के सेशंस क्रिएट होते हैं।
एक सेशन ज़ीरो क्रिएट होता है। एक सेशन वन
क्रिएट होता है। जो मास्टर आपका प्रोसेस
है एसएमएसएस उसमें दो तरह के होते हैं।
सेशन ज़ीरो सेशन वन। अब सेशन ज़ीरो में दो
तरह के प्रोसेससेस होते हैं। सीएसआरs.exe
और win init.exc और सेशन वन जो होती है
उसमें दो तरह के प्रोसेससेस भी क्रिएट
होते हैं। एक तो csrs.exe
कॉमन है आपका ये होता ही होता है। इसके
साथ विन logon.exc ये आपका क्रिएट होता
है। अब सेशन ज़ीरो की जब बात करते हैं तो
विनit.exec
जो है तीन तरह के सब प्रोसेससेस को
एग्जीक्यूट करता है। एक सर्विसेस की एक
एलsस की एक एलएस एआईएसo.exc
ठीक है lsio.exc
उसी तरीके से अगर हम सेशन वन की बात करें
तो Windows लॉग इन जो है वो एक आपका
स्टार्ट करता है सेशन या प्रोसेस यूजर
init.exc और यूजर init जो है
एक्सप्लोरर.exc को स्टार्ट करता है। तो
मैं आपको बताता हूं एक्सप्लोर.exc क्या है
एक्सैक्टली वो भी मैं आपको अभी दिखाऊंगा।
और इधर सेशन जीरो में वन यूनिट ने तीन
सर्विज एल्स और एलएसआईएसओ को एग्जीक्यूट
किया है यहां पे। ठीक है? एंड इसी में
सर्विसेस exc जो है वो sbc होस्ट exc
प्रोसेस को एग्जीक्यूट करता है। अब इन
सारे पूरे डायग्राम में ये पूरे चार्ट में
आपको कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट प्रोसेससेस हैं। जैसे
कि sms.exc ये आपका मास्टर प्रोसेस होता
है। जब भी आप सिस्टम स्टार्ट करते हो तो
सबसे पहले जो एग्जीक्यूट होने वाला
प्रोसेस है हमारा वो sms.exec
आपका मास्टर प्रोसेस। अब यही दो अलग
प्रोसेससेस को सेशंस को स्टार्ट करता है।
सेशन ज़ीरो वन। सेशन ज़ीरो में आपका एक
विनit.exe स्टार्ट होता है। अभी
सीएसआरs.exc
को भूल जाइए। ये कॉमन है दोनों में सेशंस
में तो इसको साइड करते हैं। ज़ीरो में
विनit.exc और वन में विन logon.exec अब
विन इन init जो है तीन अलग सब प्रोसेससेस
को स्टार्ट करता है। और विन logon यूजर
init.exc को स्टार्ट करता है। और विन इन
init रेस्पोंसिबल होता है सर्विसेस को
स्टार्ट करने के लिए। एल्स यानी
सिक्योरिटी लॉगिन सिक्योरिटी सिस्टम जो भी
सिक्योरिटी इनफोर्समेंट का काम वाला
प्रोसेस है वो एंड एलएस आईएसओ exc करके
प्रोसेस है उसको और सर्विज जो होती हैं
exc जो प्रोसेस वो स्टार्ट करता है svc
होस्ट जो कि मल्टीपल डिफरेंट वेरियस अदर
प्रोसेससेस को मैनेज करता है svcstexc
इसको याद रखिएगा svcstex ये बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट प्रोसेस है क्योंकि svc होस्ट
exc को जनरली अटैकर्स टारगेट करते हैं टू
प्लांट द मैलवेयर्स मैलवेयर्स को प्लांट
करने के लिए मैवेयर्स को एग्जीक्यूट करने
के लिए यह सबसे उनका फेवरेट प्रोसेस है
svc होस्ट exc ठीक है नाउ यूजर आई exc जो
है आपका प्रोसेस ये ही स्टार्ट करता है
एक्सप्लोरर exc यही एक्सप्लोररex प्रोसेस
है जो आपका ये पूरा जो आप सिस्टम चला रहे
हो ये जो डेस्कटॉप एनवायरमेंट आप देख रहे
हो ये जो दिस पीसी ओपन करते हो इसमें
चीजों को स्टार्ट करते हो तो ये सारा
एक्सप्लोरर डॉट exc ही आपका स्टार्ट होता
है। दीज़ ऑल आर एक्सप्लोरर जो आपका चलता
है। यही होता है आपका। तो जैसे आप टास्क
मैनेजर स्टार्ट करते हो ना टास्क मैनेजर
में जैसे मैंने टास्क मैनेजर देखो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
प्रोसेससेस पे चलते हैं। यहां पे प्रोसेस
में देखोगे तो आपको दिखेगा हमेशा टास्क
मैनेजर में कि एक प्रोसेस Windows
एक्सप्लोरर की हमेशा चल रही है। इसको
एक्सपेंड करोगे तो लॉग फाइल्स अभी चल रहे
हैं इसके अंदर में। बट Windows एक्सप्लोरर
की जो वो है प्रोसेस है वो हमेशा आपकी चल
रही है। सिंपल किसी भी प्रोसेस का अगर
आपको प्रोसेस नेम पता है तो आप उसको ऐसे
भी स्टार्ट कर सकते हो। Windows R प्रेस
करो और यहां टाइप करो एक्सप्लोरर.exc
अगर आप उस प्रोसेस को स्टार्ट करना चाहते
हो तो उस प्रोसेस का नाम अगर पता है तो आप
एक्सप्लोरर.exec या उस प्रोसेस का नाम लिख
के रन कमांड के थ्रू जो Windows का रन
यूटिलिटी है उसके थ्रू स्टार्ट कर सकते
हो। एंटर करोगे ये स्टार्ट हो जाएगा। उसी
तरीके से जैसे मान लो मैं करता हूं विन
वर्ड डॉट exc ये एक प्रोसेस है स्टार्ट
करता हूं ये वर्ड का प्रोसेस है वर्ड का
प्रोसेस नेम है तो विन वर्ड exc से वर्ड
स्टार्ट आपका हो जाएगा ये इस तरीके से
जैसे मैंने किया वर्ड पad exc आई आई डोंट
थिंक ये है कि नहीं उसका नाम ये नहीं है
उसका नाम आई थिंक ms paint होगा ms
paintex exc है क्या हां ms paint exc ये
प्रोसेस का नाम है तो ms paintexee से ये
आपका स्टार्ट हो जाएगा तो इस तरीके से
प्रोसेससेस को Windows R रन वाले चीज से
भी आप प्रोसेससेस को स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं।
इफ यू नो द प्रोसेस नेम दैट्स इट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
क्या हो गया भाई? सब लोग इतना कम
भाई एक्सपेक्टेड है। यह तो कोई इतना टाइम
तक नहीं रहता। डिसिप्लिन नहीं होता। सभी
सभी पावरफुल बना जाते सभी पावरफुल बन जाते
हैं। बिल्कुल सही बात मैं बिल्कुल सही
बोला। इतने कम लोग हैं इसलिए सर का एनर्जी
डाउन हो रहा है। नहीं नहीं मेरा एनर्जी
डाउन कभी भी नहीं होता है। मेरा जब मैं
देखो जब मैं एनर्जी डाउन की बात नहीं है।
जब मैं आपको कोई चीज पढ़ा रहा हूं, कोई
चीज सिखा रहा हूं, तो मैं आपको उसी लेवल
ऑफ
एक एनर्जी और उसी लेवल ऑफ क्वालिटी के साथ
आपको सिखाऊंगा। अगर नहीं सिखाना होगा तो
सिंपली कैंसिल नहीं सिखाऊंगा मतलब कैंसिल
कर दूंगा या छोड़ दूंगा सिखा रहा हूं तो
बिल्कुल लेकिन हां लेकिन यहां पर दिक्कत
यह है कि लोग जो आते हैं इनिशियली रहते
हैं बाद में वो अपना पेशेंस खो देते हैं।
सोचते हैं अरे यार बहुत लंबा हो गया ये तो
यार बहुत ज्यादा हो रहा है। वो बाद में
बेचारे थक के चले जाते हैं। सोचते हैं चलो
यार आगे रिकॉर्डिंग देखेंगे। बट इसी में
कुछ लोग ऐसे हैं जो कंटिन्यू रहते हैं।
वही आगे चल के कुछ अलग करते हैं। लिख के
रख लो इस बात को। क्लास में स्कूल में
बच्चे आते हैं। बंक मारने वाले भी होते
हैं। रेगुलर क्लासेस भी अटेंड करने वाले।
कई ऐसे रेगुलर क्लासेस वाले जो बच्चे हैं
उनमें से कई टैलेंटेड हमारे निकलते हैं
बच्चे एंड दे डू अ लॉट ऑफ़ थिंग्स इन देयर
लाइफ। तो देयर आर डिफरेंट पर्सपेक्टिव्स
ऑफ़ एव्री एक्शन। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हां।
लव यू टू ब्रदर।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। तो ये सारी चीजें आप याद रखिएगा। कुछ
चीजें जो कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट प्रोसेससेस जैसे
sms.excinit.execin
lgin.exc यूजर आई.exe एक्सप्लोर.exc
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] उसी तरीके से
एलs.exec svices.exec svc होस्ट.exc
ओके [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
नेक्स्ट अब यहां पे आते हैं Windows
प्रोसेस का लाइफ साइकिल।
क्या होता है? तो Windows की जो प्रोसेस
होती है जो भी प्रोसेस होती हैं उसके एक
लाइफ साइकिल होती है जिसमें पांच तरह के
चीजें पांच तरह की चीजें होती है। देयर आर
फाइव थिंग्स क्या होती है? ओके बिफोर वी
स्टार्ट दिस मैं कुछ खा लेता हूं थोड़ी सी
लड्डू टाइप चीजें क्योंकि आई आई थिंक आई
नीड टू ईट ऐसा लग रहा है मुझे। सो जस्ट
जस्ट जस्ट अ मिनट एक मिनट।
मैं यहीं पे हूं। जस्ट अ मिनट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके गाइस आई एम हैविंग बेसन का लड्डू
मैंने बताया आप लोगों को कि मैं बेसन का
लड्डू खाने जा रहा हूं। सो आई एम हैविंग
बेसन का लड्डू वन ऑफ माय फेवरेट
हम हम
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
डन
अब यहां से लड्डू कैसे दो आप?
मुझे बेसन के लड्डू मोतीचूर के लड्डू से
भी ज्यादा अच्छे लगते हैं। आई लव बेसन
लड्डूस।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां से
अगर मैं भेज पाता तो जरूर भेजता। [हंसी]
ओके ओके ग्रेट पीतांबर इज़ आल्सो लविंग।
बस यार थोड़ी बहुत सेशन के टाइम खा लो। बस
थोड़ी देर और है सेशन आपके उसके बाद
कंप्लीट हो जाएंगे। आपका इवेंट लॉग वाला
सेक्शन थोड़ा लंबा था। यह सेक्शन ज्यादा
लंबा नहीं है। आर्किटेक्चर थोड़ा सा है।
बस उसके बाद सर्विज एंड खत्म।
मैं तो हूं ही गुजराती। क्या बात है।
गुजरात वालों के लिए तो लड्डू बहुत
पसंदीदा चीज होती है। साथ में जलेबी
फापफड़ा और क्या-क्या वो तारक मेहता से
मैंने देखा है। तो उससे मुझे पता है कि
गुजरातियों को क्या-क्या चीजें जलेबी
फापफड़ा
तो यह सच्चाई सच है क्या कि जलेबी फापफड़ा
बहुत वहां पॉपुलर या बहुत ज्यादा लोगों को
पसंद होता है।
ओके चलिए अब आते हैं प्रोसेस लाइफ साइकिल
के ऊपर में। प्रोसेससेस जो भी प्रोसेससेस
हो रहे हैं जो चल रहे हैं आपके सिस्टम में
जो भी प्रोग्राम के सॉफ्ट प्रोसेससेस चल
रहे हैं वो सारे प्रोसेससेस की एक लाइफ
साइकिल होती है। उसमें पांच तरह के
स्टेजेस होते हैं। एक होता है न्यू,
एक होता है रेडी, एक होता है
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] रनिंग, एक
होता है टर्मिनेटेड एंड इसी रेडी एंड
रनिंग के बीच में एक वेटिंग का भी पीरियड
आपका होता है। तो समझते हैं ये पांचों
क्या है? अह न्यू अगर कोई प्रोसेस का
स्टेज न्यू है, न्यू स्टेज में है वह।
इसका मतलब है अ न्यू प्रोसेस इज़ क्रिएटेड
टू रन अ प्रोग्राम। इसका मतलब है जैसे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आपने नोटपड को स्टार्ट किया। आपने अ
Microsoft Office या मतलब वही यार
Microsoft Word को स्टार्ट किया। आपने मान
लो कि अ Windows VMware को स्टार्ट किया।
ठीक है? या आपने कोई भी एसआईएम सॉफ्टवेयर
टूल स्टार्ट किया तो उसका मतलब है कि अभी
एक प्रोसेस क्रिएट हुई है एक प्रोग्राम को
चलाने के लिए। न्यू स्टेज में यही होता
है। रेडी स्टेज में द प्रोसेस इज़ रेडी टू
रन। यानी प्रोसेस अब रन होने के लिए रेडी
है। रनिंग स्टेट में मतलब प्रोसेस रन कर
रही है और यहां पे एग्जिट हो के टर्मिनेट।
जब टर्मिनेट हो गई तो टर्मिनेट स्टेट में।
बट जब रेडी और रन स्टेट में है तो बेसिकली
क्या होता है यहां पे देखिए
रेडी है रनिंग है अब यहां पे एक प्रोसेस
का टाइमलाइन होता है लाइफ साइकिल होता है
वेटिंग का इसका मतलब क्या है द प्रोसेस
कैन नॉट रन ठीक है जब यह रेडी हो गया है
कैन नॉट रन मेनी रीज़ंस वेट फॉर वेट फॉर
फ्रॉम द यूजर और नेटवर्क वेट फॉर सिग्नल
ठीक है और सिंपली हैज़ रन टू ऑफेन द ओएस
कर्नल इंश्योरर्स फेयरनेस मतलब कि कोई
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] प्रोसेस है
[खांसने की आवाज़]
वो चल नहीं पा रहा है इस पूरे लाइफ साइकिल
में जैसे न्यू रेडी रनिंग और टर्मिनेट के
बीच में वो चल नहीं पा रहा है तो वो चला
जाता है वेटिंग पीरियड में वेटिंग वाले
स्टेज में ऐसा मल्टीपल रीजन हो सकता है या
प्रोसेस क्रैश किसी वजह से क्रैश कर रहा
है या हैंग कर रहा है प्रोसेस चल नहीं पा
रहा है ठीक है ना यूजर के साइड से कोई इशू
नेटवर्क के साइड से कोई इशू या फिर सिंपल
कर्नल जो है ओएस का कर्नल बोल रहा है कि
भैया तुम बहुत चल रहे हो, बहुत ज्यादा चल
रहे हो। डाउट हो रहा है मुझे तुम पे। तो
थोड़ा वेट कर लो, थोड़ा होल्ड करो। तो
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट रीज़ंस की वजह से चाहे वो
जेनेरिक रीज़ंस हो या सिक्योरिटी रीज़ंस हो।
यहां वेटिंग पीरियड में प्रोसेस कई बार
चला जाता है। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब Windows प्रोसेस के स्टेप बाय स्टेप के
फ्लो को समझते हैं। यूजर या सिस्टम
ट्रिगर्स एग्जीक्यूशन।
सिस्टम या यूजर जो है प्रोसेस के
एग्जीक्यूशन को ट्रिगर करता है। विन 32
एपीआई कॉल्ड Wind 32 Windows 32 एपीआई जो
जितने भी सर्विसेस प्रोसेससेस को चलाने के
लिए आपका एक उसके
पापा जी हैं वो उनको उनके एपीआई को कॉल
किया जाता है। कर्नल क्रिएट्स प्रोसेस
सब्जेक्ट्स विन 32 एपीआई के थ्रू सारी
चीजें इनिशिएट हो रही हैं आपकी। बेसिकली
मतलब कि मतलब हां भाई अब शुरू करो। अब
स्टार्ट करो इनिशिएट करो। कर्नल क्रिएट्स
प्रोसेस ऑब्जेक्ट। कर्नल प्रोसेस का
ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट करता है। मेमोरी एलोकेट
करता है। थ्रेड्स को क्रिएट किए जाते हैं
और प्रोसेस जो है एग्जीक्यूशन स्टार्ट
होती है। यानी प्रोसेस के एग्जीक्यूशन से
पहले भी बहुत कुछ है। ये सारे स्टेप्स
हैं। ये पांच स्टेप होने के बाद ही
प्रोसेस आपका एग्जीक्यूट होता है। दिस इज़
कॉल्ड स्टेप बाय स्टेप फ्लो ऑफ़ प्रोसेस
एग्जीक्यूशन। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
आईएम का मतलब होता है आइडेंटिटी एंड
एक्सेस मैनेजमेंट। दिस आर लाइक आपकी
आइडेंटिटी और एक्सेस को मैनेज करने का जो
भी पोर्टल या यूटिलिटी होती है वो आईएम
पोर्टल कहा जाता है। एडब्ल्यूएस
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वगैरह में इसको
काफी ज्यादा इसके बारे में पढ़ाई भी करनी
पड़ेगी आपको क्लाउड सिक्योरिटी में एंड
काफी ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट चीज होती है
क्योंकि वो एक मेजर सिक्योरिटी
यूटिलिटी है। आईएम कॉम्प्रोमाइज या कुछ
ऐसा हुआ तो पूरी की पूरी बैंड बज जाएगी।
सो दैट इज़।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? अब यहां पे इस चीज को थोड़ा समझते
हैं। पैरेंट चाइल्ड रिलेशनशिप।
पैरेंट चाइल्ड इधर फोकस कीजिए सभी लोग।
पैरेंट चाइल्ड रिलेशनशिप होता है। क्या जो
भी आपका प्रोग्राम है और प्रोसेस है
उसमें पैरेंट और चाइल्ड का रिलेशनशिप होता
है। कैसे? एव्री प्रोसेस इज़ क्रिएटेड बाय
अनदर प्रोसेस। तो जो भी प्रोसेस क्रिएट
किए जाते हैं वो किसी और प्रोसेस के
द्वारा क्रिएट किए जाते हैं। मतलब एव्री
प्रोसेस इज क्रिएटेड बाय अनदर प्रोसेस।
ठीक है? यानी कि एक्सप्लोरर.exe
Chrome.exe को स्टार्ट करता है। मतलब कि
जो एक्सप्लोरर exc है आपका एक्सप्लोरर
चलेगा। आपका कंप्यूटर चल रहा है तभी तो वो
Chrome Chrome को चलाएगा ना भाई। तभी तो
Chrome.exe भी चलेगा। एज सिंपल एज दैट। तो
हर एक प्रोसेस एक दूसरे प्रोसेस को
स्टार्ट करती है। बस इतना ही समझना है।
एसोसिएट्स की बात करें तो इफ पैरेंट
चाइल्ड चेन इज एबनॉर्मल यह सस्िशियस हो
जाता है। यानी कि पैरेंट चाइल्ड जो यह
कनेक्शन है यह एब्नॉर्मल आपको दिख रहा है।
इसका मतलब क्या हुआ कि विन वर्ड.x यानी MS
Word का एक प्रोसेस है। वह पावर शेल को
चालू कर रहा है। तो यहां पे यह सस्पिशियस
होना चाहिए। यह बात को समझ लीजिएगा। दिस
इज़ अ वेरीेंट थिंग दैट आई हैव दैट आई एम
टॉकिंग अबाउट राइट कि अगर कोई Windows
माने सॉरी MS Word जैसा प्रोसेस है वो
पावर शेल को चलाने लग रहा है या
एग्जीक्यूट कर रहा है तो यहां पे समझ
जाइएगा कि यानी MS Word में किसी तरह की
कोई वबिलिटी या एक्सप्लइट कोई एक्सप्लइट
है MS Word को एक्सप्लइट किया गया है टू
रन आर्बिटरी कमांड्स मतलब टू रन वेरियस
डिफरेंट C2 कमांड्स जो अटैकर की तरफ से आ
रहे हैं और आपका सिस्टम जो है वह कमांड
एग्जीक्यूशन के लिए या आरसी आपके ऊपर
रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन होने की संभावना
बढ़ चुकी है। आपका सिस्टम कॉम्प्रोमाइज
होने वाला है। तो ये पैरेंट चाइल्ड रिलेशन
मेंटेन रहना चाहिए। तब तक बिल्कुल सही है
सब कुछ। अगर ये इसमें कुछ गड़बड़ी है तो
गड़बड़ी है। फिर अटैक। ठीक है? ये इतना
इजी वे में मैंने समझाया।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां बात
करते हैं क्रिटिकल विंडोज सिस्टम
प्रोसेससेस की। कुछ क्रिटिकल विंडज के
सिस्टम प्रोसेससेस होते हैं। इसको हम वर्ड
में ओपन कर लेते हैं।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
आज [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मुझे देखना
है कि एंड तक कितने लोग रहते हैं। कौन-कौन
रहता है। मैं आज उसके नाम स्पेशली देखूंगा
कि एंड तक कौन-कौन रहता है। कौन मतलब इतना
धुरंधर कौन है जो लास्ट एंड तक टिक जा रहा
है आज। ठीक है। अरे भाई मक्खी जी मक्खी
कहां से आ गई यार? ये मक्खी कहां से?
मक्खियों का बहुत बुरा हुआ है यार।
मक्खियां आती है। कभी-कभी एक ही जगह पे
बैठने लगेंगे।
क्रिटिकल विंडो से कुछ Windows सिस्टम के
कुछ क्रिटिकल प्रोसेससेस होते हैं जो
एसेंशियल प्रोसेससेस होते हैं जिनकी जरूरत
होती है Windows को ताकि Windows स्मूथली
जो है वो रन कर पाए। तो उसको हम देखते हैं
यहां पे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एक प्रोसेस होती है जिसका नाम है
सिस्टम। इसकी प्रोसेस फाइल होती है NTOS
कर्नल मतलब NT यह NT जो होते हैं ना
Windows NT का Windows NT जो है उस वही
बात है यहां पे OS ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कर्नल
कर्नलX
ठीक है इसकी प्रोसेस आईडी जो रेंज होती है
4 से 500 तक की जितनी प्रोसेस आईडी है वो
सारी इसी प्रोसेस की बिलॉन्ग करती है इससे
बिलोंग करती है इसमें क्या होता है द
Windows NTOS कर्नल ये क्या करता है
मैनेजेस हार्डवेयर मेमोरी प्रोसेससेस
सिस्टम यूज़ सारा कुछ ये मैनेज करता है
क्रिटिकल चीज़ होती है यह। सिस्टम विल
क्रैश इमीडिएटली बीएसओआईडी। अगर इंपैक्ट
हुआ मतलब इसका इंपैक्ट क्या है? अगर इसको
टर्मिनेट किया गया इसको या इसको बंद किया
गया तो तुरंत बीएसओआईडी स्टार्ट हो जाएगी
या सिस्टम क्रैश कर जाएगा। उसी तरीके से
एसएमएs.ex जिसके बारे में मैंने पहले बात
की थी। 500 से 600 का पीआईडी प्रोसेस आईडी
इसके रेंज में आती है। यानी 500 से 600 के
अंदर में जितने भी अदर्स प्रोसेस चल रहे
हैं, वह इसी प्रोसेस के द्वारा चलाया
जाएगा। ये सेशन मैनेजमेंट और ये सब चीजें
करता है। यूजर के सेशंस वगैरह स्टार्ट
करता है। सिस्टम फेल हो जाएगा। ये शट डाउन
हो जाएगा। अगर आप इसको बंद करेंगे।
crss.exc जो मैंने उस टाइम में बात की थी।
ये क्या होता है? बेसिकली क्या होता है?
crsx 600 से 900 तक की प्रोसेस आईडी सारी
इसी में होती है। क्लाइंट सर्वर रन टाइम
सब सिस्टम हैंडल करता है। यह विन 32 सब
सिस्टम हैंडल करता है। कंसोल विंडोज़
वगैरह हैंडल करता है। एप्लीकेशन एंड
सिस्टम यूआई विल मतलब जितने भी एप्लीकेशन
और यूआई एप्लीकेशन या सिस्टम के यूआई
वगैरह होते हैं जो आपको दिखता है सामने
यूजर इंटरफ़ेस वो सब बंद करना काम करना बंद
कर देगा। उसी तरीके से win init.xee होती
है 900 से 1000 Windows इनिशियलाइज़ेशन
प्रोसेस होती है। स्टार्ट सर्विसेस एंड
यूज़र आई नीट.exe
Windows को सर्विसेस को स्टार्ट करना
यूज़र्स की सर्विज को स्टार्ट करने का उसका
जो प्रोसेस होता है यूजर यूनिट उसको
स्टार्ट करता है। ये सब कुछ होता है। उसी
तरह से सर्विज जो होती है वो सर्विज के
लिए होती हैं। एल्स एस जो होता है एल्स
लोकल सिक्योरिटी ऑथॉरिटी सब सिस्टम जो
बेसिकली किसके लिए होती है? ऑथेंटिकेशन
सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसीज वगैरह जो चला स्टार्ट
करती है वो प्रोसेस है। इसको बंद किया तो
लॉग इन वगैरह फेल हो जाएगा। सिक्योरिटी
फंक्शनंस स्टॉप हो जाएंगे। और एक चीज बाकी
तो बहुत सारे हैं बट मैं यहां पे
इंपॉर्टेंट कुछ चीजें sbc होस्ट.ex ये
1000 से 6000 प्लस तक की जितने भी पीआईडीज
हैं वो सब sbc होस्ट.exc
के तरफ से मैनेज हो रही है। यह जेरिक
होस्ट प्रोसेस है फॉर Windows सर्विज
मल्टीपल इंस्टेंसेस रन क्रिटिकल सर्विसेस।
यह एक जेनेरिक होस्ट प्रोसेस है। मतलब यह
होस्ट का प्रोसेस है। Windows सर्विज के
लिए जितनी भी Windows सर्विज हैं, उसका यह
प्रोसेस है। एंड बेसिकली मल्टीपल
इंस्टेंसेस इसमें चलते हैं क्रिटिकल
सर्विज के। एंड यह इसलिए काफी ज्यादाेंट
हो जाता है। दैट इज़ वेरी वेरीेंट बिकॉज़
इसी के अंदर में जो है अ मैलवर्स को हाइड
किया जाता है अटैकर के द्वारा एंड ट्राई
किया जाता है कॉम्प्रोमाइज करने का। इसको
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब आते हैं एक्सप्लोररex यह वही है आपका
2000 से 4000 पीडी Windows का एक्सप्लोरर
हो गया डेस्कटॉप हो गई टास्क बार हो गया
स्टार्ट मेनू हो गया या आप सीडी ड्राइव
मतलब जो Windows का आप डेस्कटॉप देख रहे
हैं टास्क बार नीचे का देख रहे हैं
स्टार्ट आप देख रहे हैं या आप
अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जो सीडी
ड्राइव ओपन करते हैं Windows वो सब कुछ
इसी प्रोसेस में है। आपने इसको स्टॉप किया
तो आपका सब बंद हो जाएगा। उसी तरीके से
यहां पर और भी प्रोसेससेस हैं। बेसिकली
जिनके यहां पर डिटेल्स दिए गए हैं। आई
रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबॉडी टू प्लीज गो थ्रू दी
थिंग्स। प्लीज गो थ्रू दीज़
प्रोसेससेस एंड इनके बारे में थोड़ा पढ़िए
जरूर। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। वार्निंग डू नॉट एंड दीज़ प्रोसेससेस।
टर्मिनेटिंग क्रिटिकल सिस्टम प्रोसेससेस
कैन कॉज़ सिस्टम इन कैन कॉज़ सिस्टम
इनस्टेबिलिटी, डेटा लॉस और कंप्लीट ओएस
फेलर। अगर आपने कुछ सिस्टम सर्विज को
सिस्टम प्रोसेससेस को अगर आपने स्टॉप किया
तो हो सकता है आपका सिस्टम क्रिटिकल
सिस्टम्स जो है आपका काम करना बंद कर दे
ओएस फेल हो जाए ये सब चीज हो जाए तो प्लीज
ऐसा काम मत कीजिएगा ठीक है हाउ टू
आइडेंटिफाई क्रिटिकल प्रोसेससेस चेक द
प्रोसेस फाइल लोकेशन अगर कोई प्रोसेस की
फाइल लोकेशन सी ड्राइव में Windows के
अंदर में है या Windows के अंदर भी किसी
और डायरेक्टरी में है जैसे सिस्टम 32 या
किसी और डायरेक्टरी में तो वो सिस्टम
प्रोसेससेस जनरली होते हैं। अब इसको कैसे
चेक करते हैं भैया? जैसे मेरा टास्क टास्क
बार है। ठीक है? मैंने टास्क मैज ओपन
किया। अब मान लो कोई प्रोसेस है। तो
Chrome का ये प्रोसेस है। ये Chrome अब
इसकी मैं लोकेशन देखूंगा। राइट क्लिक
करूंगा। ओपन फाइल लोकेशन। ये प्रोसेस ये
लोकेशन है। मैं इसको ओपन करूंगा तो ये
मुझे लोकेशन बताएगा। तो ये कहां पे है? ये
सी ड्राइव में प्रोग्राम फाइल्स में
Google Chrome Chrome एप्लीकेशन इसके अंदर
आ रही है। तो ये कोई खास बहुत ज्यादा
सिस्टम से रिलेटेड कोई प्रोसेस नहीं है।
अब मैं नीचे की तरफ आता हूं यहां पे एंड
कोई और प्रोसेस देखते हैं।
अ चलो यहां देखते हैं। ये रही Windows
सिक्योरिटी नोटिफिकेशन या हां इसको देखते
हैं। इसको करते हैं। राइट क्लिक करते हैं।
ओपन फाइल लोकेशन। जब इसको ओपन करेंगे तो
ये देखो Windows के सिस्ट C के Windows के
सिस्टम 32 में इसका लोकेशन दिख रहा है।
यानी कि ये एक सिस्टम प्रोसेस है एंड इट
कैन बी क्रिटिकल। इसको आप बंद या क्लोज
एंड नहीं कर सकते हैं। नहीं करना चाहिए।
इट मे कॉज सिस्टम फेलर, ओएस फेलर और एनी
काइंड ऑफ़ सर्विसेस फेलर व्हिच इज़
डिपेंडेंट ऑन दिस पर्टिकुलर अ प्रोसेस। तो
ये सब आपको काम नहीं करना है। ठीक है? तो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ये चीजें आप
फाइल लोकेशन ओपन करके देख पता लगा सकते
हैं कि कौन सा प्रोसेस एग्जैक्टली सिस्टम
प्रोसेस है या नॉर्मल प्रोसेस है। बेस्ट
प्रैक्टिस [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] क्या
होती है? रेगुलरली मॉनिटर सिस्टम
प्रोसेससेस कीप Windows एंड ड्राइवर्स
अपडेटेड। Windows और ड्राइवर्स को दोनों
को अपडेट रखिए। हमेशा प्रोसेस को मॉनिटर
कीजिए।
सिक्योरिटी सॉफ्टवेयर्स
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] को यूज़ कीजिए।
हालांकि Windows के केस में Windows
डिफेंडर इज़ द मोस्ट
सिक्योर ऑपरेटिंग Windows सिक्योरिटी
सॉलशंस काफी अच्छा एक सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन
है। फिर भी आप अलग यूज़ करना चाहें। इट्स
टोटली अप टू यू। इन्वेस्टिगेट अनोन
सस्फिशियस प्रोसेस। इन्वेस्ट अननोन और
सस्िशियस प्रोसेससेस को इन्वेस्टिगेट
कीजिए। अब इन प्रोसेससेस के लिस्ट में
यहां पे आपको टैग मिला थाेंस में। कुछ
क्रिटिकल थे, कुछ हाई कैटेगरी के थे, कुछ
मीडियम, कुछ लो कैटेगरी के थे। तो
क्रिटिकल मतलब ओएस के ऑपरेशन के लिए वह
इंपॉर्टेंट थे। हाई मतलब इंपॉर्टेंट फॉर
कोर फंक्शनैलिटीज़। मीडियम का मतलब है कि
इंपॉर्टेंट तो है बट सिस्टम इनके बिना भी
फंक्शन कर सकता है। लो का मतलब है इसकी
कोई जरूरत भी नहीं है। चलता रहेगा। ठीक
है? बस सिंपल। अब यहां पे एक चीज़ है ऑलवेज
क्रिएट अ सिस्टम रिस्टोर पॉइंट बिफोर
मेकिंग एनी चेंजेस टू सिस्टम प्रोसेससेस
और सर्विसेस। हमेशा सिस्टम रिस्टोर पॉइंट
बना के एक रखिए। सिस्टम रिस्टोर पॉइंट
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट चीज होती है। अगर नहीं
पता आपको तो मैं आपको इसका तरीका बता देता
हूं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे सिस्टम
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन या व्यू एडवांस सिस्टम
सेटिंग्स इसमें आप चले जाइएगा। जब व्यू
एडवांस सिस्टम सेटिंग में जाएंगे यहां पे
तो इस तरीके का कुछ इनेशन आपको यहां देखने
को मिलेगा। कंप्यूटर नेम पे यहां पे
कंप्यूटर नेम वगैरह आपको दिख जाती है।
यहां पे लास्ट में हार्डवेयर के यहां पे
डिटेल्स आ जाते हैं। डिवाइस मैनेजर वगैरह
एडवांस में यहां पे परफॉर्मेंस यूजर
प्रोफाइल स्टार्टअप एंड रिकवरी ये ऑप्शन
सबको मिल जाते हैं। एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल
मिल जाता है। इसी के साथ यहां पे एक ऑप्शन
होता है सिस्टम प्रोटेक्शन का। ये है आपका
सिस्टम रिस्टोर पॉइंट क्रिएट करने का जगह।
सिस्टम प्रोटेक्शन पे जब जाएंगे तो यहां
पे आपको जो भी आपका सिस्टम जिसमें
इंस्टॉल्ड है वो ड्राइव दिखेगी। जैसे उस
पे आगे सिस्टम लिखा रहेगा यानी Windows
जिसमें इंस्टॉल्ड है और दूसरी जो आपने
पार्टीशन बना रखी है जैसे डी है तो जो
आपका सिस्टम वाला पार्टीशन है जिस पे
विंडो इंस्टॉल्ड है उसकी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
प्रोटेक्शन हमेशा ऑन रहनी चाहिए इट शुड
ऑलवेज बी ऑन तभी आपका रिस्टोर पॉइंट बनेगा
क्रिएट होगा ठीक है अदरवाइज़ इट विल नॉट बी
क्रिएटेड ऑटोमेटिकली तो ये हमेशा ऑन
रखिएगा कभी भी ऑफ यहां पे हो तो इसको ऑन
कर दीजिएगा सिंपल सा फंडा है कॉन्फ़िगर
कीजिएगा यहां पे तो यहां पे आपको ऑन ऑफ
करने का ऑप्शन मिल जाएगा। आप देख सकते हैं
यहां पे करंट यूसेज 6.84GB यहां पे यूज़
हुआ है। टर्न ऑन सिस्टम प्रोटेक्शन दैट्स
इट। और इसी के साथ यहां पे क्रिएट का
ऑप्शन है। तो यहां पे क्रिएट अ रिस्टोर
पॉइंट राइट नाउ मतलब अगर आप का मान लो
लेट्स सपोज कि कभी आपने देखा ऑफ है और जब
ऑन करोगे ऑटोमेटिकली ये कभी करेगा टाइम
लगेगा। आपको तुरंत क्रिएट करना है सिस्टम
रिस्टोर तुरंत क्रिएट कर दीजिए। ये आपकी
तब हेल्प करेगा जब आपका सिस्टम क्रैश हो
गया। कोई प्रॉब्लम आ गई। सारे डेटा उड़ गए
हैं या कुछ ऐसा हो गया। तो लास्ट जो भी
आपका रिस्टोर
आपका यहां पर रिस्टोर पॉइंट बना होगा
लास्ट डेट में जैसे मेरा आज अगर इशू हुआ
क्रैश हुआ और मेरा कल सिस्टम बिल्कुल सही
था तो कल के कल के डेट में अगर कोई
रिस्टोर पॉइंट बना है तो आप इसको जो है इस
ऑप्शन से एडवांस में यहां पे आपको दिख रहा
है स्टार्टअप एंड रिकवरी इस ऑप्शन से
स्टार्टअप एंड रिकवरी वाले यहां से
कॉन्फ़िगर कर सकते हैं कि डिफ़ॉल्ट ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम कौन क्या है? क्या चीज़ हैं? ये सब
आप कॉन्फ़िगर कर सकते हैं। और इसको रिबूूट
करेंगे जब आप जब आप सिस्टम रिबूूट करते
हैं और उस टाइम में रिकवरी वाली रिबूूट जब
करेंगे तो वहां पे आपको सिस्टम रिस्टोर
पॉइंट से रिस्टोर करने का ऑप्शन मिल
जाएगा। एंड आप अपने रिस्टोर पॉइंट को यूज़
करके सिस्टम को बैक डेट में लेके जा सकते
हैं। एंड सारी आपकी इशूज़ है वो रिॉल्व हो
जाएंगी। आई होप कि आपको ये चीज समझ में आ
गया हो। ठीक है?
चलिए [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ये क्लियर हो गया। अब यहां पर आते हैं
Windows के प्रोसेस ट्री के बारे में।
हालांकि जो मैंने चीजें आपको बताई है वही
चीजें यहां पे हैं। प्रोसेस ट्री में जैसे
SMS.exec तो कुछ इस तरीके से प्रोसेस ट्री
दिखती है। यानी कि एक पहले आपका मेन
प्रोसेस होता है। फिर सब प्रोसेससेस होते
हैं। फिर उसके चाइल्ड प्रोसेससेस होते
हैं। ठीक है? तो sms.exc मेन प्रोसेस है।
उसमें दो तरह के सब प्रोसेस हैं। cआरएs
csrs.exc
और win unit.x और विन यूनिट.exc के भी
अपने सब प्रोसेससेस तीन हैं। सर्विसेस
एल्स एसबीसीओस ये सब चीजें। ठीक है? तो ये
सारी प्रोसेस है। एसओसी का यूज़ केस क्या
है भैया? कोई भी डेविएशन हुआ इस प्रोसेस
ट्री में किसी भी तरह का डेविएशन चेंजज़
हुआ तो इसका मतलब है आपको इन्वेस्टिगेशन
करनी है। एग्जांपल अगर winword.exe यानी
Microsoft Word का cmd.exee ओपन कर रहा
है। फिर ये पावर शेल्क ओपन कर रहा है तो
यहां पे गड़बड़ है। इसमें इन्वेस्टिगेशन
जरूरी है। प्रोसेससेस के भी टाइप्स होते
हैं। एक यूजर प्रोसेस होता है, सिस्टम
प्रोसेस होता है, बैकग्राउंड प्रोसेस होते
हैं। तीन तरह के प्रोसेस होते हैं। यूजर
प्रोसेससेस में जो भी आप एप्लीकेशन,
सॉफ्टवेयर्स यूज़ करते, स्टार्ट करते हैं
वो सारे आ जाते हैं। सिस्टम प्रोसेससेस
में जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के लिए रिक्वायर्ड
प्रोसेससेस हैं जो सिस्टम लेवल प्रोसेससेस
हैं जैसे मैंने बताया थोड़ी देर पहले जो
इंपॉर्टेंट बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट प्रोसेससेस
हैं वो सारे आ जाते हैं। और बैकग्राउंड
प्रोसेससेस में जो बैकग्राउंड में
सर्विसेज चल रही हैं जो आपके सामने नहीं
दिख रही हैं। बट बैकग्राउंड में वो सर्विज
चलनी इंपॉर्टेंट है। जैसे अगर आपका
वाईफाई ब्लूटूथ आप यूज़ कर रहे हैं तो
वायरलेस सर्विज अगर नहीं चल रही हैं तो आप
उनको यूज़ नहीं कर पाएंगे। हाइपरवाइजर की
सर्विस नहीं चल रही तो आप अह Windows की
काइंड ऑफ़ जो वर्चुअल एनवायरमेंट्स
सॉफ्टवेयर्स हैं, बाकी चीजें हैं, उनको आप
यूज़ नहीं कर पाएंगे। तो, यह चीजें जो हैं,
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
टाइप्स होती हैं। प्रोसेस के टाइप्स। अब
प्रोसेस बेस्ड कुछ अटैक्स भी होते हैं। जब
प्रोसेस की बात करते हैं, तो प्रोसेस पे
बेस्ड कुछ अटैक्स होते हैं। ठीक है?
इसमें पहला होता है प्रोसेस इंजेक्शन।
इसका मतलब क्या है? इंजेक्ट कोड इंटू अनदर
प्रोसेस। इससे अटैकर कोड को इंजेक्ट करता
है मलेशियस कोड को दूसरे प्रोसेससेस के
अंदर में एग्जांपल मैलवेयर है इंजेक्ट
किया एक्सप्लोरx में एक्सप्लोरx में
मैलवेयर को इंजेक्ट कर दिया यानी कि जब भी
आपका सिस्टम ऑन होगा और कभी आप कोई ड्राइव
खोलने जा रहे हैं या डेस्कटॉप आपका ओपन हो
रहा है कुछ भी तो वो एक्सप्लोरex से ही
चालू होता है तो जैसे ही आपका सिस्टम
स्टार्ट हुआ आपका मेलवेयर स्टार्ट हो
जाएगा यह होता है प्रोसेस इंजेक्शन एसओसी
इंडिकेटर में क्या आएगा सस्िशियस चाइल्ड
प्रोसेससेस कुछ सस्पिशियस चाइल्ड
प्रोसेससेस बन रहे हैं मेमोरी एनोमिलिस
मेमोरीज अलग-अलग तरह के मेमोरीज एलोकेट हो
रहे हैं जो यूजुअली नहीं होने चाहिए। फिर
आता है डीएलएल इंजेक्शन डायनेमिक लिंक
लाइब्रेरी इंजेक्शन। ये इसमें क्या होता
है? मलिशियस डीएलएल्स को इंजेक्ट किया
जाता है। डीएलएल्स में मलिशियस डीएलएस
इंजेक्ट किए जाते हैं। ये बस नाम मैं आपको
बता रहा हूं। ये सारे प्रोसेस इंजेक्शन
डीएल इंजेक्शन। इसको बस थोड़ा सा
हल्काफुल्का एक्सप्लोर कीजिएगा। बहुत
ज्यादा आपको ऐसी कोई अभी रिक्वायरमेंट
नहीं पड़ेगी। एज एसओसी एल वन आपको इन सब
में डीप जाके और डीप नॉलेज की इतनी
रिक्वायरमेंट मैं आपको एक्चुअल चीजें बता
रहा हूं। आप पढ़ लो, आप डीप चले जाओ उसके
बारे में और डीप जाके मास्टर कर लो। दैट
दैट वुड बी टोटली फाइन। वो आपके ऊपर है।
आपकी चॉइस है। बट मैं आपको बस एसओसी एल1
के पर्सपेक्टिव से बता रहा हूं कि इसमें
बहुत ज्यादा घुसने की जरूरत नहीं है। नाम
कुछ पता हो कि भैया यहां प्रोसेस बेस्ड
अटैक्स होते हैं। कहीं प्रोसेस इंजेक्शन
होता है, डीएलएल इंजेक्शन होता है।
प्रोसेस फॉलोइंग होता है। इसका मतलब कि
स्टार्ट लेजिट प्रोसेस रिफ्लेक्ट्स इट्स
मेमोरी। लेजिट प्रोसेस स्टार्ट होगा बट
मेमोरी को रिप्लेस कर दी जाएगी। जैसे
नोटपड exc रिप्लेस्ड विथ मलवेयर। अब नोटपड
exec तो स्टार्ट हो रही है बट एक्चुअली
में मैलवेयर ने उसको रिप्लेस कर दिया।
मैलवेयर उसके अंदर काम कर रही है। दैट्स
इट।
नीरज पायवाल बग बंटी क्लासेस इज़ गुड। या
आई नो दैट्स गुड। और एक प्रोसेस पे अटैक
होता है लॉल बींस लिविंग ऑफ द लैंड। इसमें
क्या हो जाते हैं? यूजिंग लेज़िट टूल्स
जैसे पावर extxc cmd.exc रन dl 32.exee
ऐसे टूल्स का यूज़ करके यहां पे ये अटैक
किए जाते हैं। जैसे कि पावर शेल.exc विद
इनकोडेड कमांड मतलब कोई इनकोडेड कमांड इन
कमांड को इनकोड कर दिया गया है। इन या
इंक्रिप्ट बोल दो इनकोड मोस्टली इनकोड
बोलेंगे। एंड फिर जो है पावर शेल के साथ
फ्यूज करके और उसको एग्जीक्यूट कराया जा
रहा है। तो ऐसे को हम लॉल बींस लिविंग ऑफ
द लैंड अटैक्स कहते हैं। जिसमें एक
लेजिटमेट सॉफ्टवेयर का यूज़ करके उसके अंदर
जो है कमांड्स इनकोड करके और उसको
एग्जीक्यूट करा के फिर कॉम्प्रोमाइज किया
जाता है सिस्टम को। अगर हम प्रोसेस
इन्वेस्टिगेशन फ्लो की बात करें तो एसओसी
स्टेप्स की बात करें तो सबसे पहला काम
होता है प्रोसेस को आइडेंटिफाई करना।
दूसरा काम होता है पैरेंट प्रोसेस को चेक
करना। फिर कमांड लाइन को चेक करना। फिर
यूजर के कंटेक्स्ट को चेक करना। फिर
नेटवर्क की एक्टिविटी को चेक करना। फिर
लॉग्स के साथ कोरिलेट करना या दूसरे जो
लॉग्स हैं उसके साथ को-रिलेट करना। ये
एसओसी के स्टेप्स हैं। जब भी आप कोई
प्रोसेस इन्वेस्टिगेशन कर रहे हैं। कोई
प्रोसेस पे आपको डाउट है, कोई
इन्वेस्टिगेशन कर रहे हैं तो उसमें ये
स्टेप्स एसओसी एज एसओसी एल1 आपको लेना है
कि आप प्रोसेस को आइडेंटिफाई कीजिए।
प्रोसेस के पैरेंट प्रोसेस को चेक कीजिए।
कौन सा पैरेंट प्रोसेस है? कमांड लाइन चेक
कीजिए कि भैया ये क्या एग्जीक्यूट कर रहा
है? कोई ऐसी कमांड लाइन कोई ऐसा कोई कमांड
एग्जीक्यूट एग्जीक्यूशन हो रही है। यूजर
का कॉन्टेक्स्ट चेक कीजिए कि भैया किस
टाइप का यूजर क्या यूजर कौन एग्जीक्यूट कर
रहा है। नेटवर्क की एक्टिविटी को देखिए
एंड देन को अदर लॉग्स के साथ कोरिलेट
कीजिए। कॉमन अगर रेड फ्लैग्स की बात करें
कि क्या-क्या रेड फ्लैग्स हो सकती हैं? तो
सस्िशियस क्या-क्या रेड फ्लैग्स हो सकती
हैं? तो वर्ड पावर शेल को स्टार्ट कर रहा
है। ये गड़बड़ है अपने आप में। ब्राउज़र
कमांड लाइन को स्टार्ट कर रहा है। सीएमडी
को। अरे भाई ऐसे कैसे? एसबीसी होस्ट
स्पॉनिंग चाइल्ड प्रोसेस मतलब एसबीसी
होस्ट का एक डुप्लीकेट प्रोसेस है और एक
और एसबीसी होस्ट चालू हो गया जिसकी लोकेशन
कहीं और है एक्चुअल जगह पे हो है ही नहीं
ये भी एक सस्िशियस है रैंडम एग्जीक्यूटेबल
फ्रॉम टेम फोल्डर मतलब टेम जो फोल्डर है
आपका जैसे कि
यहां [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] पे परसेंट
टेम लिखेंगे आप टीईएमपी तो ये टेम फोल्डर
को ओपन करेगा जो टेंपरेरी फोल्डर होती है
आपकी कई बार जो अटैकर होते हैं एमलिसियस
हैकर होते हैं वो इस टेंपरेरी फोल्डर में
अपने एक्सप्लइट्स को प्लांट कर देते हैं
और यहां से उसको एग्जीक्यूट कराते हैं। तो
अगर यहां पे कोई ऐसी मलेशियस सीएक्स फाइल
या कोई भी एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल आपको दिखती
है जो आपको मलशियस लग रही है तो समझ जाइए
कि कोई ना कोई आपके सिस्टम में घुसने की
कोशिश कर रहा है। एग्जैक्टली घुस चुका है
वो स्टार्ट हो चुकी है। ठीक है? तो ये एक
रेड फ्लैग है। एसओसी का माइंडसेट क्या
होना चाहिए बीइंग एन एसओसी एल वन? जब भी
आप कोई इस प्रोसेस को देखें तो आप यह मत
बस पूछिए कि व्हाट इज़ दिस प्रोसेस? ये मत
पूछिए बस। ये तो पूछना ही है व्हाट इज़ दिस
प्रोसेस? बट इसके अलावा आप पूछिए व्हाई इज
दिस प्रोसेस रनिंग? क्यों चल रहा है यह?
किसने इसको स्टार्ट किया? अब व्हाट डिड इट
डू नेक्स्ट? आगे ये क्या करने वाला है?
एंड आपको आंसर मिलेगा तब आप एक
इन्वेस्टिगेटर कहलाएंगे एसओसी एल वन
एनालिस्ट कहलाएंगे। अब गाइज़ एवरीथिंग इज़
डन। यहां पे एक और टॉपिक है Windows
सर्विसेस की। क्या बोलती है पब्लिक? शुड
आई कंटिन्यू या शुड आई ड्रॉप इट फॉर द
नेक्स्ट सेशन? आपके ही
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कहने पर मैं आगे करूंगा जो भी आप कहेंगे
बताइए एवरीबडी आई एम टोटली फाइन आप बताइए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कंटिन्यू ्यू पब्लिक ने कंटिन्यू बोला है।
क्या बात है। पब्लिक बड़ा डेंजर होती है
यार। पब्लिक इज डेंजरस। पब्लिक को टेंशन
ही नहीं है यार।
ठीक है भाई पब्लिक। देखो पब्लिक कंटिन्यू
में बहुत लोग मैसेज कर रहे हैं। ठीक है।
लास्ट टॉपिक है ये। 10 मिनट लगेंगे। इट
विल बी ओवर। चलो।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब आते हैं Windows
[हंसी][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
आते हैं Windows सर्विसेस पे। Windows
सर्विसेस क्या होती है? बेसिकली तो देखो
जब हमने टास्क मैनेजर ओपन किया था। तो
यहां पे प्रोसेससेस थे। यहां पे कुछ
परफॉर्मेंससेस होती हैं जिसमें
हार्डवेयर्स के बारे में पता चलता है। CPU
कितना परसेंट यूटिलाइज़ हुआ है? मेमोरी
कितना परसेंट यूटिलाइज हुआ है डिस्क कितना
परसेंट है इथरनेट फिर आपका वाईफाई आपका
जीपीयू जो आपका इंटरनल जीpu है एक्सटर्नल
जीpu है तो जीpu वन आपका इंटरनल यहां पे
बता रहा है जीpu एक्सटर्नल जो है आपका
एनवीडिया GE4 जो है मेरा वो बता रहा है तो
देखो जैसे मेरा अभी रैम है मेमोरी है तो
मेरी रैम कितनी है 32GB की रैम होगी आई
थिंक कहां है भाई
32GB का लगा रखा है मैंने
चार स्लॉट्स हैं रैम के दो मैंने यूज़ कर
रखे हैं एंड दिस इज़ अप्रोक्स यूज़ जो है
9.2GB यूज़ हो रहा है। 22GB लगभग अवेलेबल
है 32GB टोटल यहां पे आपको दिख रहा होगा।
तो ये डिटेल वगैरह बताता है। CPU में बता
रहा है कि मेरा CPU का बेस देखो एक क्लॉक
अच्छी क्लॉक स्पीड CPU लेने का क्या
बेनिफिट होता है। जैसे अगर मैं आपको ना
सेटिंग्स में मेरी CPU की क्लॉक स्पीड
दिखाऊं बेस क्लॉक स्पीड। तो आप देखो
सिस्टम में [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अबाउट में चलते हैं। तो मेरे सिस्टम का
बेस क्लॉक स्पीड क्या है? 2.59 GHz मान लो
2.6 GHz मान लो ओनली 2.6 GHz तो दिस इज़
आल्सो गुड मतलब ठीक है मैनेजेबल है थोड़ा 3
प्लस में रहता तो ज्यादा बेटर रहता बट जब
मैंने ये सिस्टम लिया था उस टाइम पे 2.6
GHz की और क्लॉक स्पीड इतनी काफी थी तो 2
बट ये 2.6 ही अगर रह जाता ना सिर्फ 2.6
GHz रह जाता तो दिक्कत थी तब यह अच्छा
नहीं होता सिस्टम तब आपके सिस्टम हैंग
करते हैं। अगर आपका 32 GB भी RAM हो और
सिस्टम का प्रोसेसर जो है वो अच्छा ना हो।
सिस्टम का प्रोसेसर लेटेस्ट ना हो या
अच्छी जनरेशन का ना हो और उसकी क्लॉक
स्पीड थोड़ी अच्छी ना हो तो आपका सिस्टम
हैंग करेगा। तो हमेशा क्लॉक स्पीड 2.6 2.5
से ऊपर हो या एंड उसके साथ ही वो क्लॉक
ओवरक्लॉकिंग हो सके। यानी वो स्पीड बढ़
जाए। जब भी कोई उस पे प्रेशर पड़े तो अपने
आप को एक लेवल तक उसको इंक्रीस करे। जैसे
कि मेरा सिस्टम क्लॉक हो रहा है। आप देखो
CPU अभी स्पीड 4.32 GHz की है। जबकि इसका
बेस है 2.6 GHz बट ये ओवरक्लॉक हो के यानी
एक बार इसको नॉर्मली बोलो कि इसकी स्पीड
ऑटोमेटिकली ये बढ़ा लेगा अपने लोड के
अकॉर्डिंग। तो इसका भी एक रेंज होता है कि
4.5 GHz तक मैक्सिमम ये क्लॉक कर सकता है।
5 GHz तक क्लॉक कर सकता है। तो अगर ये
क्लॉकिंग है आपके में ओवरक्लॉकिंग आपके
प्रोसेसर में तो अच्छी चीज होती है। तो ये
देखो ये बढ़ा के अपना काम कर रहा है। इसी
पर्टिकुलर सारे ऑप्शंस में एक ऑप्शन होता
है आपका सर्विज का जिसके बारे में हम अब
बात करने वाले हैं। ये सर्विज होती है।
सर्विज के लिस्ट में जितनी भी सर्विज चल
रही हैं आपके Windows में वो सारी लिस्ट
होती है। जितनी भी सर्विज चल रही हैं।
चाहे वह अभी चालू हैं, चाहे वह अभी बंद
है, रनिंग में हैं या रुके हुए हैं, सब
लिस्ट होती है। उन सर्विज से एसोसिएटेड जो
प्रोसेससेस हैं, उनकी पीआईडीस आपको यहां
पे देखने को मिलेंगी। बेसिकली जो भी
सर्विज रनिंग है उनकी ही मोस्टली पीआईडी
दिखेंगी। क्योंकि मैंने आपको पहले ही बोला
था कि प्रोसेस जो होती है वो रनिंग
इंस्टेंस होती है एक प्रोग्राम का एक
सर्विस का। तो सर्विस चलेगी तभी तो पीआईडी
होगी। तो जैसे आप देख सकते हैं जितने भी
सर्विज स्टॉप्ड हैं उनकी कोई भी पीआईडी
नहीं है। बट जितने सर्विज चल रहे हैं उनकी
पीआईडीज आपको देखने को। तो जहां पे आपको
पीआईडी दिख रही है ना वहां पे समझ लो कि
वो रनिंग में है। वो प्रोसेस जो है वो जो
सर्विस है वो रन कर रही है। चल रही है। ये
भी एक तरीका है देखने का। साथ ही में
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आपको यहां पे स्टेटस दिख जाएगा रनिंग
स्टॉप और ग्रुप दिख जाएगा कि किस ग्रुप से
ये बिलोंग करते हैं। तो जो भी यहां पे
सर्विज हैं वो किस ग्रुप से बिलोंग करते
हैं वो आपको दिख जाएगा। ये सारी चीज़ दिख
जाएगी। तो यहां पर अब चलते हैं वापस से
बैक टू द पवेलियन।
Windows [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सर्विज
की बात करें तो Windows सर्विज इज अ
प्रोग्राम दैट रंस इन द बैकग्राउंड। एक
ऐसा प्रोग्राम जो बैकग्राउंड में चल रहा
है उसको हम सर्विसेस बोलते हैं। बिना किसी
यूजर के इंटरेक्शन के। यूजर उससे इंटैक्ट
नहीं कर रहा है। वो बैकग्राउंड में अपना
चल रहा है। ऑफेन स्टार्ट्स ऑटोमेटिकली एट
सिस्टम बूट। जैसे ही सिस्टम बूट करेगा यह
हमेशा जो होते हैं उस पर स्टार्ट हो जाते
हैं। जब भी सिस्टम आपका बूट करेगा मोस्टली
जो है आपका ये ऑटोमेटिकली स्टार्ट हो जाते
हैं सर्विज जो भी सर्विज रिक्वायर्ड है या
ऑटोमेटिक स्टार्टअप में डाले हुए हैं।
सिंपल अंडरस्टैंडिंग की बात करें तो
एप्लीकेशन नीड्स यूजर एंड ये विज़िबल होते
हैं। सर्विसेस रन साइलेंटली एंड
बैकग्राउंड में होते हैं। बस सिंपल सा
मतलब यही होता है आपका कि एप्लीकेशन जो
होते हैं यूजर के द्वारा चला जाते हैं।
दिखते हैं सामने सर्विज बैकग्राउंड में
चलते हैं अपना नहीं दिखते हैं। कुछ लेजिट
सर्विज की बात करें तो Windows की अपडेट
सर्विस यह लेजिट सर्विस है। एंटीवायरस की
सर्विज लेजिट है। प्रिंट स्पूलर प्रिंटर्स
की सर्विज लेजिट है। डीएचसीपी क्लाइंट
सर्विज ये लेजिट है। क्योंकि डीएचसीपी
डायनेमिक जो होस्ट कंट्रोल प्रोटोकॉल ये
सर्विस है। इसी के कारण से आपको जो है वो
आईपीस जो है एलोकेट होती हैं और आपका आप
इंटरनेट चला पाते हो कंप्यूटर। रिमोट
डेस्कटॉप सर्विस रिमोट सर्विज की ये लेजिट
सर्विसेस है। अब सर्विज
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इंटरनली काम कैसे करती हैं यह मैं आपको
बताता हूं। थोड़ा इमेज की क्वालिटी थोड़ी
सी डाउन है बट स्टिल आप समझिए। सर्विस एक
आपका ना एससीएम होता है। सर्विस कंट्रोल
मैनेजर
यह सेंट्रल मैनेजर होता है। सारी सर्विज
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] का सेंटर में
होता है। इसी के थ्रू सब कुछ होता है। अब
एससीएम जो है वो Windows सर्विस इंस्टॉलर
एक होती है। Windows सर्विस कंट्रोलर एक
होती है जो एससीएम से कनेक्टेड है। उसके
बाद Windows सर्विस डेटाबेस होती है और
Windows सर्विसेस इन एग्जीक्यूशन होता है।
चार तरह की यहां पे चीज़ें जो एससीएम से
कनेक्टेड है, कंट्रोल होती है। एक Windows
सर्विस इंस्टॉलर होता है। एक Windows
सर्विस कंट्रोलर होता है। एक Windows
सर्विस डेटाबेस होती है। और एक Windows
सर्विसेस इन एग्ज़क्यूशन
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] होता है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके कोई बात नहीं। नटखट।
अ Windows सर्विस इंस्टॉलर क्या करता है?
ऐड, रिमूव एंड रिपेयर द Windows सर्विसेस।
जितने Windows सर्विज हैं उनको ऐड करना,
रिमूव करना, रिपेयर करना इसका काम है।
Windows सर्विस कंट्रोलर क्या करता है?
कंट्रोल, कॉन्फ़िगर एंड क्वरी या Windows
सर्विस। जितने भी सर्विज हैं उनको कंट्रोल
करना, कॉन्फ़िगर करना, क्वेरी करना, पूछताछ
करना सब इसका काम है। Windows सर्विस
कंट्रोलर का। Windows सर्विस डेटाबेस क्या
करती है? अपडेट एंड क्वरी Windows सर्विज
इनफेशन। जितने भी Windows सर्विस के
इंफॉर्मेशनेशंस हैं उनको अपडेट करना, उस
उससे पूछताछ क्वेरी करना, इंफॉर्मेशन ये
सब काम करता है और Windows सर्विस इन
एग्जीक्यूशन इसका काम होता है कंट्रोल
रिक्वेस्ट्स का। मतलब कि जो भी
रिक्वेस्ट्स हैं जो भी रिक्वेस्ट मतलब हो
रहे हैं उनको पूरा उनके उनका जो कंट्रोल
है वो इनके हाथ में
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] है। Windows
सर्विस एग्जीक्यूशन। इस तरीके से आपका
Windows सर्विस जो है सर्विज जो है वह काम
करती हैं और यह सब जो है मैनेज किए जाते
हैं एससीएम के द्वारा सर्विस कंट्रोल
मैनेजर के द्वारा यानी सर्विस कंट्रोल
मैनेजर जो है वो है हमारा मेन बंदा जो सब
कुछ को मैनेज करता है। ठीक है? अब हम
जानते हैं एससीएम के बारे में। क्या होता
है एक्सैक्टली? सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर
एग्जैक्टली होता क्या है? जो इतना
इंपॉर्टेंट है भाई। एक सर्विस कंट्रोल
मैनेजर Windows सर्विस इंस्टॉलर को मैनेज
कर रहा है। सर्विस कंट्रोलर को मैनेज कर
रहा है। सर्विस डेटाबेस को मैनेज कर रहा
है। सर्विस एग्जीक्यूशन को मैनेज कर सब
कुछ मैनेज कर रहा है। तो अब एससीएम क्या
होता है? सेंट्रल कंट्रोलर ऑफ़ ऑल
सर्विसेस। जितनी भी सर्विज हैं सबको
सेंट्रल में बैठ के एकदम पीएम है। पीएम
सबको कंट्रोल कर रहा है। रिस्पांसिबिलिटी
क्या होती है? सर्विस को स्टार्ट करना इसी
की रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है। स्टॉप करना इसी की
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है। मैनेज करना सर्विस के
स्टेट को इसी की रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है।
सर्विस के डेटाबेस को मेंटेन करना इसी की
रेस्पोंसिबिलिटी। मतलब दुनिया की सब चीजें
इसी की रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है। सर्विस से
रिलेटेड। तो सर्विस का एग्जीक्यूशन फ्लो
कैसे होता है? सिस्टम जब आप बूट करते हैं
सिस्टम बूट एससीएम स्टार्ट हो जाता है।
सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर बोलता है मैं
स्टार्ट। अब एससीएम जो है रजिस्ट्री को
रीड करता है। क्योंकि मैंने आपको पहले ही
बताया था कि रजिस्ट्री में ही सारे
प्रोसेस सर्विसेस प्रोसेससेस जो भी सर्विज
होती हैं उनकी डिटेल होती है। उनको कैसे
एग्जीक्यूट होना है, कैसे काम करना है। तो
रजिस्ट्री को रीड करेगा। उनमें से उन्हीं
के रजिस्ट्री रूल्स के अकॉर्डिंग जो भी
रजिस्ट्री में एंट्री है उसके अकॉर्डिंग
उनको लोड कर देगा एंड सर्विसेस को चालू कर
देगा। दैट्स इट सिंपल सा तरीका है। बूट
एससीएम स्टार्ट एससीएम ने रीड द रजिस्ट्री
सर्विस को लोड किया एंड सर्विस को स्टार्ट
किया। सिंपल
अब वेयर आर सर्विसेस स्टर्ड? अब ये
सर्विसेस स्टर्ड कहां होते हैं? तो
रजिस्ट्री में एक लोकेशन है एचकेएलएम।
ठीक है? एचकेएलएम मशीन वाली लोकल मशीन के
अंदर सिस्टम सिस्टम के अंदर कंट्रोल करंट
कंट्रोल सेट और उसके अंदर सर्विज यहीं पे
सारी सर्विज स्टोर होती है। इसको मैं लाइव
आपको दिखाना अगर चाहूं तो Windows R करके
रजिस्ट्री टाइप कीजिए। रेजिड टाइप कीजिए।
इसको स्टार्ट करते हैं।
एचकेएलएम में चलते हैं। एचकेएलएम यहां पे
एचके एलएम में
सिस्टम में चलते हैं।
करंट कंट्रोल सेट एंड यहां पर सर्विज यह
सारी सर्विज की लिस्ट है यह सर्विस द सेम
थिंग एचकेएलएम सिस्टम करंट कंट्रोल सेट
एंड सर्विज तो हम भी वहीं पे हैं एचकेएलएम
सिस्टम करंट कंट्रोल सेट एंड सर्विज यहां
पे जितनी भी सर्विज हैं वो सारी सर्विज
आपको यहां पे दिख जाएंगी। यहीं पे इसकी
एंट्री होती है। जितनी भी सर्विज देखो यह
बहुत लंबी लिस्ट है सर्विज की सारी सर्विस
आपको दिखी। तो यहीं पे ये सर्विज जो है वो
आपकी स्टर्ड होती है। ठीक है? चलिए ये
आपको समझ में आ गया। अब
ईच सर्विस कंटेन्स सर्विस का नाम जितने भी
सर्विज है क्या होता है? सर्विस का नाम
होता है इमेज पाथ, एग्जीक्यूटेबल पाथ,
स्टार्टअप टाइप क्या है और परमिशंस क्या
है? ये सारी चीजें सर्विज कंटेन करता है।
अब सर्विस के टाइप्स की बात करें तो एक
कर्नल सर्विज होते हैं। फाइल सिस्टम
सर्विज होते हैं। यूजर मोड सर्विज होते
हैं। ये सर्विस के टाइप्स होते हैं। कर्नल
सर्विज में जैसे आपके ड्राइवर्स वगैरह हो
गया यू जो सिस्टम
डिवाइस ड्राइवर्स वगैरह आ गए जो कर्नल
लेवल पे ऑपरेट होते हैं। मतलब तो वो कर्नल
सर्विसेस कहलाते हैं। फाइल सिस्टम सर्विज
में जैसे आपके जो भी फाइल से रिलेटेड
सर्विसेस हैं, डिस्क से रिलेटेड सर्विज
हैं वो सारे फाइल सिस्टम सर्विज। यूजर मोड
सर्विसेस में आते हैं। जो नॉर्मल
बैकग्राउंड सर्विसेस चलते हैं। नॉर्मली जो
यूजर रिलेटेड सर्विसेस जो बैकग्राउंड में
चल रहे हैं, वह यूजर सर्विसेस यूजर मोड
सर्विसेस में आते हैं। तो तीन तरह के
सर्विस टाइप्स होते हैं। कर्नल, फाइल
सिस्टम एंड यूजर मोड सर्विसेस। ठीक है? अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सर्विस के भी
कुछ टाइप्स होते हैं। सर्विस के क्या होते
हैं? टाइप्स होते हैं। अब इन सर्विज को आप
ऐसे भी एक्सेस कर सकते हैं। मैं आपको इसका
एक और तरीका बता देता हूं। हम एक और तरीका
बता देता हूं। इन सर्विज को अ स्टार्ट
करने का एक और तरीका बताता हूं। Windows R
प्रेस करना। सर्विसेस डॉट एमएससी ये टाइप
करना है। सर्विसेस
Windows R ये वाली टाइप सर्विसेस एमmएससी
ये टाइप करके ओपन करोगे ना तो जितनी भी
सर्विज लोकल आपकी सर्विज चल रही हैं लोकल
सर्विज वो सारी यहां पे दिख जाएंगी। तो
यहां पे आपको दिख रहा होगा सर्विस का नाम
इनकी डिस्क्रिप्शन इनके बारे में डिटेल।
ये देखो यहां पे जैसे कि कोई सर्विस है
मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं।
डीएससीपी क्लाइंट तो क्या है? रजिस्टर्स
एंड अपडेट्स IPपी एड्रेससेस एंड डीएनएस
रिकॉर्ड्स फॉर दिस कंप्यूटर। इफ दिस
सर्विस इज़ स्टॉप्ड दिस कंप्यूटर विल नॉट
रिसीव डायनेमिक आईपी एड्रेसेस एंड डीएनएस
अपडेट्स। इफ दिस सर्विस इज़ डिसेबल्ड। एनी
सर्विसेस दैट एक्सेप्ट डिपेंड ऑन इट विल
स्टार्ट टू फेल। तो यहां पे सर्विस का
डिटे डिस्क्रिप्शन रहता है। स्टेटस दिखाता
है कि रनिंग है या नहीं। स्टार्टअप टाइप
दिखाता है। स्टार्टअप टाइप में डिफरेंट
टाइप के स्टार्टअप टाइप्स होते हैं। जैसे
कि एक ऑटोमेटिक होता है। एक ऑटोमेटिक
डिलेड स्टार्ट होता है। तो डिलेड थोड़ा
स्टार्ट करना। एक मैनुअल और डिसेबल्ड। तीन
तरह के होते हैं। ऑटोमेटिक, मैनुअल,
डिसेबल्ड। तो, एक मैनुअली मैनुअल कीजिएगा।
मतलब मैनुअली आप इसको स्टार्ट स्टॉप
करेंगे। डिसेबल मतलब बंद कर देना।
ऑटोमेटिक मतलब ये ऑटोमेटिकली अपना
कॉन्फ़िगर रहेगा अकॉर्डिंग टू जो भी इसकी
रिक्वायरमेंट है सिस्टम के अकॉर्डिंग
करेगा। और लॉक्स ऑन एज। तो, लॉग इन कैसे
हुआ? लोकल सर्विस। तो, लोकल सर्विज यहां
पे आपकी की तरह यह काम कर रहा है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। तो यहां पर तीन तरह के टाइप्स होते
हैं सर्विस के स्टार्टअप टाइप्स जो जिस
तरीके से यह स्टार्ट होते हैं। एक
ऑटोमेटिक तो ऑटोमेटिक का मतलब है ये बूट
पे ऑटोमेटिकली स्टार्ट होगा। जब भी आप
सिस्टम को स्टार्ट करेंगे मैनुअल जब आप
चाहिए तब स्टार्ट कीजिए मैनुअली खुद से
एंड डिसेबल्ड मतलब कैन नॉट स्टार्ट। ये
बंद इसको बंद कर दिया गया है। अब इसी में
एक सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट सर्विस है svc
होस्ट.acc जिसके बारे में मैंने पहले भी
आपको बताया हुआ था। पहले ही बोला था कि
sबीc होc जो प्रोसेस है बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है एंड डेंजरस है इंटरेस्टिंग
है ये क्या होता है sबीc होc अ कंटेनर
प्रोसेस दैट रंस मल्टीपल सर्विज एक ऐसा
प्रोसेस है जो मल्टीपल सर्विज को चलाता है
मल्टीपल सर्विज को चलाने के लिए ये
प्रोसेस रिस्पांसिबल है एग्जांपल sबीc
होस्ट होस्ट्स मल्टीपल सर्विसेस मल्टीपल
सर्विसेस को चलाता है एसओसी के लिएेंस
क्यों है आप एसओसी एल1 के लिए क्योंकि
मैलवेयर्स जो है वो sबीc होस्ट में हाइड
कर सकते एंड थोड़े डिटेक्शन में हार्ड होते
हैं। डिटेक्ट करना मुश्किल हो जाता है
क्योंकि यहां पे मल्टीपल सर्विज चल रही
हैं। तो इनको बहुत आसान हो जाता है एज अ
मालवर इनको हाइड करना अपने इनमें हाइड हो
जाना और डिटेक्ट होना उतना ही मुश्किल हो
जाता है। तो sबीc होस्ट हमेशा अटैकर्स का
फेवरेट एक आपका प्रोसेस होता है टू अटैक
ऑन। ठीक है? होप यू आर गेट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अगर सर्विज [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
वर्सेस प्रोसेससेस की हम बात करें तो फीचर
में हम बात करें तो यूजर इंटरेक्शन में
प्रोसेस का यूजर इंटरेक्शन से मतलब है
सर्विस का कोई यूजर इंटरेक्शन नहीं है।
रंस में अगर बात करें तो ऑन डिमांड
प्रोसेस रन हो सकते हैं। सर्विज
बैकग्राउंड में जनरली रन होती है।
पर्सिस्टेंस की बात करें तो प्रोसेस में
पर्सिस्टेंस बनाना मुश्किल है थोड़ा।
सर्विसेस में पसेशन बनाना कंपेरेटिवली इजी
है। तो यह प्रोसेस वर्सेस सम अब कॉमन अटैक
टेक्निक्स की बात करें फॉर सर्विसेस तो एक
मलशियस सर्विस इंस्टॉलेशन होता है। सर्विस
हाईजैकिंग होती है। प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
वाया सर्विसेस होती है। पर्सिस्टेंस होता
है। ये अटैक होते हैं और भी इसमें होते
हैं बहुत सारे लेकिन फिलहाल हम चार ही
देखेंगे। मलेशिया सर्विस इंस्टॉलेशन का
मतलब है कि कोई सर्विस नेम है अपडेट
सर्विस पाथ जो है इसका मैलवेयरx दे दिया
मतलब ये सर्विस चल रही है अपडेट सर्विस बट
ये एक्चुअली ये मलेशियस है तो इसको होस्ट
कहां किया गया है टेम डायरेक्टरी में
malvware extxc नाम से एक फाइल है वो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] चल रही है लेकिन
सर्विस का नाम है अपडेट सर्विस तो ऐसा लग
रहा है कोई अपडेट वाली सर्विस है जेन्युइन
है बट यहां पे [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
मलेशियस सर्विस है जिसका इंस्टॉलेशन की जा
रही है लुक्स लेजिट बट इज़ मैलवेयर लेजिट
तो है देखने में बट मैलवेयर है सर्विस
हाईजैकिंग रिप्लेस पाथ ऑफ़ एकिस्टिंग
सर्विस जैसे अब कोई लेजिट सर्विस है कोई
सर्विस है मान लो winwd exc तो रिप्लेस्ड
विद malware exc winwd exc को malware exc
से रिप्लेस कर दिया गया तो लेजिट सर्विस
की जगह एक मलेशिया सर्विस चलने लगेगी
प्रिविलेज [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एस्केलेशन वाया सर्विसेस इसका मतलब इफ
सर्विस रंस एज सिस्टम अटैकर गेट्स एडमिन
एक्सेस अगर कोई सर्विस है उसको एज अ
सिस्टम या एज अ एडमिन चला रहा है कोई या
चलाया जा रहा है यूज़ किया जा रहा है तो वह
अटैकर को एडमिन एक्सेस दे सकता है। तो कोई
भी ऐसी सर्विस जो कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो सकती है
इली
उसको एज अ एडमिन यूज़ करना सही नहीं है।
हालांकि जितने भी ऐसे क्रिटिकल सर्विज हैं
उनको एज अ एडमिन यूज़ करना बिल्कुल भी सही
नहीं है। इट लैक्स सिक्योरिटी
पर्सिस्टेंस मैलवेयर इंस्टॉल सर्विस रंस
एट एव्री रिपोर्ट। मतलब कोई मैलवेयर है।
उन्होंने कोई एक सर्विस इंस्टॉल कर दी है
कंप्यूटर पे आपके और वह हर रिबूूट पे
ऑटोमेटिकली स्टार्ट हो रही है। तो
पर्सिस्टेंस उसको मिल चुका है। तो जब भी
आप सिस्टम रिबूट करेंगे वापस से वो मेल
स्टार्ट हो जाएगा। जब भी सिस्टम रिबूट
वापस तो ये चेंज चलता रहेगा। राइट?
यह चीजें होती है।
अब रियल एसोसिएट सिनेरियो की बात करें
यहां पर तो लॉग्स में मान लो 4624 है तो
लॉग इन वाला लॉग है। 468 है तो पावर सेल
एग्जीक्यूशन चल रही है। 7045 है। न्यू
सर्विस जो है इंस्टॉल की गई है। तो ये
लॉग्स अगर आपको दिख रहे हैं तो
एसओसी थिंकिंग क्या है आपका? इनिशियल
एक्सेस हुआ है। एग्जीक्यूशन हुई है और
पर्सिस्टेंस हुआ है। ठीक है? मतलब कि
इनिशियल एक्सेस
पावर सेल एग्जीक्यूशन हुआ है और
पर्सिस्टेंस न्यू सर्विस इंस्टॉल हुई है।
पर्सिस्टेंस हो सकती है। तो एज एसओसी आपको
इस तरीके से फेज वाइज सोचना है। फेज में
सोचना है। ठीक है? लाइक ठोक दिया है। थैंक
यू वेरी मच। अब आगे बढ़ते हैं। एसओसी के
स्टेप्स की बात करें। अगर सर्विस
इन्वेस्टिगेशन फ्लो की बात करें तो इसमें
एसओसी के स्टेप्स क्या होते हैं? पहले
सर्विस को आइडेंटिफाई करो। फिर उसका पाथ
चेक करो। फिर चेक यूजर की प्रिविलेज चेक
करो। पैरेंट प्रोसेस चेक करो, रिलेटेड
लॉग्स चेक करो एंड कोरिलेट करो। बाकी
लॉग्स या जो टाइमलाइन है उससे कोरिलेट
करो। कि देखो भैया कि इससे रिलेटेड कुछ और
इनेशन है। तो सबसे पहला सर्विस को
आइडेंटिफाई आपको करना है। कौन सी सर्विस
चल रही है? उसका पाथ चेक करना है। भाई कोई
मलशियस पाथ तो नहीं है। सही तो है। यूजर
की प्रिविलेज चेक करनी है। भैया ये सर्विस
जिस यूजर से स्टार्ट हुई है, वो यूजर का
प्रिविलेज क्या है? एडमिन है तो डेंजरस हो
सकता है। नॉर्मल यूजर है तो ज्यादा डेंजर
नहीं है। इसका पैरेंट प्रोसेस कौन है? कौन
सा इसका पैरेंट प्रोसेस है जो इस सर्विस
से एसोसिएटेड है उससे चेक करो कौन सी
प्रोसेस चल रही है कौन सा प्रोग्राम है
चेक [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] रिलेटेड
लॉक्स से रिलेटेड जितने लॉक्स हैं सबको
चेक करो और कोरिलेट करो अदर लॉक्स के साथ
रेड फ्लैग्स क्या हो सकते हैं डेंजर वाली
घंटी एसओसी के लिए सस्पिशियस क्या हो सकता
है कि न्यू सर्विस अचानक से कोई न्यू
सर्विस को क्रिएट कर दी गई है टेम फोल्डर
से कोई सर्विस चालू कर दिया गया है जो
मैंने बताया था डेंजरस हो सकता है टेम
फोल्डर से अगर कोई सर्विस चालू हो रही है
रैंडम कोई सर्विस नेम आपको दिख रहा है
अपडेट Windows सर्विस। अरे भाई, यह कौन सा
सर्विस है? सर्विस क्रिएटेड आफ़्टर पावर
शेल। मतलब पावर शेल एग्ज़क्यूशन हुई है।
पावर शेल पे कुछ हुआ है। एंड उसके बाद कोई
सर्विस क्रिएट हुई है, कोई कमांड चली है,
सर्विस क्रिएट हुई है, दिस माइट बी द
डेंजरस। ऐसा कैसे हो सकता है? तो एज़ एन
एसओसी L1 आपका [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
माइंडसेट क्या होना चाहिए? जब भी आप कोई
सर्विस को देखिए, तो डोंट द डोंट जस्ट
थिंक दिस इज़ जस्ट अ बैकग्राउंड प्रोसेस।
थिंक ऐसा इज़ दिस पर्सिस्टेंस? क्या यह
पर्सिस्टेंस है सर्विस? इज़ दिस प्रिविलेज
एस्क्लेशन? क्या इसको प्रिविलेज एस्केलेट
किया गया है इसके प्रिविलेज को या इज़ दिस
अटैकर फुट होल्ड क्या यह अटैकर की
जमीनी खेल है क्या ये अटैकर जो है जो बैंड
बजा रहा है हमारी बैंड बजाने की कोशिश कर
रहा है और यहां पे अलग-अलग तरह की चीजें
करने की कोशिश कर रहा है तो ये अपने आप से
आपको एज एन एसओसी पूछना चाहिए कि भैया जब
भी आप कोई सर्विज को देखते हैं तो ये थी
पूरी की पूरी आज की सेशन आज की कहानी एंड
आई होप कि आप लोगों ने अह
आका मोक्ष माल दे मोक्ष मिलेगी अभी मोक्ष
मिलेगी आई होप कि आपको आज मजा आया होगा आज
के सेशन में 31 स्लाइड्स की पूरी ये सेशन
थी थोड़ी लंबी थी आई नो बट स्टिल आई थिंक
इट इट मस्ट बी वर्थ फॉर यू एंड इट मस्ट बी
वर्थ फॉर एवरीबॉडी आपको अच्छा लगा होगा
शायद अगर आपको मजा आया होगा तो ठीक है
अच्छी बात है और जाते-जाते एक लाइक ठोकते
जाइएगा एंड सब्सक्राइब नहीं किया हुआ तो
सब्सक्राइब कर लीजिएगा ऐसे कंटेंट्स के
लिए ऐसे क्लासेस के लिए ट्रेनिंग्स के लिए
लोगों को वीडियो शेयर कीजिएगा। Lindin पे
वीडियोस के लिंक डाल सकते हैं। आप
प्लेलिस्ट के लिंक डाल सकते हैं। कई लोग
Lindin पे पोस्ट करते हैं बट वीडियोस के
लिंक वहां पे नहीं होते। तो लोग कई लोग
समझ नहीं पाते एक्सजेक्टली क्या कहां से
ये पढ़ना है। तो लिंक्स जब डालेंगे तो उनको
एक्सैक्टली पता चल जाएगा। वो यहां तक लैंड
हो जाएंगे। तो यू कैन शेयर द लिंक्स। अदर
प्लेटफॉर्म्स पर भी आप कर सकते हैं। यह
आपकी इच्छा है, मर्जी है। आप करेंगे तो
हमारे को सपोर्ट मिलता है। हमें
इनकरेजमेंट मिलती है। अच्छा लगता है।
लोगों तक जब हम पहुंचते हैं मैक्सिमम
लोगों तक पहुंचते हैं। सो इट फील्स गुड।
सो आज का सेशन इतना ही। इसको हम एंड करते
हैं। उसके पहले टॉप फैंस के लिस्ट मैं
यहां पे एक बार स्क्रॉल डाउन कर देता हूं
यहां पे। तो आप देख सकते हैं टॉप फैंस के
लिस्ट में। तो सबसे ऊपर पीतांबर और रोबोट
जी हैं। आदित्य भी हैं। इन लोगों को तो
मैं इन लोगों को मैं देखता हूं कंटिन्यू
रहते हैं ये लोग। फाइनेंस और ये जगतगुरु
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आदित्य सिंह ठीक
है गुड सुजोए भूत भांग भूतभांग इनका नाम
यूनिक है तो याद हो गया है तो ये हमारे
टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट है एंड आई थिंक मुझे
देखना है अभी कि कौन-कौन है अभी मैंने
बोला था ना कि आज की मैं देखूंगा लिस्ट
में नाम क्योंकि एक बार मैं देख लूंगा ना
तो मेरे दिमाग में रहता है गौरव जांगरा भी
कंटिन्यू रहते हैं सब कंटिन्यू वाले ही
हैं ऑलमोस्ट और दोस्त शालिम ओके
ओके
ठीक है सो देयर आर लॉट ऑफ़ पीपल एंड इनके
नाम मैंने देख लिया थोड़ा कि आज इतनी
देर बाद भी आप लोग टिके रहे ये अच्छी बात
है ऑलमोस्ट 2ाई घंटे की सेशन आज हो हुई
हुई है 7:00 बजे से लेके 9:30 होने वाले
हैं अब ये लंबा सेशन था बट यूज़फुल जरूर था
एंड आई एंजॉयड विद यू गाइस एंड आई होप यू
एंजॉयड दिस सेशन टू यू लर्न समथिंग रियली
एंड मजा आ गया। थैंक यू सो मच गाइस। एंड
सर पूरा एसओसी में स्प्लक एंड अदर टूल्स
हां सब सब टूल आएगा भाई। टेंशन मत लो। जो
भी टूल्स जरूरत हैं जो भी एसआईएम टूल्स
जरूरत है सब आएंगे। टेंशन बिल्कुल नहीं
लेना। ठीक है? न्यू सब्सक्राइबर वेलकम टू
द डिफ्रॉनिक्स अडमी YouTube चैनल न्यू
सब्सक्राइबर्स
अर्जुन। अर्जुन मैंने बहुत लोगों का नाम
नहीं लिया अर्जुन। सबके नाम नहीं ले सकते
हैं। ऑलरेडी बहुत बोल लिया इसलिए ये नाम
नहीं लिया और कोई बात नहीं है। तो आप भी
रेगुलर रहते हैं। बहुत अच्छी बात है।
रेगुलर रहिए अर्जुन।
हां एक क्वेश्चन था सुजॉय का सर डिफरेंस
बिटवीन बग बंटी सीरीज डीसीएपीटी डीएई डीसी
जीएसपी भर डीसी। अरे यार ये कौन सा
क्वेश्चन है? तुमने सारे सर्टिफिकेशन के
बारे में पूछ लिए। चलो इस पे मैं एक
वीडियो ला दूंगा क्योंकि तुमने तो सारे ही
पूछ लिए। बग बंटी की अलग सीरीज है। उसमें
वेब एप्लीकेशन एंड टेस्टिंग आपको कराई गई
है। डीसीएपीटी पूरी पूरी वीएपीटी कवर है।
उसमें सिर्फ वेब एप्लीकेशन नहीं है। उसके
साथ नेटवर्क एपीआई थिक थिन बहुत सारी
चीजें जुड़ी हुई है। तो वो एक अलग चीज है।
डीईएई ईजीपीटी लेवल की सर्टिफिकेशन लेवल
की ये कंटेंट आपको प्रोवाइड करने वाला एक
प्लेलिस्ट है। डीसीजीएसपी एक बिगिनर टू
इंटरमीडिएट लेवल का प्लेलिस्ट है।
रिकॉर्डेड कोर्स है। ओनली 2499 में। आपको
हमारे डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी ऐप पर भी यह मिल
जाएगा। इसमें जैसे कोई बिल्कुल न्यू कमर
है, बिगिनर है या जिसको कांसेप्ट्स
प्रैक्टिकल्स ये सब हैंड्स सब एक साथ
सीखने हैं। बेस स्ट्रांग करना है उसके लिए
तो डीसीजीएसपी इज़ द मस्ट। एंड डीसीएसपी
डीसीजीएसपी का नेक्स्ट एडवांस आपका पाथ
है। जहां पे आप सिक्स मंथ्स की ट्रेनिंग
करते हैं। साथ में पूरी हैकिंग, पूरी
Python, पूरी नेटवर्किंग, प्रोजेक्ट्स इन
सब कुछ आपका होता है। तो, यह सारी चीज़।
बाकी इसके ऊपर एक वीडियो भी ला दूंगा मैं।
ठीक है?
शुरू कहां से करूं इस चैनल के वीडियो से?
आपको मैं रिकमेंड करूंगा कि स्टार्ट विद द
काली लinक्स एंड द नेटवर्किंग सीरीज
प्लेलिस्ट में एंड उसके साथ फिर बग बंटी
डीएचई एंड एसओसी ये है आपका। ठीक है? ओके।
सो आज के इस सेशन के लिए बस इतना ही गाइस।
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में। बहुत जल्द।
आपको रिसोर्सेज जो है ग्रुप में मिल
जाएंगी। सोशल मीडिया हैंडल्स को फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा। एंड वी विल बी मीटिंग इन द
नेक्स्ट सेशन वेरी सून। आई होप कि इस सेशन
को थोड़ा सा कवर करने में आपको थोड़ा टाइम
लगेगा। तो प्लीज कवर कर लीजिएगा
जल्दी-जल्दी। जितना जल्दी हो सकता है। एंड
नोट्स बना के सब कुछ करके Lindin पे भी
शेयर कर दीजिएगा। सो दैट्स ऑल फॉर टुडे
सेशन गाइस। थैंक यू वेरी मच फॉर जॉइनिंग।
हैव अ गुड नाइट। शुभ रात्रि एंड मजे से
डिनर कीजिए। जिनको डिनर करना था,
जिन्होंने खाते-खाते बैठे-बैठे कर लिया
अच्छी बात है। जिन्होंने ऑलरेडी कर लिया
है, मजे कीजिए। थैंक यू वेरी मच। बाय-ब
टेक केयर। गुड नाइट। शुभ रात्रि।